AHEAD AND GET STARTED WITH
TODAY'S BUDGET THE FIVE. PUBLIC
SAFETY HEARING. I HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO RETURN DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
INSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY FOLLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THIS QUESTION.
TODAY IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT. IN PERSON HEARING WE
CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW
MEMBERS AND MINIMAL CONTENT IN
A STAFF. AND A VERY LIMITED
NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO
WE CAN KEEP SIX FEET OF SPACE
IN THERE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
THIS NOTHING PROTOCOLS. FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITOL FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. OUR STATE
DOESN'T PUBLIC COME AGAINST BUT
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WHICH SPEAK THEY WILL
RAISE THEIR HAND AND I WILL ASK
THEM TO PUT THE MICROPHONE.
WILL ALSO HELP OF THE COMMON WE
GET TELEPHONE. WILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER WE'VE FOR ALL
ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. I
WOULD AFFECT THE PUBLIC RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISTANCE THEME. AND DO
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
YOU'LL EACH HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE THEIR
PUBLIC COMMUNIST ON. A RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT BUT PLEASE OBSERVE
PHYSICAL THIS NOTHING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING- THE ELEVATOR USED TO
TWO PEOPLE AT A TIME. THE
PANELISTS ARE APPEARING ANIMAL
IT TODAY. I ASK THAT EVERYONE
SILENCE ELECTRONIC DEVICES AND
HELP FEED THEMSELVES AND PLEASE
BE THEMSELVES WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING. WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT. ITEMS FROM THE MAY
REVISE- THE STATE'S SURPLUS
RIGHT THERE STARK OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIANS THAT HAVE BEEN THE
HARDEST HIT BY THE PANDEMIC IN
THOSE UNDER INVESTED
COMMUNITIES. THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED UP IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LIKE MINE.
WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE PRUDENT
FIDUCIARIES TOWARDS WHICH MEANS
INVESTING FOR THE LONG TERM
INVESTING IN THE MOST CRITICAL
AREAS THAT IMPACT PEOPLE'S
LIFE. HEALTH SAFETY WELFARE AND
AVOID WASTE THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION INCLUDES MANY PUBLIC
SAFETY PROPOSALS. THAT EVENTS
OF BOTH THE GREATER COMMUNITY
SAFETY MORE SERVICE THIS
PROJECT THE SYSTEM INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS SUPPORTING
SURVIVORS OF CRIME AND
STRAIGHTENING THE STATE'S
RESILIENCY AGAINST FEDERALIST
AFTERS. WE'LL BE HEARING FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
ALL OF THESE PROPOSALS TODAY.
WE HAVE HAD MANY PROPOSALS
TOGETHER TODAY AFTER THE DEALER
FOR CENTS ON EACH PROPOSAL THE
L. A. O. WILL PROVIDE ANY
COMMENT THEY MAY HAVE ON THAT
PROPOSAL. WILL PASS THROUGH
QUESTIONS FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AFTER EACH PANEL FINISHES. IN
THE CASE OF THE DEPARTMENTS.
THAT HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS I WILL PASS BETWEEN
GROUPINGS A PROPOSAL TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. AS WE- AS WE LOOK.
AS WE ENGAGE IN THE DISCUSSION
AND WE HAVE THIS SURPLUS THAT
IS A BLESSING IT'S ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO IMAGINE
HOW WE CAN SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES BETTER HOW WE CAN
MOVE THE STATE FORWARD THROUGH
THE RECOVERY- AND HOW WE CAN
ENSURE WE ACTUALLY HAVE ONE
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WORKING FOR
EVERYONE AND NOT JUST FOR THOSE
BORN IN THE RIGHT SUPPORTER
WITH THE RIGHT INTENSITY OUT
THERE. ARE IN THE EXCITED FOR
TO THIS DISCUSSION. DO ANY OF
MY- COMMITTEE MEMBERS WANT TO
SAY ANYTHING BEFORE WE GET
STARTED. OKAY THEN AND WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
WITH OUR FIRST PANEL- WE HAVE
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT. AND SO
THEY BATES NAY MAY BEGIN. BUT
BENCHER MEMBERS MY NAME IS LAW
ORDER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCED BY THE FIRST PROPOSAL
FOR A MILITARY PARK CAPPELLI
PROPOSAL RELATED TO THE
CONSOLIDATED HEADQUARTERS
COMPLEX. PHOTOS REQUEST FOR
SUPPER APPROPRIATION FOR TWENTY
FIVE MILLION EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND FOR THE
DIVINE DESIGN BUILD PHASE OF
THIS PROJECT. SO WE ARE BROUGHT
TO. THE RECENT CHALLENGES OF
THIS PROJECT HAS HAD BEFORE AN
EARLIER MEETING. THESE FUNDS
WILL HELP TO STEER THE PROJECT
BACK ON TRACK AND MAINTAINING
THE TRAJECTORY TOWARDS
COMPLETION AND THAT INCLUDES A
FUNDS FOR OVERSIGHT FROM BOTHA
TGS AND FROM INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE- PROJECT IS COMPLETED. JUST
THE FIRST PROPOSAL THE SECOND
PROPOSAL IS A REQUEST FOR TWO
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND. BUDGET YOUR TWO
POINT EIGHT NINE ON. TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ONGOING
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES FOR
THE MILITARY OUR- RESOURCES
MORE HANDS THE CURRENT.
LOGISTICAL AND ADVANCES GOAL.
SUPPORT FUNCTIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT THESE RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED BECAUSE- IN ADDITION TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF. CLAIMS
THAT THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
DISASTERS AND THE LENGTH OF
TIME BUT THE- SERVICE MEMBERS
NEEDED HAS INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY SO THIS. CONTINUE
TO- THE THIRD PROPOSAL IS FOR
THE MOST ALAMEDA SEVEN REGIONAL
HEADQUARTERS OPERATIONS CENTER
ANOTHER APPLE OUTLOOK AND THIS
IS A REQUEST RIVER- SOME
UNEXPECTED FUNDING FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF CONSTRUCTION I
DO TO THE DISCONTINUATION OF
THE PROJECT SO- THERE BEEN
MULTIPLE BARRIERS IN DEVELOPING
AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
STATE THAT TO US. TO ALLOW FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THIS
FACILITY AND SO- ENTERED THE
PROJECT WILL BE DISCONTINUED
THESE FUNDS ARE NO LONGER
NEEDED. SO FOURTH PROPOSAL IS
A- DEFERRED MAINTENANCE REQUEST
BUT IT IN THE AMOUNT OF FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
A ONE TIME WITH THE IDEA THAT
IT WOULD BE ENCUMBERED IT. OVER
A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME TO
ALLOW FOR IT TO BE EXPENDED AND
TIMELY MATTER AND I'M- HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND THE
NUMBERS MAY HOUSE. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE BEGIN ON THE
SIDE OF. THE PANEL. BORN
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE WE
DID NOT RAISE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THESE PROPOSALS. OKAY I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
FIRST I ITEM. RIGHT THANK YOU
THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
TO. TOTAL TOUR IN AB HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE MY START. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SYDNEY TANIMOTO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY REQUESTED
RESOURCES TOTALING THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
NINETEEN POSITIONS AS FAR AS
THE GUNS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AFTER HELPFUL AND PUT IN
THE LEGISLATURE. AND A WIDE
RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY HAS MODIFIED
THE BCP TO RESTRUCTURE THE
OFFICE AN ADJUST STAFFING
LEVELS TO FILL THE MISSION I
RECOGNIZE THE CONCERNS WHICH
HAVE BEEN RAISED. IN A REVISION
INCLUDES A REQUEST FOR AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY PERMANENT
POSITIONS FOR A TOTAL OF THIRTY
THIRD 33% SESSIONS AND SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
POINT TWO. THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL SUPPORT
COLLABORATION WITH COMMUNITY
PARTNERS INCLUDING POLICY
EXPERTS. CAN MEET BASED
ORGANIZATIONS COUNTY AS A
PROBATION TO MOVE TOWARDS
IMPROVE SERVICE CONTINUE AFTER
JUSTIN JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH.
IN A REVISION PROPOSAL
EXPANSIVE POLICY UNIT AND THE
COUNTY COORDINATION UNIT AS
WELL AS WITH THE- CREATING A
SEPARATE OMBUDSPERSON YEAR TO
EXPAND STOPPING TO RESPOND TO
COMPLAINTS AND SEE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS. THERE'S AUTHORED
FOR CONTRACT FUNDS TO IDENTIFY
TRAUMA RESPONSIVE CULTURALLY
IMPROVED INFORMED MODELS OF
CARE AND BEST PRACTICES FOR
SERVING JUSTICE INVOLVED YOUTH.
I AM JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE
MISS WELSH THAT CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY ARE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. WE'RE PARTICULARLY THE L.
A. L. JOINT STATE WE HAVE AN
OPERATIONS OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU REPEAT THAT PLEASE.
THIS IS THE CASE LARA AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE NOT RAISED CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL. OKAY- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HAVE A
QUESTION I DO APPRECIATE THAT-
THE AMOUNT HAS DOUBLED FROM
THREE POINT FOUR TO SEVEN POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION TH. YES THIS
QUESTIONS THE APPROXIMATE.
NUMBERS WITH THAT WAS CLOSER TO
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS AND SO
CAN YOU GIVE US A LITTLE
INSIGHT INTO. HOW YOU. COME TO
THE CONCLUSION. THAT THIS IS
THE ADEQUATE AMOUNT. SURE I'M
HAPPY TO GIVE A HIGH LEVEL AND
THEN I WOULD INVITE MY
COLLEAGUES AS WELL AS TO EXPAND
A LITTLE BIT. SO BE IT AND
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE REALLY
TO ENHANCE THE POLICY UNIT THAT
COUNTY IN COORDINATION UNIT.
AND THE- CREATING AN OFFICE OF
THE OMBUDSPERSON BUT IF
MISSPELLED LIKE THAT FURTHER
AND PROVIDE MORE DETAILS THAT
SHOULD. SURE YES I YOU KNOW I
THINK THERE'S A REALLY
CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS THAT
HAPPENED WITH THE ADVOCATES
BETWEEN THE TIME WE WERE HERE
LAST I THINK IN EARLY MARCH-
AND TODAY AND- ONE OF THE THERE
WERE TWO DIFFERENT MODELS THAT
THEY SHARED WITH US- ONE WAS
LOOKING AT TEXAS AM AND THE
OTHER WAS- HERE IN CALIFORNIA
OUR OWN FOSTER CARE ARMS
PERSONS OFFICE. I GUESS THE
DISTINCTIONS THAT I WOULD SHARE
IS THAT FOR THE TEXAS MODEL-
THERE REALLY IS A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITIES AROUND
FACILITY OVERSIGHT OF WHICH IS
A RESPONSIBILITY THAT IN OUR
SYSTEM IN OUR STATE IS. IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE SEC I
THINK WHERE WE REALLY WANTED TO
INVEST- WAS ONE TO CREATE A
SEPARATE UNIT AT BEYONCE
PERCENT WHICH INCLUDES THE UNIT
CHIF THAT REPORTS TO A NEW
DEPUTY DEPUTY DIRECTOR THAT
REPORTS TO THE- EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. AND I THINK THAT THAT
ALLOWS US TO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO RESPOND TO CALLS AND MAKE
THOSE REFERRALS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE FOR THAT ROUGHLY TEN
THOUSAND YOUNG. PEOPLE WHO WILL
BE. PAGE TEN AT IN OUT OF HOME
PLACE- WOULD BE THIS OF THE
ALMOST PERSONS. AND SO- I THINK
THAT WITH THAT IS THAT ALSO
SOMETHING THAT WAS REALLY NEW
AND I THINK THIS IS REALLY JUST
GETTING FEEDBACK IN TALKING TO
SOME OF OUR LOCAL IMPLEMENTERS
WAS. THE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR CON.
TRACT FUNDS AND- YEAH THESE
ARE- IN MANY CASES.
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE NEED TO
EITHER ENHANCE IN COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE THEM WHAT IS
SUPPORT- OUR LOCAL.
IMPLEMENTERS TO WORK REGIONALLY
NEEDS TO HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
DO SOMETHING NEW AND INNOVATIVE
THINGS AND SO I THINK WE ARE
ALL SET- WE REALLY WANT TO
FOCUS ON BEING ABLE TO GIVE
DIRECTLY PROVIDE. THE KINDS OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT WAS
NEEDED. TO SUPPORT OF THE-
POPULATION. I'M SO THANKFUL FOR
THAT BACKGROUND OF HOW YOU. GOT
TO THIS CONCLUSION AS I'M NOT
THERE THE SECOND EXAMPLE IN THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON ALSO. OUT
THERE AND THE NUMBER YOU'RE
LOOKING AT WHEN WE LAST SAW
THIS WAS CLOSER TO. THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS- AND I'M NOT
SURE HOW MANY FOR EXAMPLE I'M
NOT SURE HOW MANY RESOURCES WE
HAVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT- IN THIS. PART OF
HORSERACING BOARD WITHIN THAT
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY WHICH IS TWICE THE
AMOUNT FOR THIS OFFICE OF YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION
ITSELF- SO I WAS. PLEASED TO
SEE THAT. YOU THERE IS AN
INCREASE I STILL QUESTION WHY
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT IS SO LOW- AT
THIS MOMENT WHEN THE ADVOCATES
HAVE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR AN
OFFICE WITH MORE ROBUST- FOR
THESE KIDS. FOR THIS YOUTH. I
THINK AT THIS POINT. DO YOU
FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THE
PROVISIONS AND THE TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
CONTRACT DOLLARS WILL GIVE US
THE CAPACITY TO SUPPORT THE
SUCCESS. OF THE OFFICE. K. WILL.
WE HAVEN'T HAD ENOUGH TIME TO
DIGEST THIS ITEM WILL CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT IT BUT I AM. THIS MY
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS YOU KNOW A
LITTLE PERPLEXED BY. BUT
REPUBLICAN WE HAVE A SEVENTY
FIVE BILLION SURPLUS THAT WE
DIDN'T GET CLOSER TO THE
RECOMMENDED NUMBER OUT THERE
TWENTY MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I WE'RE LOOKING AT
ITEM NUMBER. TWO I THINK WHEN
WE AN INCH EXCUSE ME IF WE CAN
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY NO I SAY WE
DID THE ENTIRE PANEL HERE TO
GET A BREAK DOWN OF EXACTLY-
WHAT YOU PLAN TO DO AND HOW YOU
PLAN TO SERVICE. THESE YOUTH-
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE- WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT- SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION THAT IS THAT
THE NEW NUMBER- TO BE ABLE TO
RUN A SPACE STATEWIDE PROGRAM.
WITH FORTY MILLION PEOPLE I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY USERS HOW
MANY DIFFERENT AREAS- HOW MANY
YOUTH FACILITIES ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
HOW CAN YOU EFFECTIVELY OF NOT
ONLY MONITOR FOR MAKE SURE
THAT- THE DOLLARS SPENT AND
WE'RE TALKING A LOT OF MONEY
GOING INTO DJJ- THAT IT'S THAT
NOW IS IT SPENT WISELY. EXCUSE
ME WHAT IS SPENT EFFECTIVELY-
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANNA COME
BACK HERE EACH YEAR TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS OUT AND WE ARE
YOUNG PEOPLE. ARE BEST FIRST
EFFORT AT GETTING THIS RIGHT
NAY AT THE HOPEFULLY THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING. FROM FROM-
THIS PANEL FROM EVERYBODY HERE
AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
ALMOST BIPARTISAN IN IN A LOT
OF WAYS THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE DO THE BEST FOR OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE. AND YOUR EYES AND
EARS. AT THE END OF THE DAY-
WITH WITHOUT YOU- WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO LISTEN TO. REPORTS
FROM- FROM INDIVIDUALS THAT IN
THE SYSTEM- INDIVIDUALS THAT
THEY GET OUT OF THE SYSTEM AND
WE NEED TO KNOW THE TRUTH OF
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON- IN A
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM BECAUSE
THAT'S THAT'S THE BEST WAY WE
DID CAN SUPPLY EVEN MORE
SUPPORT- IT YOU KNOW IT WOULD
BE A CRIME IF. AFTER TWO YEARS
YOU COME BACK AND SAY YOU KNOW
WHAT WE REALLY NEEDIT SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS OR WE REALLY
NEEDED OF MUCH MORE THAN THAT
RENDON DAN WHAT WE GET HERE AND
I KNOW ITS ONGOING COSTS AND-
WE WHO CAME HERE IN TWENTY
TWELVE. NO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU SPEND TOO MUCH AND ONGOING
COST SO I CAN. I CAN APPRECIATE
THAT. BUT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT- WE NEED TO WRAP UP RIGHT
THE FIRST TIME AND SO IF YOU
CAN. I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU CAN
BREAK IT DOWN TO US. THEY GIVE
US SOME- THAT THEY LET US KNOW
WHAT EXACTLY YOU'RE GOING TO DO
WITH THIS MONEY AND BUT MOST
IMPORTANT HOW EFFECTIVE. THIS
WILL BE AN ENSURING THAT- THIS
PROGRAMS WE TAKE IT DOWN. TO
LOWER LOVERS- MOST EFFICIENT.
CORRECT ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT- FOR THE ACTUAL
DELIVERY OF SERVICES THAT IS A
FUNDING SOURCE THAT GOES
DIRECTLY TO THE LOCAL LEVEL-
AND SO I CAN'T BINANCE MIGHT
KNOW SOME OF THE EXACT NUMBERS
BUT IN TERMS OF THAT THAT
RESPONSIBILITY TO. PAY FOR THE
NECESSARY SERVICES TO SUPPORT
THE VIEW THAT BEING SUCCESSFUL
AND HAVE THEM NOT- PRESENTED
THEY CAN GET YOU KNOW FULLY
INTEGRATED BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY. IS NOT THE
RESPONSIBILITY THE OFFICE YOU
WERE CERTAINLY CORRECT IN THAT
IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
OFFICE TO SUPPORT THE SUCCESS
OF. THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THOSE
PROGRAMS TO COLLECT DATA AND
ONE OF THE THINGS WE DID WAS TO
ADD SOME ADDITIONAL IN HOUSE
RESEARCH CAPACITY. AS WELL AS
SOME STAFF THAT WOULD HAVE.
PROGRAM LEVEL OF EXPERTISE AND
BEST PRACTICES AROUND JUSTICE
AND- THANK YOU IN SERVICE THAT
TYPE PROGRAMS- BUT AGAIN- JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT WAS
CLEAR THAT CRITICS FOR THE FOR
THE REALIGNED YOU- THAT THE
RESOURCES TO. TO PROVIDE DIRECT
SERVICES TO THEM WHAT WOULD BE
GOING THROUGH IT NEVER ANOTHER
PROCESS- AND SO CERTAINLY-
THAT'S A ROBUST FUNDING SOURCE-
AND OF COURSE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT. THE FUNDS ARE
ACCOMPLISHING GOOD OUTCOMES AND
THAT IS WHY WE WILL BE
REVIEWING PLANS AN ANNUAL BASIS
ALSO. WORKING WITH OUR LOCAL
IMPLEMENTERS AND POTENTIALLY
FOR OUR CONSULTING CONTRACTS TO
EXAMINE DATA SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE. RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
IMPROVED PROGRAMS. SO I'M- NOW
LI COMPUTERS AS TO WHY THIS
DEPARTMENT DOES- OFF TO YOU
THINK COMMUNITY RESTORATION SO
MAYBE THAT THAT MIGHT BE THAT
MAY BE PART OF THE CONFUSION
WE'RE NOT CERTAIN WHAT YOUR
DUTIES AND RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
AND MAYBE WE NEED TO REVISIT
THAT AND MAYBE START FROM THAT.
OF BECAUSE RIGHT NOW I'M I'M
I'M JUST CONFUSED I MEAN IF ALL
YOU'RE DOING IS SHUFFLING
PAPERS LIKE THE B. SEC WHICH
I'M NOT EVEN SURE WE NEED DOWN
THE WIRE WEEK CRAZINESS LAYER
OF BUREAUCRACY AS I SEE BY. MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ACROSS THE
AISLE. LOOKING AT ME WITH HSI'S
THROUGH A WIRE WE CREATING
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING. THAT DOESN'T HELP
MOVE THIS ALONG. IN A SEPARATE
WAY SO IT MAY BE THAT. IT WOULD
REALLY BE GOOD TO TRY TO. TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS. IT THAT
YOU DO. AND WHAT OUTCOMES. THAT
MIGHT BE WHAT OUTCOMES ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO GET FROM THIS THIS
GROUP AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
CONFUSING PART IS RIGHT NOW.
OKAY YEAH WE KIND OF JUST
JUMPED IN ZERO JUST GIVING YOU
THE BASIC UPDATES ON HOW THE
PCP IS DIFFERENT BUT- THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF DELIVERABLES THAT
THIS OFFICE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EXECUTING INTO AND DOING SO
WITH QUALITY IN DOING IT- BY
COMING TO YOU TALK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. SO IN ADDITION TO
REVEALING PLANS WE ALSO HAVE
ANNUAL AND RESPONSIBILITIES TO
FOR EXAMPLE RECORDS ONLINE WHAT
WE ARE HEARING FROM THE LOCAL
LEVEL IN TERMS OF WHAT
INFORMATION WE'RE RECEIVING
THROUGH YOUR ARMS PERSONS UNIT.
WE ALSO WILL HAVE ANNUAL DATA
REPORTS THAT WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE TO SHARE BACK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS A
SPECIFIC- ANALYSIS OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
REALIGNMENTS I BELIEVE THAT'S
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR- AND SO
WE HOPE TO REALLY BE PARTNERS
WITH YOU AND TO USE THAT DATA
MUSCLE. TO COME AND TALK ABOUT
HOW DATA CAN BE USED TO DRIVE
POLICY- AND SO THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE SEE THE FOCUS OF
OUR OTHER OFFICE BEING AND- WE
ALSO HAVE A HEAD OF. THAT
COMMITTEE THAT WE'RE STANDING
UP AND WE ALSO- THAT COMMITTEE
IS PART OF THE CHILD WELFARE
COUNCIL. DOUBLE THAT WHAT WE'RE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH BUT LOOKING
AT THE DATA IS. TO IMPROVE THE
LOCAL LEVEL. OKAY TO. JUST
MAYBE CAN HAVE A BIT A I DON'T
WANT TO BELIEVE THIS HERE.
BECAUSE KEEP SOUND ALIKE TO BE
A C. C. AND IT'S IS NOT A GOOD
THING RIGHT NOW FOR ANY
ORGANIZATION TO COME BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE. REPLICATING THE
B. S. C. C. THIS IS WHAT THIS
KIND OF SOUNDS LIKE AND SO
MAYBE WE CAN HELP YOU- IT IS
MORE ABOUT. THAT SO LET'S. GIVE
YOU A CALL MY OFFICE A CALL THE
CHAIR. OF TO TRY TO FIGURE THIS
OUT. OUR SYSTEM. THANK YOU WELL
I THINK PART OF THE DISCONNECT
IS WHAT WE DON'T HAVE IN FRONT
OF US RIGHT NOW IS THE BIG
PICTURE OF WHAT THE SYSTEM
ULTIMATELY IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE AND THE CONCERN. THAT I
HAVE AND I'M GOING TO REPEAT
MYSELF IS THAT IF WE JUST HAVE
CREATED. THIS REALIGNMENT AS AS
A FUNCTION TO SAVE THE STATE
MONEY AND PUSHED RESPONSIBILITY
THAT THE LOCAL LEVEL THAN THAN.
WE ARE NOT NECESSARILY HEADED
DOWN A PATH THAT WE WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL. BUT WHAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE AND WHAT I THINK.
THIS AGENCY IS CRITICAL FOR IS
ENSURING. THAT IT WON'T MATTER
WHERE. YOUTH IS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH COUNTY OR
WHICH REGION THAT HERE WILL BE
CONSISTENT SET OF OUTCOMES AND
THAT'S WHY THIS AGENCY IS GOING
TO BE SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY'RE GONNA BE PROVIDING. THE
REVIEW THE BEST PRACTICES THAT
THE THINK TANK ENVIRONMENT.
ULTIMATELY TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
AND HELP TO COUNTIES AND
REGIONS TO SERVE YOU BETTER.
AND I STILL THINK OF THIS IS
BEYOND THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE.
THAT WE HAVEN'T THOUGHT. THE
BREADTH OF THIS THROUGH THAT WE
SHOULD BE SETTING UP. A OUR
SYSTEM AGENCY SOMETHING THAT IS
LOOKING OUT FOR ALL KIDS
BECAUSE WE STILL HAVE THE
PROBLEM OF WE'RE STYLING KIDS
IN DEPENDENCY AND DELINQUENCY
THOSE WHO ARE HOMELESS AND
THOSE ARE IN OTHER SITUATIONS
REALLY HAVE NO PLACE TO GO AND
NO NO SERVICES THAT THAT THEY
CAN REAL. REALLY RELY ON AND
WHAT I THINK WHAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS TRIED TO DO WAS
IS ARTICULATE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT IF WE HAD A
STRONGER CENTRALIZED FUNCTION
FOR ALL KIDS THAT PROMISE THE
RIGHT RISK THAT WE COULD HAVE A
STRONGER SYSTEM TO SERVE THE
KIDS BECAUSE WHETHER THEY'RE
HOMELESS OR THEIR INDEPENDENCY
ORIENTAL IN QUINCY THESE ARE
ALWAYS THE SAME KIDS OUT OF THE
SAME COMMUNITIES OUT OF THE
SAME FAMILIES OUT OF THE SAME
SITUATIONS. COMPLICATED BECAUSE
WERE DRIED OUT FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR DIFFERENT PIECES OF THIS
BUT THAT IS SOMETHING. THAT AN
AGENCY LIKE THIS REALLY COULD
HELP SORT OUT AND FIGURE OUT.
SO AS WE DEVELOP THIS. NEW
MODEL OF. HAVING REALIGNED OUT
OF THE COUNTIES AND HAVING
BROUGHT A LOT OF THIS FUNCTION
INTO THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. CAPACITY THAT SHOULD
LEAD US TO DIFFERENT OUTCOMES
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT WE ARE
ABLE TO DO WITH THESE KIDS TO
HELP THEM AND TO SERVE THEM.
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF LARGE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE GOING TO
REMAIN THERE ARE SOME. SOME
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES THAT. DJJ
HAS MADE FOR EXAMPLE IN THE SEX
OFFENDER UNIT. AT HOW THAT GETS
REPLICATED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
OR AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL. I'M
NOT REAL CLEAR ON AND I'M NOT
SURE ANYBODY REALLY IS EITHER
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
DEVELOP THAT CAPACITY. WAR
POTENTIALLY. KEEP SOMETHING
LIKE THAT THE STATE BECAUSE
IT'S NOT THAT MANY KIDS IN FROM
AN EFFICIENCY STANDPOINT I
THINK WE REALLY HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT THE STRUCTURE IS.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE HAS TO BE
HOW WE'RE SERVING KIDS. HOW
WE'RE HELPING THEM SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THAT THEY HAVE FOUND
THEMSELVES IN SO THAT THEY CAN.
FIX WHAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED AND
GET BACK OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
IN THE APPROPRIATE WAY. AND SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT A PIECE OF IT
HERE AND WE HAVE. ASKED FOR.
MORE RESOURCES MORE POSITIONS.
MORE FUNDING TO THIS AGENCY
BECAUSE OF I THINK OUR VISION
FOR WHAT YOU CAN BE FOR THESE
KIDS AND THE CONSISTENCY THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE. REPRESENTING
TH ACROSS CALIFORNIA IS REALLY
GOING TO BE CRITICAL. TO THE
SUCCESS OF THESE PROGRAMS. ROSS
THE STATE THAT'S SORT OF I
THINK YOU'RE HEARING SOME OF
THE UNCERTAINTY HERE BECAUSE-
IT'S HARD TO SEE WHAT. THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE NEEDS TO LOOK LIKE AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT ANYBODY. REALLY
HAS AN ANSWER TO THAT YET AND
UNFORTUNATELY. THAT MEANS WE'RE
GOING TO BE STEPPING THROUGH
AND LEARNING AS WE GO AND
WHAT'S THE IMPACT ON THE KIDS.
IN THE SYSTEM WHO ARE IN THE
SYSTEM NOW AND SOON TO BE IN
THE SYSTEM. THAT THAT'S WHAT'S
CRITICAL IT IS AND IF WE SET UP
THE SYSTEM MORE AS WE EXPLORE
IT. AND WE LEAVE KIDS BEHIND OR
WERE NOT SERVING THEM THAT'S
REALLY GOING TO BE ULTIMATELY
THE TRAGEDY. SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOUR AGENCY IS
FUNDED. APPROPRIATELY TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE BROADER
OVERSIGHT. THE CONNECTIONS TO
HELP. TO ENSURE SUCCESS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND POTENTIALLY
REGIONAL LEVEL BECAUSE NOT
EVERY COUNTY IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO AFFORD. TO IMPLEMENT
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE ASKING THEM
TO IMPLEMENT A WITH THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED TO. DEPENDING ON
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THE KIDS THAT
ARE IN THE- SO I THINK THAT'S
THE- THAT'S THE DISCONNECT IS
WE'RE LOOKING AT A LARGER
SYSTEMS CHANGE. AND KIND OF
PUSHING BACK ON THE
ADMINISTRATION. BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T ALWAYS SEEM LIKE THAT
LEVEL OF SYSTEM CHANGES WHAT IS
BEING TALKED ABOUT BUT THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE VERY INTERESTED IN.
WELL I AM I KNOW. OF IS FIVE
EIGHT. USING SORT OF THE
COLLECTIVE WE HEAR. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS COME FROM THERE WERE
SOME OF THE DISCONNECT COMES
FROM SO FOR US FINDING A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ALWAYS HAVE
THE BIGGER PICTURE. IN MIND AS
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THESE AND
HAVE THAT INFORMATION. SO WHAT
IS THE REST OF THIS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE BECAUSE THEY'RE
SENDING A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITY
IN A LOT OF RESOURCE. DATA
LOCAL LEVEL. AND ENSURING THAT
THOSE LOCAL LEVELS ARE
PERFORMING TO A PARTICULAR
STANDARD. IS THIS AGENCY.
THAT'S WHAT'S ULTIMATELY KEY
HERE M. AND THAT'S WE'RE GONNA
BE TRACKING THAT'S WORKING TO
BE LOOKING TO AND THERE'S
REALLY A LOT AT STAKE HERE FOR
THE FUTURE OF OUR KIDS IF WE
SET THIS UP CORRECTLY. AND IF
WE DON'T IF WE JUST TRY TO SAVE
THE STATE MONEY THEN WE WILL BE
FAILING THOSE KIDS DOWN THE
LINE. THAT'S THE SENSITIVITY
THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THE RIGHT SIZED AT THIS POINT.
AND ARE WE MAKING THE
INVESTMENTS NECESSARY. TO
ENSURE THAT CONTINUITY AND THAT
HELPED. STATEWIDE SO THINK
THAT'S WHERE IT COMES TO AN END
I AM NOT COMPLETELY SURE AS TO
HAVE BEEN TALKING TO MISPRISION
ABOUT THIS ABOUT SOME OF MY
CONCERNS OF IMPLEMENTATION.
BOTH WITHIN THIS AGENCY AND-
KIND OF BIGGER PICTURE WITH A
LOT OF THE- THE SERVICES HAT
I'M NOT SURE HAVE NOT REALLY
BEEN SETTLED ON. HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ENSURE THAT THOSE ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED. ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS. SO WE'VE GOT
WE'VE GOT PIECES OF IT AND
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ONLY LOOKING
AT. A PIECE OF IT BUT WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT HAS THE
CAPACITY. TO BE THAT. OVER
ARCHING. RESOURCE HELP. TO
ENSURE A CONSISTENT APPROACH TO
KIDS ACROSS THE STATE BECAUSE
IF IT MATTERS WHAT COUNTY
THEY'RE IN BUT WHAT REGION
THERE IN FOR THEIR SUCCESS THEN
THIS WILL NOT HAVE BEEN A
SUCCESSFUL EXERCISE. AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ONE OF
COMMENTED MR STONE. COMMENTS.
BUT THE LAST THING THAT I WOULD
SAY I JUST I DIDN'T MENTION IT
TODAY BUT WHEN WE WERE HERE
LAST TIME- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WE HAVE MANY DEPART FRIENDS WHO
AT LEAST FRIENDS LIVE THANK
YOUNG PEOPLE'S LIVES BUT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THEY
HAVE- SO I JUST WANT YOU TO
HEAR THAT IT IS A PART OF OUR
VISION AND OUR COMMITMENT THAT
WE HAVE STRONG PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THOSE AT. ALL WHICH I
THINK MIGHT BE HEADING OUT YEAH
BUT IT'S THAT WE WOULD REALLY
WANT TO DRAW THEM IN AND THAT'S
WHERE WE SEE THE SYSTEMS CHANGE
FEES BECAUSE IT ALSO MEANS WE
CAN DO THINGS BETTER- AS WELL
IN THE WAY THAT WE- ARE WELL ON
OUR PROGRAMS AND SUPPORT OUR
COUNTIES. TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
THAT IN THAT WAY. JUST WANTED
TO SHARE THAT. OKAY WELL
THERE'S NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
YOU KNOW WE LOOK FORWARD TO
KAMALA FOR TO ENGAGE IN WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION. UNDER THAT
THERE'S A REAL OPPORTUNITY HERE
AS WE'RE TRYING TO ENSURE WE
HAVE. A SYSTEM THAT'S EQUITABLE
NO MATTER WHAT COUNTY WHERE
ANYTHING THAT BOTH THE PART OF
MR STONE'S. CONCERNS A SYSTEM
THAT. TRULY HELP OUR YOUTH MEET
THEIR POTENTIAL. OUT THERE- AND
HELPS HELPS THEM I THINK LEASE
TERMS AND YOU SEE YOURSELF.
TRAUMA INFORMED AND WHAT DOES
THAT REALLY MEAN AND IF SO I
THINK WE HAVE A REAL
OPPORTUNITY. TO REALLY START TO
DELVE INTO THAT TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST CHECKING OFF A
BOX THAT MAKES US FEEL GOOD.
WELL WE'RE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT WE HAVE
HERE BOTH WHAT THE LEGISLATION
THAT'S BEEN DONE BUT ALSO WITH.
THE SURPLUS FOR THE BUDGET THAT
YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW TO DO SOME
PROPER INVESTMENTS EARLY ON FOR
THE SUCCESS OF. THE PROGRAM
WHICH IS REALLY FOR THE SUCCESS
OF ALL OF THESE KIDS WITH THIS
WELL WE I THINK HAVE A COMMON
GOAL WITH THAT SO. I WILL MOVE
ONTO THE NEXT ITEM THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME ON THAT- BUT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DISCUSS THAT.
CAN YOU GIVE. ME NUMBERS KEVIN
CLARK WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THEY WERE DISCUSSING
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE WHICH REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
MAINTAIN A DATABASE OF UNSAFE
FIREARMS TRANSACTIONS. THAT ARE
PURCHASED PURSUANT HE STOPPED
THE SEARCH ENGINES. AND ALSO
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE NOTIFICATION TO PERSONS
WHO POSSESS OR MAINTAINING. AND
GUNS AND GUNS. WE ARE CURRENTLY
BEFORE YOU CAN FOR NOW HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
IT REACHES A MAXIMUM OF THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THEN
DROPS TO SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND IN
TWENTY TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN
ONGOING. THE MAJORITY OF
RESOURCES COVER ONE TIMES IT
RELATED COSTS AS WELL AS THE
OLDER PRESENTED WAS THERE
NEEDED. TO AUDIT UNSAFE
FIREARMS TRANSACTIONS RECORDS
THAT FIREARMS DEALERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES STATEWIDE.
I'M JOINED WITH COLLEAGUES FROM
THE APARTMENT BY APARTMENT
JUSTICE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL. I NEED ONLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
ON THIS ITEM WE ARE
RECOMMENDING MODIFYING THE
PROPOSAL TO SHIFT A PORTION OF
THE COSTS TO THE DEALERS RECORD
OF JAIL SHUFFLE CAP ALSO KNOWN
AS ROAST AND THIS IS BECAUSE
THE PROPOSED. SORRY THE
LEGISLATION- HERE SPECIFICALLY
AMENDED STATE LAW TO ALLOW FOR
CERTAIN COSTS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION TO BE COVERED BY
THE FIRE V. REVENUE WHICH
DEPOSIT INTO THE ACCOUNT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ARE THE SENATE
ONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM. WE HAVE.
FOUR L. NUMBER TWO YES SORRY
LOS HAVE AB FIFTEEN L. SIX. IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINE ART. WE
ARE REFORMING FRANCE AGAIN SO
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
INVESTIGATE OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS THAT RESULT IN THE
DEATH OF AN UNARMED CIVILIAN.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED
THIRTEEN MILLION GENERAL FUND
THREE INVESTIGATIVE TEAMS AND
LEGAL RESOURCES AND ALSO
GENERAL OPERATING EXPENSES. AND
THE NEIGHBOR VISION IN
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT THREE
MILLION OR ONE OF THE TIONAL
TEAM. TO BE LOCATED IN THE
SOUTHERN REGION WELL AS THE
VICTIM SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
SURVIVORS OF THOSE KILLED IN
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS. YOU
ALSO KNOW THAT WE CAN CLEAR
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THEIR PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IN. TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. IF
NECESSARY. AND AFTER- BY TO
JOIN LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- AGAIN WE'RE JOINED
WITH COLLEAGUES FROM DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. ANY AVAILABLE CREDIT
ANALYST OFFICE- DO YOU
RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
PROPOSED PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
AS THE BUDGET ALREADY INCLUDES
AN EXISTING PROCESS LAID OUT
IN. ITEM NINETY EIGHT FORGET
THE ANNUAL BUDGET FOR STATE
PROGRAMS TO REDUCE REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR. LATED
AND NECESSARY EXPENSES- AND
SOAK TAKING THIS APPROACH
ALLOWS THE LEGISLATURE. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM
AND TO DETERMINE WHETHER
STATUTORY CHANGES ARE NEEDED.
THE PROGRAMS HIGHEST OURSELVES-
WE KNOW ABOUT THE COPY OF THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL EARLIER THIS
MORNING AND SO ARE STILL ALSO
IN THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING THE
PARTICULAR DETAILS AS WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SO ON THE
FIFTEEN OH SIX ITEM IF WE
ALREADY HAVE A PRODUCT. AND
PLAYS- AND IT ALLOWS THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO ITS JOB AND
HAVE WILL RECITE LIKE WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO. CAN YOU HELP ME
UNDERSTAND WHY WE SHOULD BE
INCREASED OR DECREASED
RESOURCES NOW. KEVIN ARE YOU
MUTED. YEAH THANK YOU SOME OF
THAT ARE YOU SPEAKING TO WHEN
YOU DISCOVER ABOUT THE NINETY
EIGHT FORTY PROCESS. YES BUT
YES SIR WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE- DEFINITELY GOT THE
LEGISLATURE PLAYS IN THE
TURNING THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES ARE BORN ACTOR
LEGISLATION LIKE EVEN IF IT'S
NO SIX THERE WERE JUST NOT A
FEW CONCERNS ABOUT THE APPROACH
SUGGESTED BY ELIO- SPECIFICALLY
THE NINETY EIGHT FORTY PROCESS
IS NOT A SURE FIRE MECHANISM TO
ADDRESS ANY AND ALL
UNANTICIPATED COSTS- THE NINETY
EIGHT FORTY PROCESS IS ON A
FIRST COME FIRST SERVE BASIS.
MEANING THAT DOJ IS NOT
GUARANTEED THEY HAVE THEIR.
COSTS COVERED BY THE WILL OF
FUNDING. AND ALSO SECOND NINE
FOUR PROCESS. IS REALLY PER
COSTS THAT ARE AN
UNANTICIPATED. WHICH DOES NOT
APPEAR UPON THIS SENSE- GIVE ME
KNOWLEDGE OF IT MAY BE A
POSSIBILITY. WHAT FUTURE COSTS.
FINALLY THE NINETY EIGHT FORTY
FULL IS REALLY CAPITANI NINE
FOR ALL DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT MAY BE INSUFFICIENT.
FOR THE NEEDS OF YOUR JACK. SO
YOU'RE SAYING THEY ACTUALLY
ANTICIPATE A HIGHER COST. WELL
MATTERS HERE WE GO THE WE HAVE
PROPOSED ORIGINAL LANGUAGE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW PARENTS TO
PROVIDE AN AUGMENTATION THAT
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT SHOULD
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD- ALL RIGHTS.
IT JUST FEELS LIKE YOU'RE
ASKING THIS- NOT DOING ITS JOB
AND JUST TRUST. TRUST TRUST IN
US AND- AND TO THINK THAT I'M
NOT SURE THAT THAT TRUST IS HAS
YET BUT- AND THEN NUMBER TWO I
DON'T THINK THAT ARE VOTERS IT
IS SENT TO. GIVE UP OUR POWER
LIKE THAT. AND SO I DO
RECOMMEND YOU GUYS- RECONSIDER
YOUR APPROACH HERE. TWENTY MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON. OKAY. WE'RE GONNA
GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO PANEL
NUMBER FOR THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ENTER DUFFY DEPARTMENT
FINANCE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY I'M BECAUSE THEY
SHOOT NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT
PROGRAM- BUILDING ON PRIOR
INVESTMENTS MAY REVISION
PROPOSES FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE NONPROFIT SECURITY GRANT
PROGRAM CODIFIED BY AB FIFTEEN
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN- THIS
PROGRAM ALL. IN THIS FUNDING
WILL SYSTEM PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN. IT MOTIVATED
VIOLENCE- THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY CALLAWAY YES
PROVIDES FOR TARGET HARDENING
ANOTHER PHYSICAL SECURITY
ENHANCEMENTS TO NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE AT RISK
OF VIOLENCE AND HATE CRIMES
BASED ON. IDEOLOGY AND THEIR
BELIEFS- FOR THE SECOND AND
THIRD ISSUE. I WILL BE PASSING
IT ON TO MY COLLEAGUE BARBARA
TAYLOR AND I WILL BE TAKING IT
BACK TO THE FOURTH ISSUE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SORRY I SHOULD
HAVE A CONNECTION PROBLEM HERE.
I APOLOGIZE SO FOR THE SECOND
ISSUE THE SOUTHERN REGION
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER-
ACQUISITION REQUEST IN TWENTY
SIX POINT FOUR NINE MILLION FOR
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND- BACK
POSITION THIS WAS- SOMEWHAT
DISCUSSED A FEW MOMENTS AGO
WHEN AND WITH. THE MILITARY
ISSUE WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
RIVER CAN OF THE FUNDS- THIS I
WAS A PART OF IT'S BEEN LONG
TRIED TO DEVELOP A CURRENT
PROJECT THE MILITARY AND- KELLY
THAT'S AND HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
SUCCESSFUL AND SO WE NOT ONLY
A- CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT FOR
THE- TIME. HELLO YES SOUTHERN
EMERGENCY- OPERATIONS CENTER ON
ITS OWN- SO WE ARE REVERTING
THE FUNDS FROM THE MILITARY AND
USING THOSE FUNDS. FOR
ACQUISITION PHASE FOR- THE
SOUTHERN AREA. THE SECOND
ISSUE- IT'S SEVEN POINT SEVEN
THREE MANY SEVEN THREE MILLION
FOR GENERAL FUND FOR LEASE AND
TENANT IMPROVEMENTS AND MOVING
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH IT
TEMPORARY FACILITY WHERE WE
CONSTRUCT THE NEW- SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL OPERATIONS
CENTER- RIGHT NOW THEY ARE
LOCATED- CAL CAL THE WII U'S IS
LOCATED IN A- TEMPORARY SET OF
TRAILERS WHERE THEY HAVE BEEN
FOR SEVERAL YEARS ON THE
MILITARY'S PROPERTY. THOSE
TRAILERS HAVE GONE FONG BEYOND
THEIR- OPERATIONAL LIFE AND
THEY HAVE LEAKS AND RODENT
INFESTATIONS AND- WE REALLY
NEED TO GET THEM OUT OF THOSE
BUILDINGS THOSE TRAILERS AND
INTO OUR MORE APPROPRIATE
FACILITIES. THAT'S BROUGH BUILD
A PERMANENT LOCATION FOR THEM
SO WE'RE REQUESTING FUNDING TO
DO THAT ON A SEPARATE BASIS AND
WILL BUILD THEIR LONG TERM
PERMANENT BASIS BERMAN A
BUILDING FOR THEM. AND WITH
THAT I'LL HAND IT BACK OVER TO-
ENTER AND THAT'S THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. FOR THE
FOURTH ITEM ACCORDING TO FASTER
ASSISTANCE ACT- IT IS A LOCAL
POST THIS. INSTEAD FOCUS
RESOURCES TO LOCAL ENTITIES
REPAIR RESTORE OR REPLACE
REPUBLIC PROPERTY- DAMAGED OR
DESTROYED BY DISASTERS OR TO
REIMBURSE LOCAL ENTITIES FOR-
EMERGENCY. ERNEST'S ORDER
MERGES THE PROTECTIVE MEASURE-
FOSS- AS PART OF A STATE OF
EMERGENCY PROCLAIM BY THE-
GOVERNOR THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO REDUCE. PREPARATION
PROPOSED FROM GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- TRIPLEX BUDGETARY
ESTIMATES AND- AND- OKAY. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COVERING
APPROXIMATELY HUNDREDS- I SHARE
OF THAT THE CLASS BE TREATED TO
COOK IN NINETEEN OVERALL THOUGH
THIS IS FROM THE PROPOSAL FOR
GOVERNOR FOR THE BUDGET ACT
WILL BE A HUNDRED MILLION ABOVE
THE BASELINE- OF SIXTY TWO
POINT SIX MILLION- IN THE FIFTH
ISSUE- SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR
VICTIMS OF. CRIME ACT-
PRESERVATION PROPOSES ONE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR CALAVERAS IS-
TO SUPPLEMENT FEDERAL FUNDING
TO SUPPORT A VARIETY OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM
SERVICES PROGRAMS- DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT
HAVE INCREASED DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHILE THE FEDERAL
FUNDING IS DECREASING- THIS
VICTIMS VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT-
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING WILL
SUPPORT RAPE CRISIS PROGRAMS
MUST BE BALANCED. VICTIM
WITNESS PROGRAMS AND CHILD
ADVOCACY CENTERS- THIS ONE TIME
AUGMENTATION ALLOW. EXISTING
PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE WHILE
BUILDING CAPACITY TO HANDLE THE
INCREASED NEED- AND WHILE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- LOOKS THAT-
EFFORTS TO ATTEMPTTO FIX THE-
VOCA FUNDING LEVELS- WITH BATS-
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THAT
AND I KNOW WE HAVE TWO OTHER
ISSUES THAT DIRECTOR- OF. OF
CALLOW S. WILL BE TAKING ON BUT
WE'LL WE'LL PAUSE THERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. THE L. A. L. HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. SORT OF BORED
WITH THE L. A. O. WITH RESPECT
TO THOSE FIRST ISSUES COVERED
BY MR DUMPING WE ONLY HAVE
COMMENTS ON THE LAST ONE THE
VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT
SUPPLEMENTAL READING OR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
CURRENTLY EFFORTS TO SECURE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THROUGH THE FOCUSED EXTRACTION
COULD. RESPECTFUL FUNDING THE
FUTURE. ACCORDINGLY IF THE
LEGISLATURE GOAL AND APPROVING
THIS FUNDING IS TO MAINTAIN
EXISTING SERVICE LEVELS IT
COULD CONSIDER ADOPTING BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE REQUIRING. ANY
PLANS NOT NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN
EXISTING SERVICE LEVELS TO
REPORT AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
THANK YOU AYE I HAVE A QUESTION
I DON'T KNOW IF- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE EARLIER THIS ANYONE
HAVE ANY UPDATES OF HOW THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ARE GOING AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR THE FOR THE
FUNDING TIED TO BOCA. MADAM
CHAIR I CAN CERTAINLY SEE IF WE
CAN LOOK INTO THAT FOR YOU AND-
AND GET SOME INFORMATION FOR
YOU AND- YOU INVESTMENT. I
WOULD DEFINITELY APPRECIATE
pARE FOCUSING AND THE MAY
REVISE. AND LOOK AT THE
SOMETHING THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
ME. WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO. AT A MINIMUM
MAINTAIN THE LEVEL BUT AS WE
KNOW THROUGH COVERT- THE.
RATE
HAS BEEN INCREASING SINCE SO WE
MIGHT ICING. ALL I WOULD
APPRECIATE CONTINGENCY PLANS
THAT WE CONSIDERING CASE THAT
THAT DOESN'T GET DONE. AND THEN
FINALLY THE SOUTH OF THE
DISCRETION WHETHER OR NOT THAT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS- IT'S
ENOUGH OF A TO CLOSE THE GAP. I
THAT WE COULD POTENTIALLY BE
SEEN OUT THERE. AND SO YOU KNOW
WHAT I WOULD LIKE THIS LOOK AT
THIS. A LITTLE MORE DETAIL AND
NUANCE US AS WE MOVE FORWARD
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THAT THIS
IS MADE IT INTO THE MAY.
REVERSE AND WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THIS
FURTHER- THERE'S NOTHING WORSE
THAN BEING- THE VICTIM OF THE
MIX OF VIOLENCE AND NOT HAVING
THE SUPPORT OUT THERE TO. GIVE
YOU THE SPACE TO TAKE THE STEPS
YOU NEED FOR YOURSELF OR YOUR
FAMILY OUT THERE AND SO. I
THINK WHAT THE SURPLUS WE HAVE
WE HAVE A REAL OPPORTUNITY. TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ABLE. TO
SUPPORT THE VICTIMS AND
FAMILIES IN THE PROPER WAY. AND
ANYONE COMMITTEE HEARD THIS
ITEM. OKAY I KNOW THERE ARE TWO
OTHER- ISSUES FOR CALLAWAY
ASSET BELIEVE- DIRECTOR
GHILARDUCCI IS- GOING TO BE-
DISCUSSING THOSE ISSUES THANK
YOU THANK YOU. WELL GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARK
RTG DIRECTOR OF CALLOW YES.
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS ARE MORE FREQUENT
COMPLICATED AND INVOLVING
MULTIPLE COUNTIES AND REGIONS
OF THE STATE. AND MANY AT THE
SAME TIME. WE'VE EXPERIENCE AT
ALL WILDFIRE EARTHQUAKE FLOOD
AND FLASH FLOODS MUDFLOWS
TSUNAMIS DROUGHTS HAS MASS
POWER OUTAGES AND SECURITY
THREATS. AND WE LIKE YOU HAVE
WITNESSED TOO MANY TIMES THE
DEVASTATION OF A COMMUNITY HAVE
BY ONE OR MORE OF THESE
CATASTROPHIC DISASTERS.
STRUCTURAL AND FINANCIAL
RECOVERIES FOR COMMUNITIES ARE
LONG AND CHALLENGING
PARTICULARLY FOR THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES OF OUR STATE. WE NEED
TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF DISASTER
REBUILD DISASTER REBUILD. SO TO
STRENGTHEN AND BETTER PREPARE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE WE
ARE REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR A NEW
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE. AIR
CALIFORNIA BUILDING RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES- CALIFORNIA
MAXIMIZES THE POWER OF
GOVERNMENT NGOS CBO'S FBOS AND
BUSINESS COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
THROUGH A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
TO RECOGNIZE AND CENTER DRIES
PRIORITIZATION AND RESPIRE
ORGANIZATION ACTION AND HELP
ADDRESS CURRENT BARRIERS FOR
LOCAL AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
IT'S FUNNY WHICH SUPPORT LOCAL
COMMUNITY PROJECTS AND
INITIATIVES DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
ALL HAZARDS VULNERABILITIES.
BUILD RESILIENCY AND PROTECT
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES BEFORE
DISASTER WITH THE SUPPORT OF
STATE GOVERNMENT. REMEMBER
TARGET DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES PROMOTING THE
PRINCIPLES OF EQUITY AND
BUILDING A FOUNDATION FOR
STATEWIDE RESILIENCY AND
EDUCATION TO ALL HAZARDS THE
PARTNERSHIP ENGAGEMENT AND
COMMUNITY HARDING PROGRAMS-
CALIFORNIA ALSO INCLUDES
FUNDING TO HELP RELIEVE
GOVERNMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS UP
TO A HUNDRED PERCENT. OF THEIR
SHARE OF COSTS REQUIRED FOR
MITIGATION PROJECTS UNDER THE
FEDERAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PROGRAM A BARRIER FOR MANY.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PARTICULARLY
SMALLER DISADVANTAGED ONCE. AS
A FIRST RESPONDER I WILL TELL
YOU I HAVE SEEN AND WALK
THROUGH TOO MANY COMMUNITIES
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN LEVELED BY
DISASTERS. LIVES WERE FOREVER
CHANGED BY THESE EVENTS. WE
KNOW THAT BUT THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED BUT WE CAN DO A BETTER
JOB AT SUPPORTING IN PREPARING
OUR COMMUNITIES AND BUILDING
THAT LEVEL OF RESILIENCY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS PROPOSAL HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. SORT OF BORED
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE ARM. WELL WE ARE OFFICE
WOULD DEFINITELY OF KNOWLEDGE
THAT COMMUNITY HARDENING
ACTIVITIES CAN'T ACHIEVE
NOTABLE BENEFITS- THERE ARE
SOME KEY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROGRAM. POSTED BY THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES THAT
REMAIN UNANSWERED INCLUDING HOW
FUNDS WOULD BE PRIORITISED
BETWEEN DIFFERENT TYPES OF
HAZARDS SUCH AS WILD FIRES
EARTHQUAKES AND FLOODS- FUNDS
WOULD BE DIVIDED BETWEEN
OFFSETTING FEDERAL MATCHING
REQUIREMENTS AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THE EXTENT TO WHICH
FEDERAL MATCHING REQUIREMENTS
WOULD BE OFFSET HOW
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WOULD
BE IDENTIFIED AND HOW FUNDS
WOULD BE PRIORITISED BETWEEN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. IF
THE LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO
APPROVE THIS FINDING IT COULD
OUR STRUCTURE THE PROGRAM TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH ITS PRIORITIES
FOR EXAMPLE TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO
DIRECT THESE BONDS TRADE ROUTES
A SPECIFIC TYPE OF HAZARD-
HAZARDS SUCH AS WILDFIRES YOU
CAN DOSO BY ADOPTING
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE OR BUDGET
TRAILER. LEGISLATION
LEGISLATION. I THANK YOU- I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES- IN ADDITION
TO MYSELF I HAVE A NINE. SMALL
CITIES THAT HAVE REALLY LIMITED
BUDGETS AND SO. EVEN AT THAT
25% LEVEL I'LL IT'S HARD FOR
THEM TO MEET THAT THAT MATCH.
OUT THERE IF THEY DO APPRECIATE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT A RANGE
THAT LOCAL. NOT THAT LOCAL I.
SHARE PART UP TO A 100% AND- I
DO APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE
TALKINGABOUT THIS ADVANTAGE IN
TRYING TO PRIORITIZE. THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHO- ARE OFTEN
AFFECTED THE MOST AND HAVE THE
LEAST TO BE ABLE TO PREPARE AND
GET THROUGH. THESE MOMENTS I DO
HE'D- THE L. ALES. WARNING IN A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE THAT WE
LOOK A LITTLE MORE WHAT DOES IT
MEAN TO BE DISADVANTAGED HOW TO
REPAIR TIES WITHIN THEIR- WHEN
WE SAY UP TO A HUNDRED PERCENT.
I WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
100% IF THERE'S A SORT OF SCALE
AND WHAT IS THAT SKILL LOOK
LIKE. TO MEET THOSE NEEDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING THIS
IN AN EQUITABLE WAY AND SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
DETAILS TODAY ON THAT I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT. AND IF NOT- AS
THE NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE
SOMETHING THAT I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN AND CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS ON. MADAM CHAIR
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS- WITH
LEGISLATORS AS WE PROCEED
THROUGH- LEGISLATIVE SLAM IN
THE BUDGET PROCESS. MISS
VIOLADAS. THANK YOU AND- AGAIN
TO BOTH- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN LA- FOR YOUR-
PRESENTATIONS I DO I WOULD LIKE
CLARITY IS WELL ON THE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN PUSHING
FOR- IS FOR MORE FUNDING FOR PS
PS- MONIES BECAUSE OUR CITIES
OR OUR TRIBES ARE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE TRYING TO
MITIGATE WILDFIRES- AND- TRYING
TO HELP THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND
SERVICE THEIR COMMUNITIES- ARE
OUT OF POWER WHEN PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS OCCUR AND THOSE
ARE HAPPENING MORE AND MORE
FREQUENTLY- AND THEN WE ALSO
EXPECT THAT THERE WILL ALSO BE-
SOME ROLLING BLACKOUTS THIS
SUMMER WITH THE- DRYNESS AND
HEAT THAT WE'RE EXPECTING AND
MY CONCERN IS THAT WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WHETHER IT WAS LAST YEAR
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION OR- THE
PREVIOUS YEAR FIFTY MILLION- IT
WASN'T ENOUGH. NUMBER CITIES
THAT THE NEED FAR EXCEEDED THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE SO CAN THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TELL
ME WHAT ARE CITIES- WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR RESOURCES IN THE
FORM OF GRANTS FOR PS PS EVENTS
INCLUDING BUYING BACK UP
GENERATORS- OUR BATTERY PACKS-
COULD THEY REQUEST SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES OR OR WOULD THERE. BE
GRANTED BILLABLE THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM FOR THAT. I'LL START A
MINUTE AND THEN I'LL PASS IT
ON- TO CALAVERAS MY
UNDERSTANDING IT IS THIS IS
MORE HARDENING OF
INFRASTRUCTURE- TO MITIGATE
AGAINST FUTURE FLOODS FIRES
EARTHQUAKES- BUT- I'M NOT
CERTAIN THAT THAT- THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF-
RESOURCES WHICH WOULD BE
DIRECTLY- INCORPORATED AND INTO
THE- THOUGH THOUGH THERE THERE
MAY BE SOME SEEM TANGENTIAL
BETTER BENEFITS- I'M NOT SURE-
YES HAS ANYTHING TO ADD ON TO
THAT. AND THANKS SSEMBLY
MEMBER- FOR THE QUESTION THIS
IS MARK RTG. I THINK THE ANSWER
ON THIS IS THAT- THROUGH ABOUT
ABOUT- PREPARE CALIFORNIA'S
ISSUE THAT IF YOU IT'S REALLY
COMMUNITIES LOOKING AT. THERE
RISKS ALL ACROSS THE BOARD
OFTEN AT ALL HAZARDS
STANDPOINT- EVERY PART OF THE
STATE HAS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
RISKS SIGNATURE. THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT VULNERABILITY LEVELS
AND IN SOME AREAS- POWER COULD
BE OUT. THERE DRIVING FOR
PROFITABILITY IN SOME OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE IT'S NOT A
LOT THAT'S WHY THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM IS REALLY NOT DESIGNED
TO BE ONE HAZARD AND FOCUS ON
ONE HAZARD BUT TO LOOK AT A
BROAD. OFF MORE- YOU KNOW
COLLABORATIVE WAY BUT THE FACT
THE MATTER IS WE WOULD SAY IN
THIS INITIATIVE BACK INSTEAD OF
DOING A ONE OFF BY EIGHT EIGHTY
UP- A GENERATOR WHAT WE WOULD
SAY IS THAT WE WOULD WORK WITH
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT BUT DISTRICT TO
DETERMINE WHERE THE PHONE
ABILITY IS IF IT'S IN POWER
THEN WE WOULD LOOK ACROSS ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT ELEMENTS
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AND FUNDS
WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE WITHIN
BE PRIORITY SETTING UP ACT
COLLABORATIVE COMMUNITY. GROUP
MADE UP OF ALL THE FOLKS I
MENTIONED BEFORE TO ADDRESS THE
POWER NEEDS- THAT WAY IT COULD
BE A GENERATOR BUT HAS THAT
GENERATOR FIT INTO THE LARGER-
I NEED SHOULD HAVE A FIELDING
RESILIENCY IN THE COMMUNITY
OVERALL. SO THEN YOU CAN
MAXIMIZE THE EFFORT ABOUT ONE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT OR ONE LOCAL
COMMUNITY BY BUILDING
AUTOMATION BROADER SET OF
CAPABILITIES. WITHIN THAT
JURISDICTION. SO YOU'RE SAYING
THERE'S A CHANCE. YEAH YEAH
THEY'RE THEY'RE YOU KNOW IT'S A
PART OF THE EFFORT THERE
THEY'RE SOME OF THE MONEY COULD
USED- BUT AGAIN IT WOULD BE IN
IN THE APPROACH JUST A ONE OFF.
RIGHT TO WORK THE- LEGISLATIVE
AND OFFICE ONLY THING I'M GOING
TO JUMP INTO ACT IS JUSTICE
REITERATE THE MARKET REMARKS I
MADE BEFORE IS THERE'S NO.
THERE'S NO REASON THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULDN'T STRUCTURE
THIS PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
CERTAIN HAZARDS WERE ADDRESSED-
SO AND WE ARE ENCOURAGED THE
LEGISLATURE TO. ENSURE THAT ITS
PRIORITIES ARE REFLECTED IN
WHATEVER THEY ALSO THE
STRUCTURE OF THE PROGRAM AS-
THANK YOU. MISTER DANCER RIGHT
AND I JUST. ON THE DISASTER
COST TRACKING AND RECOVERY
UNIT- AND- I DON'T KNOW IF WE
GOT THAT PART ABOUT MODERNIZING
THE TECHNOLOGY AND DATA
ANALYTICS I THINK THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT- AS SOMEONE.
THEY USED TO. DO THIS COLLECTED
DATA TO GET RECOVERY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- AND WE DID IT WITH
PAPER. THEN WE'LL HAVE TO KEEP
THAT WEIGHT ROOMS AND ROOMS
FULL OF PAPER- TO BE ABLE TO
JUSTIFY A RECOVERY- AND I RAN
THAT UNIT. AND IT DAY UNIT MORE
THAN PAY FOR THEMSELVES OF OVER
THE LONG RUN AND SO- I WOULD
LIKE SOME MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. WITH- YES AND- I COULD
COSTLY HERE ABOUT SMALL CITIES
AND OTHER PLACES THAT MAY NOT
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO- TOOK
TOMATOES CORRECTIVE TO MAINTAIN
OF RECORDS OR HAVE STAFF TO
COLLECT THOSE RECORDS. AND TO
BE ABLE TO PROPERLY GET
REIMBURSED- OR EVEN TO COME UP
WITH FUNDS TO DO THE DATA
COLLECTION SO. I MAY BE AHEAD
OF THE GAME BUT I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THANK YOU YOU
ARE BEING A GREAT STATE AND-
AND JUST A LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF
THE GAME WITH THE LATEST NEXT
ITEM- AND SO I WILL HAVE THEM
PERCENT ON THAT AND THEN WE
COULD ASK YOUR QUESTION AGAIN
IF YOU NEED ADDITIONAL DETAILS.
THANK HELLO WE COULD BEGIN-
ISSUE SEVEN STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S EMERGENCY CAPACITY
AND CAPABILITIES. OKAY COME
BACK OVER TO ME AGAIN THE
TARGET MARKET RTG BOB. SO GIVEN
THAT THAT THAT THE EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS ARE MORE FREQUENT
AND COMPLICATED IN CALIFORNIA
BUT MAYBE VISION INCLUDES SIXTY
POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND.
AND ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
POSITION TO STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S EMERGENCY
CAPABILITIES. THIS IS THE
BETTER SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
THIS INITIATIVE DOES THE
FOLLOWING. IT ESTABLISHES A
PERMANENT INCIDENT SUPPORT TEAM
AS A PART OF THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER AND INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT TEAM TO MORE QUICKLY
RESPOND. AND SUPPORT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE-
FOR CONTINUITY OF GOVERNMENT
AND LESSEN OUR CURRENT REDUCE
OUR RELIANCE ARE RE DIRECTED
STAFF TO DO SO. THE CURRENT
OPERATION THAT WE HAVE IN THAT
WE'VE BEEN USING IS REALLY OLD
SCHOOL AND NOT SUSTAINABLE. IT
ALSO ESTABLISHES A NEW OFFICE
OF EQUITY AND CAL WE ASKED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR- CONNECTIONS
WITH UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
AND FURTHER. ELEVATE EQUITY AS
A CORE PRINCIPLE OF THE
ORGANIZATION. IT ALSO PROVIDES
PERMANENT RESOURCES FOR THE
LEAST THOSE PROGRAM AND EXPANDS
ITS FOCUS TO INCLUDE RESPONSIVE
RECOVERY PROGRAMS THE BETTER
BILL THEN SERVICE TO DISASTER
SURVIVORS AND COMMUNITIES.
EVERY PLACE IS ANTIQUATED
SYSTEMS THAT THAT LEVERAGES
INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGIES TO
MODERNIZE THE STATE'S
CAPABILITIES- TECHNOLOGY AND
STRENGTH IN DATA ANALYTICS AS
DISASTERS AND THEIR IMPACTS ON
PEOPLE AND PROPERTY HAVE
INCREASED TIMELY DATA AND
ADVANCED ANALYTICS ARE EVER
MORE CRITICAL TO SUPPORT DATA
INFORMED DECISIONS. IT ALSO
ESTABLISHES A NEW COST RECOVERY
UNIT HELLO YES TO MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY AND DISASTER
DOLLARS PROVIDED CALIFORNIA. AS
THE US I REMEMBER SORRY JUST
MENTIONED AS THE STATE'S LEAD
AGENCY FOR FEMA FEDERAL DOLLARS
THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS WOULD.
HAVE RESULTED IN BILLIONS OF
FEDERAL FUNDS PROVIDED THE
STATE AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THIS COST RECOVERY THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO BRING BACK IN TO
BE ABLE TO HELP- HELP BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND HE STATE AND
FINALLY THE MAY REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES THIRTY SEVEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION- HUNDRED FIFTY
POINT SEVEN OF THAT. BEING FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE
PERMANENT FUNDING FOR
ADDITIONAL LONG TERM COST
RECOVERY POSITIONS. IT WOULD BE
BETTER SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
RECOVERY EFFORTS ARE
ACCELERATING ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND HELP GET COMMUNITIES BACK
ON THEIR FEET AND RECOUP ALL OF
THE ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
DISASTER FUNDS FOR THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
MAXIMIZE BOTH OUR PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE AND HAZARD. HAZARD
MITIGATION PROGRAMS. THANK YOU
HAPPENED AFTER QUESTIONS. GEN
JOHN THIRTY HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS. JUST UP JUST HOW
THE- HOW DO YOU PLAN TO USE THE
DISASTER COST TRACKING A
RECOVERY UNIT AND HOW I SEE
FOURTEEN POSITIONS BUT HOW
SPECIFICALLY DO YOU PLAN TO-
AND HOW ROBUST WILL IT BE AS
FAR AS OUR RECOVERY FOR GETTING
FEDERAL FUNDS BECAUSE YOU
MENTION. THAT COULD RESULT IN
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS COMING BACK DOWN TO THE
STATE BUT HOW CAN WE ALSO MAKE
SURE IT GOES DOWN TO LOOK MEANS
IT MAY NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY.
TO BE ABLE TO RECOVER THOSE
FUNDS. THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
I REMEMBER- SO ONE OF THE
ISSUES IS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE EVER INCREASING.
NUMBER OF DISASTERS AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF THESE DISASTERS-
YES AS I'VE BECOME MORE AND
MORE ENGAGED OUT ASSISTING
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
AND SUPPORTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BOB EVEN EVEN
BOTHER RESPONSE OPERATIONS ARE
GOING ON WE'RE ALREADY
BEGINNING THAT PROCESS OF
SETTING UP. THE LONG TERM
RECOVERY OPERATIONS EVER
FINDING THAT WERE HAVING TO
ENGAGE. OVER THE LONG TERM THE
LIFE OF THE RECOVERY- CYCLE.
ENGAGE WITH THOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO KEEP THEM- ARE
ON THE RIGHT TRACK THROUGH ITS
SYSTEM IN MAXIMIZING EVERY
DOLLAR. AND THOSE DOLLARS COULD
COME FROM FEEDBACK THEY COULD
COME FROM OUTSIDE- BABY NO THEY
THERE THEY COULD BECOME FROM
USDA. DEPENDING ON WHEREVER
THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS ARE. WE
REALLY WANT TO MAXIMIZE THE
RECOVERY BILLS AND GET THEM
DOWN INTO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT BUT TO UTILIZE THOSE FUNDS
EFFECTIVELY THAT LONG TERM
RECOVERY PLAN NEEDS TO BE ON
THE FRONT END OF THE RECOVERY
PROCESS. AND THIS IS WHERE- YES
REALLY PROVIDES THAT. TECHNICAL
DATA NOT LET ME BE CLEAR THAT.
THAT THAT YOU KNO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE LEGISLATURE ARE IT
PROVIDES- HUNDRED FOUR
POSITIONS OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD. THAT EXPIRED JUNE
THIRTIETH AND WE'RE AT WORK WE
WORK WE'RE REQUESTING THAT.
THEY MAKE THOSE PERMANENT AND
ALSO AT A HUNDRED TEN NEW
POSITIONS. INTERESTING TO NOTE
THAT THAT SIX TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE NOW WE'VE HAD
FIFTY SEVEN. ADDITIONAL STATE
AND FEDERAL DISASTERS JUST IN
THAT IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME
JUST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. BUT
THE ISSUE IS THAT- WE'VE GOT
THOUGHT THAT DISASTERS THAT
TYPICALLY TAKE ANYWHERE BETWEEN
SEVEN AND TEN YEARS OF SOME OF
THE MORE COMPLICATED ONES. THE
COMPLETELY REBUILT THE
COMMUNITY AND THEN WE'VE GOT
ALL THESE NEW ONES THAT. THAT
SORT OF STACK RACK AND STACK ON
TOP OF. EACH OTHER THEY WERE
HAVING TO DEAL WITH WE ONLY
HAVE SO MANY REACHED. BUT
AROUND BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE ARE. WE SUPPORT THOSE LOW
GOVERNMENTS TO THE GREAT EXTENT.
THE MAXIMUM EVERY BIT OF COST
RECOVERY. IT WILL JUST MAKE
SURE WE CAN QUANTIFY BECAUSE
FOR EVERY PERSON YOU HIGHER. UP
I DON'T WANNA MAKE IT. LOOKED
LIKE JUST STRAIGHT DOLLARS BUT
FIERCELY FOR EVERY PERSON YOU
HIRE THEY BRING BACK. X. AMOUNT
OF DAY PAY FOR THEMSELVES IN IN
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND SO IF WE CAN
QUANTIFY THAT I THINK WE YOU
WOULD HAVE ANY. PROBLEMS THAT
ONLY HAVING US- RE AUTHORIZED
OF POSITIONS BUT ALSO MAKING A
PERMIT BECAUSE THE DATE. THEY
EASE THE GENERAL FUND AND SO
WHEN A DISASTER HAPPENS WE'RE
NOT TAKING THE BIGGEST HIT ON
THE GENERAL FUND- AS WE WOULD
NORMALLY DO. YES SIR I COULD
CURRENT WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET THAT FAT BY DETAIL FOR
YOU. THANK YOU THERE'S NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS WHO WILL MOVE
ON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU'RE SORT
OF OUR WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE DECADES- IF
THERE'S TIME OUR OFFICE DOES
HAVE SOME REMARKS ON THIS IS AN
ONLINE. COOPER THAT'S RIGHT
NEXT TIME TO JUMP IN AHEAD OF
TIME. HELLO THE ONLY GRAMMY I
EXPECT TO GET A JUMP IN SO I
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU. NO PROBLEM
NO PROBLEM. SO WITH RESPECT TO
THE PROPOSAL TO CREATE A
PERMANENT STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER TEAM IN PRINCIPLE WE
FIND. THE IDEA OF A DEDICATED
TEAM REASONABLE HOWEVER WE
WOULD NOTE THAT- YES IS NOT
PROVIDED DATA ON THE EXTENT TO
WHICH STAFF ARE UNABLE TO
COMPLETE THEIR NORMAL WORK
LOAD. I DO TOO THE STOCK
ACTIVATIONS WHICH IS THE
PRIMARY REASON WHY HE'S
ADDITIONAL STAFF ARE BEING
REQUESTED. I SUCH IT'S
DIFFICULT TO ASSESS WHETHER THE
AMOUNT F RESOURCES PROPOSED OR
APPROPRIATE. WITH RESPECT TO
THE OFFICE OF EQUITY WE FIND A
PROPOSAL REASONABLE AND
RECOMMEND APPROVAL- WHEN IT
COMES TO THE- WE STILL SEE
GRANT PROGRAM- WE FIND THE
PROGRAM PROMISING. BUT SIMILAR
TO SOME OF THE GRANT PROGRAMS
MENTIONED BEFORE THERE ARE SOME
KEY QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE
ABOUT HOW IT WOULD OPERATE SUCH
AS WHAT SERVICES WOULD BE
SUPPORTED. HOW FUNDING WOULD BE
PRIORITISED BETWEEN SUPPORTED
SERVICES. AGAIN HELLO YES WHAT
IDENTIFIED COMMUNITIES THAT
COULD BENEFIT FROM THE SERVICE
AND HOW OR WHAT- YES WOULD
PRIORITIZE BETWEEN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND WHETHER
OUTCOME DATA WOULD BE COLLECTED
AND USED. TO INFORM FUTURE
GRANT AWARDS. WHEN COMES TO THE-
DISASTER- COSTS TRACKING AND
RECOVERY UNIT WELL AS THE- TO
MODERN- YES. SYSTEMS FIND THAT
THESE ARE A REASONABLE
PROPOSALS AND RECOMMEND THEIR
APPROVAL AND WE WOULD NOTE THAT
TO THE EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T PROVE ON. IT WOULD
ALLOW THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROVIDE MONTHLY REPORTS ON
STATE EMERGENCY EXPENDITURES
SOMETHING THAT OUR OFFICE HAS
RECOMMENDED REQUIRING THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DO TO IMPROVE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. OVER
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND FINALLY
WITH RESPECT TO THE LONG TERM
RECOVERY THE PROPOSAL ENDING
FOR LONG TERM RECOVERY TEAMS WE
ALSO FIND THAT THIS IS A
REASONABLE. AND DON'T RAISE ANY
CONCERNS. THANK YOU FOR THAT-
BUT THAT WE WILL. WE WILL MOVE
ON TO PANEL NUMBER FIVE WE'RE
GOING TO COVER THE FIRST FIVE
ITEMS AT TOGETHER AND AT THE
END OF THE FIFTH ITEM I WILL.
GO AHEAD AND TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE
REFERRED THAT ALLAH WILL JUMP
IN APPROPRIATELY. THANK YOU. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON HAD JUST A
REMINDER FROM THE FINANCE I'LL
BE COVERING YOU SHE WARNED THAT
THE REVISION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE FOR THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
IN WILL BE HANDING OUT TO MY
COLLEAGUES EVEN WORSE TO COVER
THE FOLLOWING CAPPELLI ISSUES.
RELIGION INCLUDING A HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. DIGITAL
SIGNATURE BRAND STRESSED
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
THIS BRINGS THE TOTAL
INVESTMENT FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION ONE TAX FUNDING.
THANK YOU CHAU COUNCILS
IDENTIFIED OVER FIVE BILLION IN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
COSTS IN THE USUAL GONZALEZ
ALSO INDICATED THAT MONEY WILL
UNABLE TO PROVIDE. A LIST OF
PROJECTS THAT WOULD BE
ADDRESSED WITH THIS FUNDING
BECAUSE THESE DECISIONS WE NEED
TO BE MADE THAT DELIBERATE
MANNER THROUGH THEIR ADVISORY
COMMITTEE PROCESS WHERE THE
ENTIRE JUDICIAL BRANCHES
RECOMMEND- IT'S A- REPRESENTED
IN THEIR COMMITTEES BUT THEY
CAN MAKE. AN INFORMED DECISION
TO ADDRESS THESE DOLLARS CAME
WITH A SPECIFIC PROJECT LIST.
IS ALSO. IMPORTANT THAT THIS
FUNDING IS ALSO. OVERSPEND IN
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY FOUR
THANK YOU PLEASE LET ME KNOW
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTION. I NEED
ONLY WHAT THE LARGEST L. OFFICE-
ON THIS ISSUE WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO PROVIDE A LIST OF
THE PROJECTS THAT WILL BE
FUNDED BY THIS ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION. BEFORE ACTING ON
THIS PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT
THE SELECTED PROJECTS ALIGNED
WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AND
SO FOR FRAME OF CONTEXT FOR THE
JANUARY PROPOSAL FOR THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS THE LEGISLATURE
DID RECEIVE AND WAS ABLE TO
REVIEW A LIST OF THIRTY ONE
PROJECTS ARE PROPOSED TO BE
FUNDED. AND WE'RE EIGHT AND WAS
ABLE TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
ABOUT THOSE PROJECTS AS WELL.
THANK YOU. HI. ECCRINE ONE
ROBERTS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE NEXT THREE PROPOSALS ARE
THE NEXT THREE HIGHEST
PRIORITIES IN THE RECENT
REASSESSMENT THAT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH PERFORMED ITEM NUMBER
TWO IS ACTUALLY OUR THIRD ONE
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD FIND THE
WORDS THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND FOR THE
ACQUISITION AND PERFORMANCE
CRITERIA PHASES OF A NEW
PROJECT THAT WILL INCLUDE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW SEVEN
COURTROOM COURTHOUSE TOTALING
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET AT FOUR
OR- ITEM NUMBER THREE WOULD BE-
OUR SECOND. PRIORITY THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD FIND NINE
HUNDRED TO ONE THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND THE ACQUISITION AND
PRELIMINARY PLANS PHASE OF A
NEW PROJECT THAT WILL INCLUDE
CONSTRUCTION OF TWO NEW COURT
ROOMS TOTALING APPROXIMATELY
FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE FEET
ASSOCIATED WITH CLERICAL SPACE
AND A LOBBY EXPANSION AT THE
CURRENT JUVENILE DEPENDENCY
COURTHOUSE IN ST BERNARD DINO
AND NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS OUR
FIRST PRIORITY THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD FIND SIX HUNDRED AND FOUR
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND FOR THE
PRELIMINARY PLANS AND WORKING
DRAWINGS PHASES OF ANY PROJECT
THAT WILL INCLUDE NEW
CONSTRUCTION APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET AND A
RENOVATION OF APPROXIMATELY
THIRTEEN HUNDRED SQUARE FEET.
OF COURT EXCLUSIVE SPACE AND
THE EXISTING BUTTE COUNTY
JUVENILE. HALL IN ORDER BILL.
THE PROPOSED BEFORE TODAY
REPLACE OUR PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AT GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET WITH THIS NEW VERSION OF
STATUTORY CHANGES. TO ALLOW
DIGITAL BOOK JUDICIAL BRANCH TO
UTILIZE THE DESIGN BUILD
METHODOLOGY. TO COMPLETE ANY
NEW CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
WITH UNIONIZED LABOR OR PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS. THE DAILY L.
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD ON THE
PHANTOMS. AND ANY OTHER WITH
THE ONLY A WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH- THESE ITEMS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FROM-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WE HAVE NO
QUESTION SO WE WILL MOVE ON
THANK YOU MOVE ON TO ITEM SIX
TO ELEVEN FOR THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH. ZERO NINE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE MERE NATION
INCLUDES THIRTY MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO JUST FOR
THE CHIEF JUSTICE IS EARLY
DISPOSITION READING THIS
CONFERENCE PROGRAM FOR CONTACT
PURPOSES BACK IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY. CHIEF JUSTICE
REPLIES THE TEMPORARIES AND
JUDGES PROGRAM TO ALLOW COURTS
TO REQUEST JUDGES TO FACILITATE
READINESS CONFERENCE PROGRAMS
WHICH ALLOW THE PARTIES IN THE
CASE THE GATHERED A SEPARATE.
CONFERENCE TO EXPEDITE THE
ADJUDICATION OF THESE CASES
WELL THE CHIEF JUSTICE PROVIDES
TEMPORARY JUDGES TO COURTS THAT
ARE IN FOR THIS VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM NOT ALL COURTS HAVE THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
STAFF TO SUPPORT THESE JUDGES.
THIS IS MADE SOME COURTS
RELUCTANT TO OPT INTO THIS
PROGRAM THIS FUNDING WOULD MEAN
THAT FINANCIAL DOCUMENT TO
FURTHER PROMOTE THIS PROGRAM
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE TRANSPORTS
TO ADDRESS. A BACKLOG WITH THE
PROCESSING OF CRIMINAL CASES
THIRTY MILLION ONE TIME WOULD
ENABLE THE CHIEF JUSTICE
REMOVED THE TEMPORARY SIDE
JUDGES PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THE COURTS TO
SUPPORT ALL ASPECTS FOR THE
READY MIX. CONFERENCE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. I NEED ONLY WITH THE
L. A WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNS ON
THIS PROPOSAL. THE FOURTEENTH
THE- ISSUE ON PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE. THE MAYOR THIS
INCLUDES PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO REQUEST UP
TO SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS CIVIL AND CRIMINAL CASE
BACKLOGS IN THE EVENT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES REQUIRED
HOW DID YOU. THE COUNCIL TO
SUBMIT A FORMAL REQUEST FOR THE
DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES IN
THIS WOULD REQUIRE A SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATING
NOTIFICATION OF VALLEY I WAS
RECOMMENDED TO REJECTED THIS
LANGUAGE IN A STATE OF THIS
FUNDING COULD BE REQUESTED
THROUGH THE NINETY EIGHT FORTY
ON ANTICIPATED COUGH REQUEST
PROCESS HOWEVER WE'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH FUNDING AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE NINETY EIGHT FORTY
PROCESS GIVEN THERE'S ONLY
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN ROOM
IN THE GENERAL FUND. WE DO NOT
CONSIDER THESE COST TO BE
UNANTICIPATED I'M BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T THERE WE ARE PLANNING
FOR THEM TO OCCUR WITH THIS
TRADITIONALLY SO THEREFORE
WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR
THE NINETY EIGHT FORTY PROCESS
TO BE USED IN LIEU IT'S
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE IN REGARD
TO THE ALIENS RECOMMENDATION OF
LIMITING THE USE OF THIS
FUNDING FOR CERTAIN CASE TYPES
ARE JUST LIKE GOING OUT THAT
ACROSS THE FIFTY EIGHT. REPORTS
OF BACKLOGS CAN VARY BY CASE
TYPE IN RESTRICTIONS TO THE
FUNDING COULD INHIBIT EACH
RESPECTIVE COURTS IS EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THEIR BACKLOGS. THANK
YOU. I NEED ONLY WITH A- ALLEN
OFFICE I MR MY- MENTION. AND WE
ARE. REJECTING THE PROVISION
LANGUAGE THERE IS AN EXISTING
PROCESS. FOR A STATE PROGRAMS
REQUEST ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
AN ANTICIPATED THAT AND
NECESSARY- EXPENSES. TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
IN INTERESTED IN MAINTAINING
THE LANGUAGE WE DO RECOMMEND.
AMENDING THE LANGUAGE TO
INCREASE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF THE PROCESS INTO PARTICULAR
WAYS. THE FIRST JUST TO MODIFY
THE LANGUAGE FOR HOW THE
FUNDING MAY BE USED AND SO THIS
CAN INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE
LIMITING USE TO CERTAIN CASE
TYPES. OR TO A STATE WIDE
TARGETED EFFORTS SUCH AS THE
EARLY DISPOSITION PROGRAM THAT
WAS JUST PRESENTED- THE SECOND
WAY IS TO. MODIFY THE LANGUAGE
TO REFLECT WHAT INFORMATION
MUST BE PROVIDED TO JUSTIFY THE
REQUEST FOR THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT BE INTERESTED
IN GETTING INFORMATION. IN
TERMS OF WHAT EFFORTS- THE
COURTS HAVE TAKEN TO ADDRESS
THE BACKLOG AND KIND OF HOW
THEY PLAN ON USING THE FUNDING.
AND SO COLLECTIVELY THESE WHAT
HELP THE LEGISLATURE MAKE MORE
INFORMED DECISION MAKING AT.
HOW TO MAKE A- DECISIONS AS
THEY WERE REVIEWING REQUESTS
FOR THE FUNDING THANK YOU. FOR
I WILL DISCUSS THE LEGAL AID
FOR RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS
ISSUE. THE COMMISSION ALSO
INCLUDES TWENTY MILLION GROWN A
LOT CORONAVIRUS FISCAL RECOVERY
FUNDED TELL TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR FOR NONPROFIT
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO
HELP INDIVIDUALS AVOID EVICTION
WERE FORECLOSURE THIS FUNDING
WILL SUPPORT GRANTS TO THE
STATE PARK OVER A HUNDRED
PEOPLE SERVICE PROJECTS IN
SUPPORT. OFFERED PEOPLE
SERVICES STUFF AND. TAKING
HOMEOWNERS THANK YOU. THE L. A.
R. HAS NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. THE NEXT ISSUE IS
INCREASING REIMBURSEMENT
ACCORDINGLY SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AUGMENTED THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES PROJECT WHICH
INCREASES THEIR CONTRACT WITH
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL FOR THE
EATEN FIFTY EIGHT PROGRAM A
CHILD SUPPORT COMMISSION FAMILY
OFFICE OKAY- PROGRAM. THIS
MEANS THIS MEANS THE NEAR
VISION WOULD INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENT OF THIRTY FIVE
FIVE MILLION TO COUNTERACT THE
INCREASE VALUE OF THE CONTRACTS
THE REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY.
INCREASES TECHNICAL IN NATURE.
DALY I HAD A CONCERN ON THIS
PROPOSAL. WE DETERMINE WHAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MINISTER
TODAY STATEWIDE INITIATIVE TO
REDUCE TRAVEL CONCERN AT THIS
PROPOSAL INCLUDES A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TWENTY TWO
DECLINING TO SEVENTY MILLION ON
GOING SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION
AND PROPERTY OR PROGRAMS AND
PRACTICES. TO PROMOTE THIS WEEK
FISHING FAIR AND TIMELY PRE
TRIAL RELEASE INDIVIDUALS
BOOKED INTO JAIL AT THIS
PROPOSAL ACTUALLY CONTAINS TWO
COMPONENTS THE FIRST EXPAND THE
PRE TRIAL PILOT PROGRAM
ORIGINALLY FUNDED WITH ONE TIME
RESOURCES AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT AFTER BY PROVIDING
FUNDS TO EACH OF THE FORTY
MONTHS HERE WHAT'S- IT NOT
RECEIVE FUNDING AS PART OF
THAT. PROGRAM AT THE SECOND ONE
IS THE ONGOING RESOURCES AND
THIS WILL PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
ALL FIFTY AIRPORTS IN
CALIFORNIA- WITH THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO SUPPORT JUDICIAL
OFFICERS MAKING PRE TRIAL
RELEASE DECISIONS THAT MAINTAIN
PUBLIC SAFETY AND SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS RETURNING TO OUR-
CLOSING AT LEAST A RESTRICTIVE
CONDITIONS ON THE DEFENDANT'S
BY IMPLEMENTING APPROPRIATE
MONITORING PRACTICES. IN THE
PROVISION OF SERVICES. THANK
YOU. I NEED ONLY WITH THE L. A.
WE DO FIND THIS MERITS CAN AS
IT PROVIDE RELIEF TO LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS WHO HAV-
WHO MIGHT HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
PAYING BAIL AND ALSO GIVEN A
RECENT CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
RULING THAT COULD INCREASE THE
NEED FOR PRE TRIAL SERVICES-
HOWEVER WE DO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER MODIFYING
THE PROPOSED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE AND FIVE WEIGHTS- WAS
THE FIRST IN THE FUNDING IS
CURRENTLY SCHEDULED TO BE
ALLOCATED BASED ON EACH COUNTY
SHARE OF THE STATE'S POPULATION
OF EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLDS. AND SO WE DO RECOMMEND
MODIFYING THE LANGUAGE TO
ALLOCATE THE FUNDING Ë
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
USING ALTERNATIVE OR ADDITIONAL
METRICS SUCH AS CRIMINAL
FILINGS TO ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDING MORE CLOSELY ALIGNS
WITH THE POTENTIAL WORKLOAD
THAT EACH CUNTY IN COURT WOULD
BE FACING THE SECOND
MODIFICATION IS TO REQUIRE
DETAILED ANNUAL REPORTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE EXPENDITURE
OF THE USE OF THE DOLLARS AND
KEY OUTCOME DATA SUCH AS THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS SERVED
AND- YOU KNOW HOW MANY AND HOW
THEY WERE SERVED FOR EXAMPLE.
THROUGH THE PERIOD PREECE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND
ENSURE THAT THE FUNDING IS USED
ACCOUNTABILITY AND EFFECTIVELY
THE THIRD MODIFICATION IT IS
THAT WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SPECIFIED THE
INTENT TO MODIFY THE ALLOCATION
FORMULA IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE FISCAL YEAR
BASED ON ADDITIONAL DATA I'M
SUCH AS USING THE PERCENT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE RELEASED
PRETRIAL RELATIVE TO THE
FINDINGS- AS WELL AS THE FIRST
REQUIRED ANNUAL JUDICIAL
COUNCIL EVALUATION OF PRE TRIAL
PROGRAMS AND PRACTICES AND SO
THE EXISTING LANGUAGE REQUIRES
THAT AS OF- JULY FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WOULD BE
SUBMITTING- EVALUATING PRETRIAL
PROGRAMS AND PRACTICES AND SO
THAT'S WHAT THAT TIES TO. THE
FOURTH MODIFICATION TO LANGUAGE
IS THAT WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER PROVIDING
COURTS WITH FLEXIBILITY TO
CONTRACT WITH THE ENTITY THAT
IS THE BEST. SUITED TO PRE
TRIAL SERVICES THAN JUST.
PROBATION WHICH IS HOW THE
LANGUAGE IS CURRENTLY WRITTEN-
AS LONG AS THE ENTITY DOESN'T
HAVE ARREST RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND THE FINAL MODIFICATION IS
THAT WE RECOMMEND MODIFYING THE
LANGUAGE TO REQUIRE THE
EVALUATION OF THE IMPACT OF
RACE AND OTHER FACTORS ON
RELEASED DECISIONS. TO HELP
INFORM WHETHER FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION IN THIS AREA
IS NEEDED. THANK YOU. JUST MADE
ANOTHER ARE GONNA FIND IT AGAIN
I DON'T WANT TO RESPOND TO. A
RECORD. IBM EXPECTS IT- TO WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE L. A.
O. ON THE BEST DETERMINE FOR
COUNTY NEEDS AND ALLOCATION FOR
THESE FUNDS- AND WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON
WHAT'S MOST APPROPRIATE AS
OPPOSED TO EACH OUR PUBLIC
FILINGS- NEAR FUTURE AND AFTER.
BE A JUDICIAL COUNCIL MEMBER
FIRST REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
I WOULD YOU ALSO AGREE THAT
REPORTING SHOULD BE ROBUST AND
MEANINGFUL. BUT WE'VE GOT SOME
CONCERNS THAT SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SPECIFIED
OUTCOMES EIGHT IT IS BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF THE INITIAL PROPOSAL
AND MIGHT REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR MORE IN DEPTH
PROCESS. INTO IT WOULD GRANT
MANAGEMENT OR ACADEMIC STUDIES
THAT AGAIN FOR GOODNESS
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL. AS FOR THE
RECOMMENDATION TO EXPAND AND ON
PROBATION ENTITIES
ADMINISTRATION THANKS OF THIS
IS THE ISSUE AND PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
ANSWERED OF COURSE THIS IS
INTENDED TO BE KIND OF A STATE
WIDE EQUALIZER. SO THE
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES ARE
PRACTICING SORT OF THE JUSTICE
BY GEOGRAPHY AND. WE BELIEVE
THAT PROBATION. IF ALL OF THE
COUNTY IN OTHER. FOR THE TROUT
SERVICES. BUT OPEN THE COUNTY
AND PROBATION DEPARTMENTS. AND
NOT THAT. WE THINK WE SHOULD
FUND. AT THIS PURPOSE REGARD
PEOPLE. AND OUT OF THE CAR
FUNCTION AND NOT. COUNTY SIR.
FROM. BAXLEY WE THE PROBATION
REPORT SERVE OUR GIVEN. ON
GOINGS AND REGARD WE TRUST. OF
TYPES OF REALIGNING. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE BUT ONE OF
MOST OF. FOR FUNDING FOR. IT.
WE HAVE ONE MORE ITEM LEFT OF
ITEM ELEVEN THAT FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM. JUST A REMINDER
PARTNER FINANCE. INCLUDES A
TOTAL OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME QUARTERBACKS
DISCORDANT COMPANY FUND FOR
DEBT FORGIVENESS PROGRAM
TELEVISED IMMEDIATE FINANCIAL
RELIEF FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS DENOMINATION OF
INFRACTION FINES AND FEES THAT
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM WILL
ELIMINATE DEBT OWED ON EXISTING
FIND AT THESE FOR ABOUT TRAFFIC
AND NON TRAFFIC INFRACTION
TICKETS ISSUED BETWEEN JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY FIFTEEN IN JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
INDIVIDUALS WOULD SUBMIT A
PAPER APPLICATION CORRECTLY TO
THE TRIAL COURTS TO HAVE THEIR
FINES AND FEES ELIMINATED THE
ONE TIME FUNDING WILL BE USED
TO BACK FILL CORK FUNDS IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR LOST
REVENUES AS A RESULT OF THE
PROGRAM IN ADDITION FUNDING
WILL BE USED TO SUPPORT TROUT
WORKS. IN THE PROCESSING OF
APPLICATIONS INCREMENTAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROMOTE GROWTH THIS PROGRAM TO
THE PUBLIC TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION AS SPECIFIED BY
THE L. E. O. THERE ARE STILL
CERTAIN COMPONENTS OF THIS
PROPOSAL THAT WILL NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATOR
AS WELL AS THE TEACHER
COUNSELOR POTENTIALLY REFINE
THIS PROPOSAL. PLEASE. LET ME
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
I NEED ONLY WITH A LOT AND
OFFICE- SO WE DO FOR THAT THIS.
MERITS CAN. AS IT WOULD REAL TO
LOWER IN AND- I'M AT THIS POINT
WE DON'T HAVE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND SO THERE ARE KEY
QUESTIONS AND WE WOULD
SUMMARIZE FOR OR BRING FOR TIER
TENSION. THE FIRST IS WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE PARTICIPATION
RATE IS HIGHER THAN EXPECTED.
RESULTING IN A LARGER REDUCTION
IN FINE AND FEE REVENUE THAN.
ANTICIPATED TO NEED IT. THE
SECOND QUESTION IS HOW MUCH
FUNDING WOULD BE PROVIDED FOR
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATION AND
OUTRAGE COSTS. THE THIRD
QUESTION IS HOW WOULD THE BACK
FULL TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BE
DISTRIBUTED. AND THE FOURTH
QUESTION IS HOW WOULD THE
PROGRAM OPERATE IN TANDEM- WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL
TO EXPAND ONLINE EDUCATION OF
INFRACTIONS AND ABILITY TO PAY
DETERMINATION STATEWIDE. AND SO
ANSWERS TO TESE QUESTIONS ARE
CRITICAL TO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO WAIVE THIS
PROPOSAL AGAINST OTHER
PRIORITIES. AS WELL AS TO
ENSURE THAT IT IS STRUCTURED
AND OPERATED IN A MANNER
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES AND EXPECTATIONS.
THE FINAL THING THAT WE WOULD
KNOW IS THAT- IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY NEED
TO ADDRESS THE IMPACT OF
REVENUE REDUCTIONS TO OTHER
STATE FUNDS. THAT RECEIVE
CONFINING THE REVENUE AND
SUPPORT- ENDED THE LEGISLATURE
DOES HAVE VERY OPTIONS VARIOUS
OPTIONS FOR DOING SO- BUT A
BACK FILL FOR THEM IS NOT
INCLUDED AS PART OF THIS.
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
I DO APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
THAT THE L. A. L. HATH. LAID
OUT- IN ADDITION TO THOSE
QUESTIONS ON THE DEBT
FORGIVENESS. PROGRAM I'D BE
INTERESTED IN OUR DEFINITION
FOR LOW INCOME AND WHAT THAT
CAPTURES. AND THEN ARE WE
STARTING TO ENGAGE AND- I GUESS
A MORE ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT
NOT JUST ONE TIMES BUT LOOKING
AT ADJUSTING THE SYSTEM TO MAKE
IT MORE EQUITABLE AND FAIR. IT
WILL BE IN FLORIDA- FOR ANYONE
AND NOT JUST. AT THIS MOMENT OF
SURPLUS. JUST A REMINDER BERMAN
OF FINANCE- THIS DEBT
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM IS TARGETED
SPECIFICALLY FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND ASK NICELY
APPOINTED OUT AND WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON CHECK THE BILL
LANGUAGE WHICH WOULD BE.
PROVIDED TO US FOR WORKING IS A
COMPLICATED DRAFT BE TROUBLING
WHICH FOR THE PROPOSAL IN ONE
OF THE TECHNICIANS WILL BE. WHO
EXACTLY WOULD QUALIFY AS LOW
INCOME AND WE'RE STILL WORKING
TO SPECIFIED. WHAT LOW INCOME
WOULD NEED AS IT RELATES TO
THAT THE FACT. COPY. THE WOULD
LET LOOK FORWARD TO THE TO
THOSE DISCUSSIONS THAT ON THAT
DEFINITION A LOW INCOME DO WE
HAVE ANY IS THIS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ADMINISTRATION
LOOKING AT. HOW TO ENGAGE IN A
DISCUSSION TO. MAKE THE
SEPARATE EVENTS PROGRAMS PER
MINUTE. SHOULD WE NOT TRY TO
HELP THIS LONGTIME PEOPLE AT
ALL TIMES NOT JUST WHEN WE HAVE
ROSY. BUDGETS. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION BUT AS FAR AS THE
DEBT FORGIVENESS PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES- RETROACTIVELY RELIEF
FOR INFRACTION TICKETS EACH
YEAR IN THE PAST TWENTY FIFTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
MOVING FORWARD INTO THE FUTURE-
AND ENTERED INTO BEYOND THE
QUALIFYING TIME PERIOD
SPECIFIED THE- TWENTY FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
OBJECTIVE WOULD BE FOR A
PERSPECTIVE EARLY TO BE
PROVIDED THROUGH THE ABILITY TO
PAY. A PROGRAM WHERE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD APPLY TO HAVE
THEIR FINES AND FEES ARE
REDUCED BY AT LEAST. BY 50% I'M
SO THAT WOULD BE THE PLAN
MOVING FORWARD. SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE IS- SOME SORT OF
PLAN A MOVING FORWARD I WOULD
BE INTERESTED AND MORE ROBUST.
DISCUSSIONS UP 50% IS HELPFUL
BUT FOR SOME OF OUR LOW INCOME
FOLKS IT'S NOT GOING TO BE.
ENOUGH OUT THERE AND SO I DO
THINK AS WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE
A MORE EQUITABLE SYSTEM OF THE
THING THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
INTO. I WOULD THESE BE SOME
PLANS THAT WE HAVE OUT THERE.
WELL I UNDERSTAND WE NEED TO
HAVE A PLAN TO ALSO BACK. AS
SADDAM SERVICES THAT WE HAVE
OUT THERE. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES. MR
STILL. WELL CERTAINLY ON THAT
LAST QUESTION A DEBT
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM. THIS IS
BECAUSE IT'S COME UP I THINK IN
IN CONTEXT OF THE PANDEMIC IT'S
JUST A BIT OF A BANDAIDAND
WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO IS
TAKE  HARD LOOK AT THE FINES
AND FEES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WE'VE TOO LONG USED FINES AND
FEES OR AS WAYS OF FUNDING
PROGRAMS. YEAH THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS IT'S REALLY GOTTEN
OUT OF HAND I THINK THE CHIEF
JUSTICE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THAT. SO THAT INVESTMENT THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS HAVING
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE LOOK AT
FINES AND FEES WHERE WE'VE
GOTTEN WHERE WE'VE GOTTEN AND
HOW. ULTIMATELY WE FUND THAT. I
JUST WANT TO TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT
THE TRIAL COURT BACKLOG AS WELL
I'M VERY INTERESTED IN. A LOT
MORE DETAIL AROUND. WHAT THOSE
PROPOSALS ARE FOR REDUCING THE
BACKLOG WE'VE HELD HEARINGS.
WITH THE JUDICIAL BRANCH IN AND
THERE WEREN'T NOT A LOT OF
ANSWERS THAT CAME. OUT OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS SO FOR US TO HAVE.
A LOT MORE DIRECT. INPUT AND
OVERSIGHT IN THOSE PROGRAMS AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY ARE. IS
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT I'M
NOT TALKING AT ALL AT THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS WE NEED TO HELP
THE COURTS ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
REDUCING THE THEIR BACKLOGS.
BUT WE DID NOT GET VERY CLEAR
ANSWERS ABOUT WHAT. THEY WOULD
BE DOING OR HOW THEY WOULD BE
DOING IT. AND THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT. OF AND IN INDEPENDENCE
COUNTY BY COUNTY ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COURTS WANTED TO DO
THINGS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY
I THINK THIS IS AN AREA WE WANT
TO SEE SOME CONSISTENCY. IN A
IN A PLAN AND IN MAY A PROGRAM.
OKAY THEN WE WILL CONTINUE THIS
CAFFEINE- THESE ITEMS TO
APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE ON. TWO PANEL MEMBERS
SIX THREE AND I HAVE CDCR TALK
ABOUT CAPITAL OUTLAY. FRIEDMAN
ROBIN ARE SEVEN A START OUT
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE THIS IS ON
THE HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT LEASE REVENUE BONDS
TO GENERAL FUND. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD WITHDRAW OUR APRIL ONE
FINANCE LETTER FOR FORTY THREE
MILLION TWO HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND LEASE REVENUE BOND
ISSUERS E. RIVER ARE EXISTING
LEASE REVENUE BOND OF THE ORDER
THAT WE HAVE NOT YET SOLD BONDS
ON A FORTY EIGHT MILLION ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND.
AND REPLACE BOTH OF THOSE WITH
A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MILLION
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND WHICH DOES INCLUDE AN
AUGMENTATION OR NET INCREASE OF
TWENTY FOUR MILLION TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND. IN ORDER
TO FUND THE REMAINING HALF OF
PROJECTS WITH GENERAL FUND
INSTEAD OF EXISTING LEASE
REVENUE BOND FINANCING
AUTHORITY. THEFUNDING FOR
THESE PROJECTS IS CURRENTLY
DERIVED FROM BOND PROCEEDS.
GENERATED THROUGH ASSET
TRANSFER ASSET TRANSFERS
HOWEVER THIS TIME IT IS UNCLEAR
WHETHER THE VALUE OF THE
REMAINING ASSETS AT CDC ARE
SUFFICIENT TO COMPLETE THESE
PROJECTS I WILL TURN THE TIME
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE JUSTIN
EDELMAN OPERATION OVER TO.
HELLO BEFORE YOU APPLY. TO HOW
INTERNET- RATED COULD TOTALLY
WITH IT PROJECT. AND POINTED
OUT IN ALL FOR THE FOR PRODUCT.
BUT YEAH BECAUSE OF THE GRANT.
FONG CAPITAL. TO COME. FROM THE-
IN A QUIET. THAT MINISTER TEND
TO CLOSE THE DOOR OKAY
INSTITUTION. BY SEPTEMBER
THIRTIETH TWENTY. AND
CALIFORNIA. CENTER BY JUNE.
TWENTY TWENTY. COVER WHAT. IT
POPULATIONS THAT THAT THE STATE
OUGHT TO BE A- BECAUSE THERE
ARE THREE ADDITIONAL PRISON
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS- BASED
ON INITIAL REVIEW WE FIND THAT
CAL. WOULD TO NOR. THE
CALIFORNIA MANY COLONY SEEMS.
AND OBISPO. THANK GOODNESS IT
PRESIDENT AND THE ACCOUNT
TWENTY FACILITY SEAT YEAH GOOD
OLD STRONG AND- FOR. OR BASED
LARGELY ON THE HAPPENED A FIVE.
RELATIVELY IN THE- CITY. AND
THE- PROPOSAL CAPITAL OUTLAY
THAT WILL BE DISCUSSED. IF THE
THAT THE PROPOSAL'S. VERY FIRST
INCLUDE ONCE THE ATTENDED BY.
ABOUT BASS FROM. YEAH BUT-
FOR
MAKING ANY EXPENDITURES WITH
THE PROPOSED FUNDING I HAVE PER
A LOT OF THE- FOR CANCEL CLOSER.
SO ETF. ON THE LEFT OF THE
PARTY BUT FLORIDA PRISON CLOSE
OF. SHOWING THE THOSE WITH.
WILL NOT BE CLOSED THANK YOU.
JUST MOMENT APART AND FINANCE
ECONOMIC FIRST CONGRESS TO THE
A. AS- REGARDING PRISON CLOTHES
AND I DON'T WITH LIVING IN OUR
TOPIC TO- I JUST WANTED
REITERATE THAT I. OF BIRTH TO
CLOSE YOU CAN. CLOSE IF A VERY
CALM ISSUE- CAN OCCUR TWENTY
SIX SEVEN IDENTIFIES THE THERE
THINGS THAT THE DEPARTMENT AND
OF EDUCATION SHOULD. ONE AT
PRISON UP JUST. MORE THAN JUST
CALL FOR FIFTH IN THE
MAINTENANCE OF THE A. I WAS I
FOR THE PAVE IDENTIFY. AND WE
ALSO NEED TO AT THINGS. WE'RE
EXPERIENCING BUT AGAIN I JUST
WANT TO DEMONSTRATE THAT IT'S A
VERY DIFFICULT ISSUE AT CLOSING
OR EVEN IDENTIFYING A LIST OF
PRISONS ACTUALLY CLOSE HAS
ENORMOUS IMPLICATIONS FOR THE
STAFF AND INMATES WORKING IN
THOSE FACILITIES. ARE IN NINE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING FOR SOME
OF THESE AREAS YOU KNOW WE
POTENTIALLY RISK. I THINK. I'M
MAINTENANCE- JUST RELIABILITY
AND OTHER KIND OF ISSUES WITH
YES THE PLANT OPERATIONS AT
THOSE FACILITIES- IT'S
DRAMATICALLY ACTING POTENTIALLY
THE DEPARTMENT'S IMPACT-
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND RISKS OF
LITIGATE INJURY DESTRUCTIONS TO
PROGRAMMING AND THINGS LIKE
THAT- AS TO THE SECOND ISSUE
ARE MOVING TOO QUICKLY- IT'S AN
ADDITIONAL REQUEST FOR FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. IN
ADDITION TO THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS I REQUESTED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SO THIS WOULD
BRING THE TOTAL REQUEST FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
THAT CDCR TWO HUNDRED MILLION-
THE PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES A
LIST TO BE ATTACHED YEAH THOSE.
ARE PROJECTS IT'S EASIER HAVE
IDENTIFIED VETERANS AND READY
STATE. TO BEGIN. IT WENT ON
YOUR WITH THE L. A. O. GIVEN
THIS. WIDE THE SIGNIFICANT
STATE WHY PRISON IN. NEEDS WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE IT.
HUNDRED MILLION AND MEATS YOU
THE ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION.
BRINGING IT TO HUNDRED MILLION
AND ONE TIME DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SPECIAL REPAIR OF
FUNDING FOR CDC ARE. BUT AS MY
COLLEAGUE LUKE NOTED WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT-
IMPLEMENTING ONE OF THESE
PROJECTS OUT OF PRISON THAT IS
THEN- CLOSE SHORTLY THEREAFTER.
SO WE RECOMMEND APPROVING
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE FIND THAT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR- WHEN
CONFRONTATION AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT'S TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR. BASED BUDGET FOR
SPECIAL RIPARIAN DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROHIBITING CITIES
HERE FROM SPENDING THE FUNDS ON
PRISON BETTER STRONG CANDIDATES
FOR CLOSURE. IN LESS IT CAN PUT
FLORIDA ATLANTIC PUTS FORWARD A
PLAN DEMONSTRATING. WHY THOSE
PRISONS WILL BE CLOSED.
GRANDDAUGHTER OTHER PARTS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
THIS PROPOSAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR MEN-
FIFTY BED MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
FACILITY REAPPROPRIATION WILL
AGREE APPROPRIATE NINETY ONE
MILLION THIRTY TWO THOUSAND.
PUBLIC BUILDINGS CONSTRUCTION
FUND ALSO KNOWN AS LEASE
REVENUE BOND AT THE READY. FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THE
PROJECT THAT WILL DESIGN
CONSTRUCT A LICENSE FIFTY BED
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS FACILITY.
I CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE FOR MEN
IN CHINO. THIS PROJECT HAS BEEN
DELAYED DUE TO RECENT
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT LITIGATION. THIS
PROJECT IS PART OF THE STATE'S
EFFORT TO COMPLY WITH A COURT
ORDERED IMPROVEMENTS STATEWIDE.
AND IS BEING MONITORED MONTHLY
BY THE COURTS. READ MORE OF THE
L. A. O. WE DID NOT RAISE
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL. K.
MOVING ON SAID THE FOURTH ITEM
THAT THESE NEXT THIRTEEN
PROPOSALS LIKE THE LAST REBELS
ARE ALSO RE APPROPRIATIONS. BUT
THIRTEEN SEPARATE PROJECTS
TOTAL THIRTY MILLION NINETY SIX
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND FOR THE
REAPPROPRIATION OF THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF THE
THIRTEEN. MEDICATION
DISTRIBUTION IMPROVEMENT. PHASE
TWO PROJECTS THESE THREE
PREPARATIONS ARE NEEDED IN
ORDER TO ENSURE SUFFICIENT TIME
FOR THE WORKING DRAWINGS PHASE
TO BE COMPLETED. THESE PROJECTS
ARE ALSO PART OF THE STATE'S
EFFORT TO COMPLY WITH COURT
ORDERED IMPROVEMENTS STATEWIDE.
WE KNOW THAT THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD INCLUDE FIND RESOURCES
ACTIVITY HAPPEN THE PERSONS WE
HAVE IDENTIFIED AT THIS FROM
HIM FOR CLOSER. I THOUGHT.
PROJECTS WE RECOMMENDED.
TALKING BUDGET ABOUT SOLUTION.
TWO RESTRICTED FROM AN EX ON
MEDICARE AND THAT A LOT TO TRY
TO A POSITIVE CANCER CLOSER
WITH SUCH A AND THE TICKET.
UNLESS THE DEPARTMENT BUT THE
PART BUDGET BUT THIS FACILITY-
THAT THE BUDGET DIRECTOR OF. AS
YOU CAN SEE COLLATERAL WILL NOT
BE CLOSED THANK YOU. AND THEN
ON ISSUE FIVE A MINUTES FROM-
OVER TO MICHAEL BRANDON MERIT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BRING IN TO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THIS
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY IS TO
APPROPRIATE FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE PRELIMINARY PLANS
AND WORKING DRAWINGS. PHASES OF
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FACILITY STOCKTON FACILITY BE
INDIVIDUAL EXERCISE YARDS
PROJECT WITH TOTAL PROJECT
COSTS OF FOUR POINT THREE SIX
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS. THIS
PROPOSAL REQUESTS FUNDING TO
DESIGN TEN INDIVIDUAL EXERCISE
YARDS AND FACILITY B. AT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE FACILITY
STOCKTON THIS WILL ALLOW
MAXIMUM CUSTODY PATIENTS
RECEIVING INPATIENT MENTAL
HEALTH. TREATMENT TO
PARTICIPATE IN MORE OUT OF CELL
RECREATION THERAPY THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH OUR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT PLAN. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO WOULD ADDRESS THE
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MONITORING REPORT FILED BY THE
COLEMAN SPECIAL MASTER. IN
WHICH IT IS INDICATED THAT
MAXIMUM CUSTODY PATIENTS HAD
EXTREMELY LIMITED TIME. FOR
STRUCTURED OR UNSTRUCTURED OUT
OF CELL THERAPY ACTIVITY EACH
WEEK. IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS
THEM AT THIS TIME. CABALLERO
CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL
GIVEN THIS PARTICULAR PRISON IS
VERY UNLIKELY TO BE CLOSED.
THANK YOU ARE NOT A QUESTION
BUT A COMMENT WE'RE STILL
TRYING TO. GET THE F. R. ALL IN
THE LONG TERM FACILITY PLAN OUT
THERE AND SO I THINK UNTIL WE
HAVE THAT. SETTLED THIS
COMMITTEE THIS AND FEEL
COMFORTABLE IN MOVING FORWARD I
HAVE. WITH WITH ANY OF THESE
RESOURCES- AND SO IT JUST FELT
THAT WE COULD GET TO A
CONCLUSION SOON- YOU'VE HEARD
IN PREVIOUS. COMMITTEES THAT
DESIRE STRONG DESIRE FROM THESE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT THERE AND GET
TO A PLACE WE CAN FIND COMMON
GROUND. YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. CAN THANK YOU AND
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE
ON. TWO PADDLED SEVEN. AND
WE'RE GONNA PUT THIS UP INTO
TWO CHUNKS WILL HAVE ITEMS ONE
THROUGH EIGHT FIRST CDCR NON
CAPITAL OUTLAYS. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR JUST NAME A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROJECTED
OVERALL ON COURSE RATED AVERAGE
DAILY POPULATION OF ABOUT
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND AND TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO ASPIRIN PROJECTIONS
NOW ESTIMATED INCARCERATED
POPULATION OF ABOUT A HUNDRED
SIX THOUSAND WHICH IS AN
INCREASE OF ROUGHLY ELEVEN
THOUSAND. FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROJECTIONS THIS IS
LARGELY DUE TO. THE RESUMPTION
OF INTAKE AND SPECIFICALLY A
RAMP UP OF THE INTAKE FROM
THOSE COUNTY JAILS WHERE
INMATES HAVE BEEN HOUSE DURING
THE COOK AT NINETEEN ENDEMIC-
THESE PROJECTIONS NOW ESTIMATE
AT WEEKLY INTAKE OF ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS- WHICH IS.
MADE RELATIVELY LATE IN APRIL.
THAT MAKE INTO FOREVER WAS
ABOUT SIX AND TO SEVEN SO IT'S
A VERY ELEVATE NUMBER- IT
DEPARTMENTS IT'S S. ESTIMATING
TO INTAKE THOSE COUNTY JAILS.
I'M ON NO ON THE LAST TIME I TO
THE THAT. I'VE MET THAT THERE
WERE TEN THOUSAND. IN COUNTY
JAIL AWAITING TRANSFER AS OF
MAY FOURTEENTH THAT NUMBER IS
DOWN TO ABOUT SEVENTY THREE
HUNDRED SO WE HAVE SEEN SOME
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN THAT
BACKLOG. AT THE DEPARTMENT AND
IT TAKES ME OR INDIVIDUALS-
INTO THE PRESENCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- ALSO
PROJECTS UP. POP OF A FORTY
THOUSAND IN THE BUDGET. AT THIS
IS A BY TWO- ROUGHLY FIVE. IN
THE MAY REVISION- THIS WILL
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY NINE POINT SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. LASTLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROJECTED A
POPULATION IN JUVENILE JUSTICE
FOR THE WARDS OF ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. THAT'S NOW
DECLINED SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO IN THE BUDGET YEAR HI THIS
IS ANTICIPATED TO RESULT IN
SAVINGS OF APPROXIMATELY TEN
POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL FUND
AS OUT. JUVENILE JUSTICE AND IN
A CONTAINED BEGINS CALTRAIN
OFFICIALS THOSE PARTS TO THE
COUNTIES. THAT ANSWER QUESTIONS
AT THE END OF THE SECOND. A NO
DEAL WITH THE L. A. L. THEN
MAYBE VISION SEEMS ABOUT THAT
THAT DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND MORE INMATES IN
THE BUDGET YEAR THAN WAS
PREVIOUSLY ASSUMED AT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WHICH
TRANSLATES TO OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN COST- AS
MISTREATMENT NOTED THIS IS.
LARGELY ASSOCIATED WITH- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ASSUMPTION
THAT WILL IT WILL- BEGIN IN
TAKING OUR CONTINUE IN TAKING
THE BACKLOG OF INMATES FROM
COUNTY JAILS THAT HAVE BEEN.
SERVING THEIR PRISON TERMS
THERE WHILE IN THE INTAKE HAS
BEEN STOPPED OVER THE OVER MUCH
OF THE PAST YEAR DUE TO COVER
IT- HOWEVER THESE PROJECTIONS
DON'T ACCOUNT FOR THE TIME THAT
THOSE INMATES HAVE BEEN
SERVING. ON THEIR PRISON
SENTENCES WHILE THEY'VE BEEN
INCARCERATED IN COUNTY JAIL- SO
WE FIND THAT THIS- THIS THE
POPULATION IS LIKELY
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER ESTIMATED AS
A RESULT- ALTHOUGH WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT IS FAIRLY
DIFFICULT TO ESTIMATE. ON WHAT
THE ACTUAL POPULATION WILL BE-
AND SO WE RECOMMEND APPROVING
THE FUNDING BUT ADOPTING BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE SPECIFYING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT SHALL REFER TO
THE GENERAL FUND ANY FUNDING IT
RECEIVED ASSOCIATED WITH
INMATES IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. BUT IT DID. NOT END
UP ACTUALLY SERVING. NO THIS
ENSURE THAT THE- DOES NOT USE
THE BUDGET FOR THE M.
POPULATION FOR PER. THAT MAYBE
PRIORITIES OF THE DEPARTMENT
I'M NOT NECESSARILY PRIORITIES
OF THE LEGISLATURE SO THIS IS
REALLY- TO HELP ENHANCE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT- AND NOW
I'D LIKE TO PASS IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE LUCAS MARIO TO-
COMMENT ON OTHER ASPECTS OF THE
POPULATION RELATED. PROPOSALS
IF YOU ARE THE L. A. O. OKAY
SPEAKING ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES POSITION WHICH CPR
JEFF THE NUMBER OF PETITIONS
BASED ON THE SIZE OF THE INMATE
POPULATION ANNUALLY. LAST YEAR
TO GET YOUR SPENT ON TO FILL
ALL OF THE SERVICE CALL
INSURANCE AND I FEEL I SURPLUS.
FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH THE
VACANT POSITIONS FOR BALLOTS
FOR EXAMPLE DISCARDED UNDER
COURT ORDER TO A CERTAIN LEVEL
SERVICES FOR FIVE YEAH.
PSYCHIATRIST APPOINTMENTS AND
VISITS AND SO THEY AFFECT. ME
DATA PHILBRICK I CRIED FOR
EXERTIONS AT NINETY PERCENT.
BECAUSE OF THAT APARTMENT
BUILDING THOSE POSITIONS
THEY'VE REPRODUCTIVE A PORTION
OF THE SALARY SAVINGS TO
SUPPORT HIGH CONTRACTORS LIKE
PRIVATELY. REGISTRY SERVICES.
GOOD LUCK MARKEDLY IT BY MANY
BIG THIS ARE BEING. AND ALL
TICKETS ARE PLAN TO FULLY
UNLIMITED POSITION IS A
QUESTION TO READ A LARGE
PORTION OF FUNDING THE FOR THE-
BASICALLY THEY EIGHT INTENDED
TO. RETAIN FOR NINE POINT THREE
AM IN TWO TWENTY ONE. AND FORTY
ONE THREE IN TWENTY TWO ONE ONE
GOLAN- DATA. BE REQUIRED. THE
MINISTRY EDITOR OF THE ABOUT
MILLION OF WOULD GET USED FOR
CHARACTER BREAKFAST OR SERVICE.
RATHER AMOUNT WOULD BE USED
ABOUT HEALTH SO IF YOU COULD A
LIMITED THE- AND THEN IN THAT
THIS FUNDING WHAT. I FORGOT WE
ADDRESS OTHER PURPOSES IN THE
MIDDLE HEALTH. BUT THEY HAVE
NOT PROVIDED A INFORMATION
BECAUSE WHAT PURPOSES ARE
SUPPORT OF THE THREE. FUNDING
ACCORDING TO THE RECOMMENDED
FOR. READING A LOT OF MILLION
AND THEN BASIS THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. A COUPLE FOR WHAT
WAS A KIND REGISTRY SERVICES.
AND EVERYTHING- COMMITTEE TERM
IS BECAUSE THESE LIKE I BREXIT
FROM THAT ARE. SUPPOSED TO BE-
I THINK SO UNTIL ALL OF THE
RESTRICTION CARE. BUILD THEIR-
SEVERAL SORT OF PSYCHIATRIST
THIS AND I SUCH DON'T ON GOING
PUBLIC IS ACROSS. AND THEN
AMERICAN NOT A READ THE
REMAINING WITH BY THE- AND THEM
IT'S INTO. THAT THE REDIRECTED
IS YOU FOR A PURPOSE CONSISTENT
WITH THE LESSER PRIORITIES.
TWENTY JUST NAY ABOUT A FINANCE
AND I JUST TO REST. AS RECORD.
TO INCLUDE BUDGET THAT LANGUAGE.
SIX IT WITH A COPY PROJECTIONS
AND FUNDING SO WITH. I WOULD
ARE COMMITTED ON BELIEVE THAT
FUNDING THAT. LANGUAGES
NECESSARY FOR JOB. AMAZONIAN
THAT THEY IS A LOT OF FUN SIR
WITH THESE FOR. PRODUCTION IN
REGARD TO THE INTAKE REGARD TO
IT. NUMBER OF MONTHS THAT
INDIVIDUALS MIGHT HAVE SERVED
ALREADY COUNTY JAIL EVERY WEEK
YOU WANT TO NOTE THAT THAT MOST
LIKELY TO IMPACT. YOUR
PROJECTIONS- AND WE DO IF THERE
IS SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY WITH
THOSE HOWEVER THAT WOULD BE
AMENDED INTO. THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ALL GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROJECTIONS FOR POPULATION AND
AGAIN WE JUST DON'T THINK IT'S
NECESSARY TO INCLUDE BUDGET
BELT LANGUAGE SPECIFIC. TO THIS
UPCOMING BUDGET EAR- AS FAR AS
THAT PSYCHIATRY POSITIONS AND
FINAL TURN. THAT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE I WAS. I WASN'T A
DIFFERENT OF FINANCE OF
INTEREST TO THE ALEJO'S.
REGARDING THE MENTAL.
POPULATION IT. THE
MINISTRATIONS FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL JUSTIFICATION TO
ADDRESS THE ALEJO'S CONCERNS
AND WERE ULTIMATELY OPEN TO
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT AN ONGOING
SOLUTION. EVENTUALLY BE
ADMINISTRATION TAILORED A
REASONABLE SOLUTION TO ADDRESS
THE BUDGET GAP I'M FOR THIS
CRITICAL PROGRAM THAT AND THAT
PROVIDES ESSENTIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. I'M TO
PATIENTS THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM
AND SO THERE WAS IT KIND OF AB
I'M RISKY IF WE DIDN'T AT- CAN
ADDRESS THAT THROUGH THIS
PROPOSAL AND SAID UNDER THE
ALEJO'S RECOMMENDATION AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO FILL POSITIONS
BECAUSE- THEY WOULD BE
PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE A
PORTION OF FUNDING THAT WOULD
BE DEDICATED TO CIVIL SERVICE
POSITIONS WHILE RETAINING
REGISTRY FUNDING. JUST WANT TO
NOTE THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
NOT TYPICALLY DO THIS TYPE OF
RIGHT SIZING EXERCISE- BUT FOR
THE SIGNIFICANT POPULATION
ADJUSTMENT AND THAT WAS DRIVEN
BY THE IMPACT OF KOBE NINETEEN.
I'M SO HAPPY TAKE CONTINUOUS
CONVERSATIONS. AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL JUSTIFICATION.
REFORM OF THE L. L. BIG AN- I
DON'T RECOGNIZE. THAT WOULD NOT
BE A PROGRAM I GET BACK
PROVIDED THE MINISTER CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE
REPRODUCTIVE. IS BEING USED FOR
PURPOSES CONSISTENT WITH THE
LOGIC OF PRIORITIES THANK YOU.
OKAY MOVING ON TO ISSUE TO
CLOSURE OF THE LOCATIONAL
INSTITUTION UPDATE LENNY SHOULD
MATTER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THIS PROPOSAL IS A REDUCTION OF
FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS RELATED TO
THE CLOSURE OF THE DUAL
VOCATIONAL INSTITUTION. IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY ONE THIS
ADJUSTMENT CAPTURES THE UPDATED
TIMELINE FOR CLOSER FOR EACH
HOUSING UNIT WHICH IS NOW
STAGGERED BETWEEN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THROUGH SEPTEMBER
TWENTY ONE. AT NOELIA CONCERNS
ON THIS PROPOSAL. THAT'S NAY
AMEND ARE GONNA FINANCE- FOR
ISSUE NUMBER THREE EIGHT IT'S
THE EXPANSION OF VICTIM SUPPORT
SERVICES SPECIFICALLY AT THIS
REQUEST WOULD BE FOR A ONE
POINT THREE MILLION GENERAL
FUND COMPETITIVE ISSUE I'M
GOING TO INCREASE SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR VICTIMS SURVIVORS
AND THEIR FAMILIES SPECIFICALLY
THIS PROPOSAL IS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT ENHANCE AND FOUR
SECONDS RIGHT I AM RIPPING A
PAROLE HEARING PROCESS FOR
VICTIMS AND PROMOTING HEALING
AND RESTORATIVE JUSTICE THE
EXPANSION OF PROFESSIONAL
EMPLOYMENT. SERVICES INCLUDING
THE VICTIM OFFENDER DIALOGUE.
NO REALLY OF CONCERN MR. AND I
WASN'T SURE WHAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COVERING IF YOU FOR
INSTANCE EACH YEAR IS
REQUESTING RESOURCES AND TO
EXPAND ITS CIVIL RIGHTS
OPERATIONS EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAM AND THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WILL ENABLE CDCR TO
ACHIEVE FULL COMPLIANCE WITH
THE TWENTY. EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
DIRECTOR OF THAT I WAS INTENDED
TO ADDRESS DISCRIMINATION AND
HARASSMENT IN STATE GOVERNMENT
AND THESE RESOURCES WILL ENABLE
CDCR TO FULLY IMPLEMENT A
CENTRALIZED DISCRIMINATION
COMPLAINT PROCESS AND THEREBY
REDUCING THE RISK OF BIAS IN
INCONSISTENT FINDINGS ANY
CHEATING FULL COMPLIANCE WITH
THE CALAVERAS GUIDANCE WE KNOW
THAT THIS UP THIS PROPOSAL WAS
INITIALLY PUT FORWARD IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET BUT WITHDRAWN- IN LIGHT
OF THAT FISCAL. CONDITIONS
DRIVEN BY CORBETT NINETEEN. BUT
NO OTHER INTERNS ON THIS
PROPOSAL. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
GOOD AFTERNOON ANTHONY FRIENDS
AWAY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE VALLEY STATE
PRISON ENHANCEMENTS- DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
REQUEST BOTH ONE TIME AND
ONGOING RESOURCES TO SUPPORT A
NUMBER OF BEST PRACTICES
MODIFICATIONS THAT DOLLARS
STATE PRISON TO BRING
INSTITUTION MORE IN LINE WITH
THE NORWAY MODEL- THIS IS
BECAUSE NORWAY IS CONSIDERED TO
BE A MODEL CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM
GIVEN THE WAY OUT OF ITS
FACILITIES. LEVEL THREE PEOPLE
AHEAD OF SERVICES OFFERED AND A
PROVEN SUCCESS IN POST RELEASE
OUTCOMES SPECIFICALLY IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO CITY
STARS REQUESTING NINE POINT
EIGHT POSITIONS AND THIRTEEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. IN THE CLEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE IT'S
THREE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND AND THEN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR NON. GOING
OUT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND. THE MODIFICATION
ARE IN SO LORD WHICH I'LL GO
THROUGH QUICKLY THE FIRST IS
UPGRADED THE FAMILY VISITATION
AREAS WITH NEW FURNITURE. THE
SECOND IS FOR TWO MODULAR
BUILDING SIX THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET EACH TO SUPPORT INCREASED
PROGRAMMING. THE THIRD IS TO
NEW BACHELOR DEGREE PROGRAMS.
ONE THAT SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED
ON STEM PATHWAYS. THE FOURTH IS
INCREASED CAREER TECHNICAL
TRAINING IN ADDITION TO
INCREASED A REENTRY EMPLOYMENT
PREPARATION THE FIFTH IS
GREATER ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
VIA THIN CLIENT LAPTOPS. AND
FINALLY THE SIX THIS PROGRAM
EVALUATION TO SEE WHAT EFFECT
THESE CHANGES HAVE ON POST
RELEASE OUTCOMES. REVISION ARE
OVER THE L. A. L. WE THINK THAT
THIS PROGRAM COULD HAVE MERIT
BUT THE OVERALL EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
UNCLEAR. AS A BARGAIN MY NAME
IS MENTIONED IN THE PROGRAM
DOESN'T INCLUDE A RESOURCES
PHONE ABOUT INFLATION IN THOSE
PARTS OF SARGANTWOULD BE
PROVIDED THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE. I RECOMMEND
MAKING THE FUNDING LIMITED
TERM. TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND ACCORDING TO
DEPARTMENT REPORT ON THE
RESULTS OF THE EVALUATION NO
LATER THAN OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THIS IS A LOT
LESS EFFORT YOU THAT YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT HOW WE CAN
DETERMINE WHETHER THE ONGOING
RESOURCE THAT SHOULD BE
PROVIDED FOR THE PROGRAM
BEGINNING IN. TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU. I
HAVE A FRIEND AHEAD OF OUR
FINAL AGAIN- TO BE A- I WILL
ALSO NEED TO CDC. AND WHETHER
OR NOT THE- THINKS. THE DOCTOR
TWENTY- TWENTY THREE IS ENOUGH
TIME TO COLLECT SUFFICIENT
DATA- BUT I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THE STEM BACHELOR DEGREE
PROGRAM IS NOT SCHEDULED TO
START UNTIL. IT'S CLEAR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
THAT IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH TIME-
TO CLICK SUFFICIENT DATA TO
MAKE CAUSAL CLAIMS ABOUT THE
OUTCOMES. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
COLLECTING DATA- WILL BE
HELPFUL TO GET PROGRAM
EFFECTIVENESS- TO POSSIBLY
UNDERTAKE EXPANSION THIS.
TARGET EXPANSIONS TO OTHER
INSTITUTIONS- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- BUT IT'S NOT INTENDED TO
SAY THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE NOT
ALREADY EVIDENCE BASED FOR
EFFECTIVE- YOU KNOW THESE
PROGRAMS ARE. ARE CHANGES THAT
IS THERE ARE WELL KNOWN
THROUGHOUT THE CORRECTIONS
REHABILITATION WORLD- AGAIN
INCREASED ACCESS TO EDUCATION
AND CAREER TECHNICAL TRAINING
THOSE SORTS OF THINGS- AND
THEY'VE BEEN PROVEN IN OTHER
CONTEXTS WHICH IS. THE ROOT OF.
THE PROPOSAL IN THE NORWAY
MODEL. REALLY SHOULD MATTER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ISSUE SIX
AND MEET THE CETACEAN EXPANSION
TO THREE DAYS THIS IS A REQUEST
FOR TWENTY POINT THREE MILLION
TO ADD A THIRD DAY VISITING AT
THIRTY FOUR INSTITUTIONS. AND
PROVIDE VISITORS WITH FREE
TRANSPORTATION ARM CHARTER
BUSES ON SELECT DAYS THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR. VISITATION PROVIDES
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ESTABLISH AND
MAINTAIN A CONTINUUM OF SOCIAL
SUPPORT. INCLUDING PARENT CHILD
RELATIONSHIPS WHICH ARE
CRITICAL FOR SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
AND THESE RESOURCES WOULD HELP
SUPPORT BACK ALL. NOELIA
CONCERNS ON THIS PROPOSAL. I
THINK YOU AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HOW QUICKLY COVER
ISSUES SEVEN EIGHT AND I'LL
JUMP AHEAD A LITTLE BIT TO
ISSUE NINE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
VARIOUS STATUTORY CHANGES THE
FIRST IS TO CODIFY EXISTING
PRACTICES AS IT RELATES TO
COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAMS. THE
SECOND INVOLVES CREATING A
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK THAT WILL
FACILITATE STATE LOCAL
PARTNERSHIPS TO CONTINUE
OPERATIONS AT PINE GROVE YOUTH
CONSERVATION CAMP AND THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT THAT
WAS EXPRESSED IN CHAPTER AT
THREE THREE SEVEN STATUS OF
TWENTY TWENTY I SB ARE THE
BETTER KNOWN AS I SPEAK TO
THREE AND THE THIRD WILL EXPAND
THE MEMBERSHIP OF THE
CALIFORNIA SEX OFFENDER
MANAGEMENT BOARD TO INCLUDE
EXPERTS I SPECIFICALLY. ON THE
TREATMENT OF JUVENILE SEX
OFFENDERS. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. HELLO OTHER CONCERNS
ON THESE ITEMS. OKAY SO I DO WE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON THE
FIRST LINE ITEMS COVERED HERE.
MISTER JONES SAWYER BUT I JUST
WANTED TO CAMP- TO COMMENT ON
NUMBER FIVE TO VALLEY STATE
PRISON IN HARASSMENT. AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS PERSONALLY GONE
TO NORWAY. WITH THE SECRETARY'S
CDCR AND THE PRESIDENT OF
CCPOA- I FOUND IT. NOT ONLY IS
AN INSTRUCTIVE. BUT IT IS THE
WAY TO GO AND I ENCOURAGE IS
NOT ONLY TO LOOK AT THIS MODEL.
AND PROVIDE THE ENHANCEMENTS TO
DO EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED TO
DO HERE I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING. IS TO
DOCUMENT. ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ESTABLISH SOME BENCHMARKS
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS THE
FUTURE. THIS IS A FUTURE
CORRECTIONS AND I SAID I KNOW
IT'S JUST AN ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
BUT IT HAD IMPLICATIONS DATA
FAR EXTEND. JUST WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO THAT COULD- CHANGE THE WAY
WE DO CORRECTIONS SIR FOR THE
FOR THE NEXT CENTURY. SO OUT OF
THE IF WE DON'T DO ANYTHING. WE
NEED TO DO THIS. THANK YOU- I
DO APPRECIATE WITH A
SCANDINAVIAN COUNTRIES ARE
DOING OUT THERE AND- THAT'S
EXCITING THAT YOU TOOK THAT
TRIP OUT THERE. IT ALSO LOOK AT
THE PATERNITY LEAVE THAT OUT IN
THE SCANDINAVIAN COUNTRIES IT'S
SO. MUCH MORE GENEROUS WITH
THIS WE ARE REPLICATING TO US
SOME OF THEIR PRODUCTS PROGRAM
FELT THIS WAY. THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE COULD OCCUR THAT TO
THE GOVERNOR FOR ME. WE WILL I
SEE YOU GOT AHEAD OF ME ON
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE ON TO ADAM THANK YOU
TWELVE- BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALREADY COVERED ITEM
NINE AND ALEJO SAID THEY HAD NO
CONCERNS IT WILL ACTUALLY MOVE
ON TO. TEN THROUGH. TWELVE
THANK YOU MOVING OUT TO ITEM
TEN I JUST NEED TO BE A PART IN
A FINANCE THIS REQUEST IS FOR
THREE POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND AND TWENTY ONE. THREE
POSITIONS I'M GOING TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. I THIS
IS INTENDED TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF BOARD COMMISSIONERS
FROM THE SEVENTEENTH. THROUGH
THE TWENTY. BY TWENTY ONE AND
THAT. PROVIDE ADDITIONAL STAFF
OF THAT BACKLOG PRO HEARING
CENTER AND- RESULT OF SEVERAL
FACTORS INCLUDING RECENT
LEGISLATION TO EXPAND THE
NUMBER OF ELDERLY PAROLE
INMATES ELIGIBLE- AS WELL AS
THE NUMBER THAT'S FINE THAT'S
THE CURRENT ACCOUNT OR TWENTY
TWENTY THE COMPANY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC I JUST ALSO INCLUDES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW
FOR THE PHD CONDUCT TOP.
BROKERAGES BY VIDEOCONFERENCE
CONTINUALLY AT ELEVEN EIGHT
SENDING HEARING NOTICES TO
SENTENCING JUDGES AND CRAP IF
YOU TECHNICAL INSECURITIES AN
EXISTING RECORDS TO THE
PERIPHERAL. CARE ACT. NO ONE
CONCERNS ON THIS FOR. HI THIS
IS MICHAEL QUESTION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MOVING ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN ST BY
TELECINCO TREE PROGRAM
SUPERVISION. THIS PROPOSAL IS
FOR THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS A GENERAL HUNDRED NINE
POSITIONS ON GOING. FORGET IT
TELESAT WITH MANAGEMENT TO
PROVIDE THREE OVERSIGHT.
CURRENTLY TELECHECK HYDRANTS IN
THE PROGRAM ARE MANAGED BY ON
SITE SUPERVISORS WHICH REQUIRES
THE REDIRECTION OF THE
SUPERVISORY POSITIONS FROM
THEIR EXISTING DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES IN SUPPORT OF
ON SITE STAFF. ADDITIONALLY THE
STRUCTURE IS NOT RECOGNIZE THE
UNIQUE OPERATIONAL FUNCTIONS OF
TELUS PSYCHIATRY SO THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD ADD DEDICATED
TELE PSYCHIATRY SHE PROVIDERS
TO ENHANCE PROGRAM OPERATIONS
AND PROVIDE FOR IMPROVED
SERVICE DELIVERY. THE REASON
WHY ON STAGE YOU PROVIDERS ARE
BEING USED AT THIS TIME IS
BECAUSE WHEN THE MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS TWO THOUSAND NINE
STAFFING PLAN WAS CREATED IN
COURT APPROVED THE PROGRAM DID
NOT EXIST ANYWHERE NO. I. TELL
A SECOND TWO SUPERVISORS. THIS
STATEWIDE LISTEN THANK YOU FOR
IS HELPING SURE MACHINE THE COR
MAN 9% FILL RATE FOR PSYCH. AND
CONTINUED REDIRECTION OF ONSITE
POSITIONS IS NOT SUSTAINABLE
AND THREATENS THE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT THE STATE BY A PROGRAM HAS
MADE OVER THE YEARS. HAVING TO
ANSWER ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
NO ELEGANCE OR SOME THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. OKAY MOVING
ON TO- ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
PSYCHIATRIC INPATIENT PROGRAM
STANDARDIZATION AND
INTEGRATION. THIS REQUEST IS
FOR THIRTY SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
THE BUDGET YEAR AND THIRTY FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ON GOING A BUDGET
YOU'RE WANTING NINE GOING IN
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE POINT
FOUR POSITIONS AND ALL YEARS TO
STANDARDIZE STAFFORD MODELS
ACROSS THE FIVE SHE SHE ARE
OPERATING IT'S AN TO SUPPORT
TARGETED STAFFING INCREASES.
FOR PERFORMING OPERATIONALLY
CRITICAL FUNCTIONS. WHEN THE
WHEN IT WHEN IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THREE TIPS
ST PATRICK INPATIENT PROGRAMS
ARE TRANSFERRED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
TO CDC ARE BUT THIS TRANSFER
WAS UNDERSTOOD AS BEING SIMPLY
A SHIFTING OF RESOURCES. ARE
FROM DISH TO SEE IF YOU ARE AND
THAT THE OPERATIONS ADDITIONAL
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT- IN
MANY WAYS FROM CDG ARE. I SO
THE PROPOSED WOULD FULLY
INTEGRATE THREE LIFT AND SHIFT
TRIPS WITHIN CITY OPERATIONS
AND BRING STAFFING INTO
ALIGNMENT ACROSS THE PITCH
BASED ON CONSISTENT METHODOLOGY
IT'S- HARD TO DISCUSS SPECIFICS
OF THIS PROPOSAL I WILL. BE
SURE TO PROBLEMS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM. BECAUSE ONE OF THE L.
A. O- IT'S FOR BOTH WE KIND OF
BROTHER DOES NOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT JUSTIFICATION IT
DEMONSTRATED THE NUMBER
REQUESTED POSITIONS IN THE
PROPOSAL OR THE INCREASING
STRESS LEVELS ARE NECESSARY FOR
EXAMPLE CITIES ARE NOT
DEMONSTRATED THE CURRENT
SERVICE LEVELS AND THAT PERHAPS
ARE NECESSARY NECESSARILY. I'M
IN A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON PATIENT
CARE IN ADDITION TO WHAT CITIES
ARE PATH INDICATED IT. ALREADY
HAS A VISION CAPACITY TO MEET
THE PROJECT THE NEEDS OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH POPULATION THE
PROPOSAL THIS IS A PRIVATE
DIGITAL TREATMENT CAPACITY AT
THE MOST. EXPENSIVE LEVEL OF
CARE. WELL WE ARE BUDGETS ARE
NOT APPROVED TO GO. UNLESS YOU
SEE ARE PROVIDE SUFFICIENT JUST.
WHETHER PROVIDE WROTE THE
PROPOSED TOPIC. AND A SURPLUS
THE PROPOSAL. OUR THINK YOU
APARTMENT FINANCE AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE MICHAEL IN. OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM I CBC ARE HERE
AND ABLE TO LAND THEIR
EXPERTISE I'M IF MEMBERS HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC. TO RESPOND TO THE
ALLEY OF COMMENTS THAT PROPOSAL
DOES INCLUDE QUITE DETAILED
BACKUP THAT THAT DESCRIBES THE
METHODOLOGIES FOR OUT ALL OF
THE POSITIONS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THIS REQUEST AND SO. WE'RE
HAPPY ABLE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL JUSTIFICATION I'VE
NEEDED TO SATISFY THE ALEJO'S
CONCERNS BUT THERE WAS
CERTAINLY A VERY DETAILED AND
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN- PROPOSED TO
JUSTIFY AND THE POSITIONS
REQUESTED HERE AND THAT NOT
ONLY COVERS. WHAT IS NEEDED TO
RECOGNIZE CDC ARE UNIQUE
OPERATIONAL NEEDS BECAUSE WE
JUST IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WHEN THAT THREE AND I
THINK YES THERE CAN BE SOME
PROGRAM FACILITIES WERE
TRANSFERRED FROM THE
<c.yellow>URISDICTION OF DEPARTMENT OF</c>
STATE HOSPITALS TO CCR IT WAS
UNDERSTOOD THAT DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS HAD. DIFFERENT
OPERATIONAL DIFFERENT
OPERATIONAL COMPONENTS I NEED
SPEND CDC ARE SO IT THIS POINT
THIS IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S TRAIN UP TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE- THE THREE
PEPS AND THAT WORK CAN SHIFTED
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS AS WELL AS THE TWO
PATHS THAT CDCR INITIATED
INDEPENDENTLY. AND ARE FULLY
STAFFED TO THE LEVEL THAT THEY
NEED TO MEET FEDERAL AND STATE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS AMONG
OTHER THINGS AND THE OTHER
THING I WOULD KNOW IS THAT
THAT'S THE ONLY IT WAS
RECOMMENDING THAT CDCR WOULD
HAVE TO SHOW NEGATIVE. IMPACTS
TO PATIENTS AS A RESULT OF AND
NOT HAVING THE STAFFING- WHICH
IS SOMEWHAT SHORT SIGHTED IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S OPINION
AND ULTIMATELY WOULD PUT-
CITIES DARKENED AT RISK OF
VARIOUS THINGS INCLUDING.
CORKED MANDATED REQUIREMENTS
WITH THAT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
HERE TO PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND EXPERTISE. CAN OUR
CDC COMMON ON THE- ELLOS. THAT
CDCR HAS AND AT A RATE HAS TO
BE OF TO MEET THE PROJECT THE
NEEDS OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
POPULATION AND IF SO HOW DO WE
JUSTIFY THIS ADDITIONAL COLORS
HERE. IT UP MATTER DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF STATEWIDE MENTAL
HEALTH- I SPEAK TO THAT WE HAVE
VARIOUS LEVELS OF CARE FOR THE
MOST SEVERELY ILL INMATES THAT
WE TREAT SO THERE ARE A- BEDS
INTERMEDIATE BAGS AND THEN
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS BEDS TO
ROUGHLY THE EQUIVALENT OF AN
EMERGENCY ROOM- AND- THAT'S
OFTEN WHERE WE'VE GOTTEN NEEDS
SOME CAPACITY IN SOME PARTS OF
ROOM- BUT WHAT WE'RE WHAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON IS FLEXING
THOSE BEDS TO TREAT. DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF CARE SO IF WE STAFF
THEM TO THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
CARE WE CAN USE THEM TO FILL UP
OR TO TAKE UP ANY SLACK YEAH
THAT'S NECESSARY IN THE OTHER
LEVELS OF CARE AS WELL WE'RE
WE'RE VERY FAMILIAR WITH THAT
YES AGE TO POP IN THE STATE
HOUSE. BILLS MODEL WE HAVE
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX BEDS
OVER THERE THAT WE SEND OUR
PATIENTS TO- AND WHEN THEIR
PATIENTS ARE TOO VIOLENT OR OR
OTHERWISE UNMANAGEABLE THE END
UP WITH US AND SO WE HAVE A
SYSTEM WHERE WE HAVE. OUR
OFFICERS CORRECTIONS OFFICERS
AND A LOT OF OTHER. THINGS THAT
THE IS IT JUST NOT ABLE TO
OFFER AS MISS YOU HAVE
MENTIONED- AND WE FEEL THAT
THIS IS THIS IS A. REALLY THAT
THE- NASA- CORRECTION TO. JUST
TO OUR- AND SO. NEED MENTIONED
THAT IT'S BOTH WE WOULD HAVE
MENTAL OF HEALTH STAFF AND
CUSTODY STAFF. WHAT IS THAT
BREAK DOWN IN THIS PROPOSAL.
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
STATEWIDE MENTAL HEALTH AND SO
THIS PROPOSAL DOES BREAK DOWN
IT MENTAL HEALTH KEY STEP
NURSING PIECE THAT CUSTODY
PEACE AND- ALL ALL OF THE OTHER
MISCELLANEOUS- ASPECTS THAT GO
INTO THIS. IS THERE A
PARTICULAR QUESTION I MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER OR COURT MY
COLLEAGUE DOING READER MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ANSWER. WHAT WHAT IT
LOOKS BECAUSE LOOK LIKE HOW
MANY STAFF I MEANING YOU MENTAL
HEALTH HOW MANY NURSES HAVE ANY
CUSTODY STAFF DOES THIS BE.
AFTER I WILL DEBT DEFERRED IT
TO A READER. HERE'S OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FISCAL. GOOD AFTERNOON
MANAGER FROM THE DETAILS OF THE
STAFFING ADJUSTMENTS ARE IN THE
PROPOSAL ARE YOU I COULD SHARE
THOSE AFTER THIS- AFTER THIS
HEARING TODAY. BEAR IN THERE I
WOULD BE A LITTLE DIFFICULT FOR
ME TO WALK TO EVERYONE OF THE
SPREAD- AS FAR AS THE- FLEXPAY
CONCERN- WE ADDED THOSE
POSITIONS AND- HAVE TO BE
TRANSPARENT THEIR NET ZERO
REQUEST BECAUSE THOSE POSITIONS
WERE APPROVED IN A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. MENTAL
HEALTH BED MANAGEMENT PROPOSAL
SO WE RECEIVE THOSE OPPOSE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR THE
FLEX BEDS AND THAT PROPOSAL AND
WE WANT TO BE TRANSPARENT AND
INCLUDE THOSE IN THE TOTAL
ALLOCATIONS. SO- THE FLEX BED-
STAFFING THAT'S IDENTIFIED IS
OFFSET WITH EXISTING AUTHORITY-
FOR THAT FLEXIBILITY JUSTIN.
AND THIS IS FROM ABOUT THAT
EXCEPT THE DIRECTOR SAY ABOUT
HEALTH JUST WANTED TO AB ONE
THING WHICH IS WE ALSO ARE
RUNNING. ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR BEDS FOR INPATIENT-
DAD ARE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
TAKEN DOWN- AT SOME POINT IN
THE FUTURE A HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO THOSE ARE UNLICENSED BY
CDPH THAT CALIFORNIA PART OF
PUBLIC HEALTH- AND A HUNDRED
AND TWELVE WITH THOSE THAT ARE-
LICENSE BUT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS TEMPORARY- IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS AND NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE CULLMAN COURT. SO WE
CONTINUE TO. PLAN FOR THE TOTAL
CAPACITY THAT WE EXPECT WE WILL
NEED OVER TIME TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT ALL OF THESE OTHER
FACTORS THAT ARE ARE ARE BEING
CHUCKLED AT THE SAME TIME. SO
IT IS THE- IT'S THAT YOU DIDN'T
MAKE. WE ARE FREE FOR USE THAT-
WE HAD VERY LITTLE TIME TO
REVIEW THAT WITHIN THESE
PROPOSALS- ARE AND WHAT WE DID
TO GET HAS INFORMATION KIND OF
SPREAD ALL OVER THE PLACE SO WE
CAN PIECE IT TOGETHER SO. I
WOULD APPRECIATE IF E CAN GET
THAT INFORMATION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE TO START TO MAKE YOUR
CASE HERE- IT IS A LITTLE
FRUSTRATING BUT YOU CAN'T PULL
UP YOUR SPREADSHEETS AND READ
THEM QUICKLY TO ME- BUT- I. YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE READY AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH THIS IS
DETAILS. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
OKAY- OKAY DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SEVENTH.
RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
WE'RE STILL IN THE SAME PANEL
WE HAVE ITEMS THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
AND FIFTEEN- AND SO WE COULD GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN THAT. PERFECT I
HAVE A FRIEND THE LEAD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. FOR ITEM
THIRTEEN THE STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION OF FIXED VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE CITIES ARE REQUEST
ONE TIME AND ONGOING RESOURCES
TO INSTALL FIX VIDEO CAMERAS.
ON A STATEWIDE BASIS IN ORDER
TO INTERDICT CONTRABAND AND
PROVIDE OBJECTIVE VIDEO
EVIDENCE- FOR VARIOUS INSTANCES
OF. NEFARIOUS CONDUCT WHICH ARE
CRITICAL CORE FUNCTIONS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
CITIES ARE REQUEST SEVEN
POSITIONS AND THIRTY SEVEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND. TO INSTALL THESE
VIDEO CAMERAS ASK FOR
INSTITUTIONS SALINAS VALLEY
STATE PRISON CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON SACRAMENTO. CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTION EMIL
CREEK STATE PRISON. AND SINCE
THE ADMINISTRATION WHAT THE
DEMONSTRATE ITS COMMITMENT TO A
STATEWIDE ROLLOUT. THIS IS WHY
THE REQUEST INCLUDES- RESOURCES
FOR TEN INSTITUTIONS IN BOTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR-
SPECIFICALLY- THOSE TWO YEARS
REQUEST TWENTY TWO POSITIONS AT
NINETY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND.
AND THE THIRTY FOUR POSITION
AND NINETY FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
RESPECTIVELY. AND WITHOUT HIGH
LEVEL OVERVIEW I WILL TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE ERIC
SWANSON AT CDC ARE IN CASE HE
HAS ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
THANKS THIS IS ERIC SWANSON ON
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES AT
CDCR. THIS PROPOSAL IS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST PRIORITIES FOR
DEPARTMENT AUDIO VISUAL
SURVEILLANCE AS INTEGRAL TO SEE
THIS YEAR'S ABILITY TO MONITOR
ACTIVITY WITHIN ITS-INSTITUTIONS. AND MAINTAIN A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION AND
STUFF. AFFECTED SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEMS HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
FACILITATE CONTRABAND
INTERDICTION INTERDICTION AND
SUPPORT ENQUIRIES AND
INVESTIGATIONS INTO ALLEGATIONS
OF STAFF AN INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUAL MISCONDUCT.THESE
SYSTEMS GENERALLY SERVE AS A
DETERRENT FOR IMPROPER OR
ILLICIT ACTIVITIES THEREBY
IMPROVING SAFETY AND ENHANCING
OPERATIONS WITHIN THE
INSTITUTIONS. PRETTY RECORDING
TECHNOLOGY CDCR TO CAPTURE AND
STORE AUDIO OR VIDEO EVIDENCE
IT PROVIDES EVIDENCE AND
TRANSPARENCY RESOLVING
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF%
MISCONDUCT. USE OF FORCE AND
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AS WELL AS
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF WRITER
INTRODUCTION AND POSSESSION OF
DRUGS AND CONTRABAND. HIGH
QUALITY VISUAL RECORDINGS OF
INCIDENTS SERVICE STRONG
EVIDENCE INVESTIGATIONS AS WELL
AS ADMINISTRATIVE CIVIL OR
CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS. EXISTENCE
OF VIDEO OR AUDIO EVIDENCE
IMPROVES THE INSTITUTION'S
ABILITY TO CONDUCT TO INCLUDE
INVESTIGATIONS COMPARED WITH
INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE RELIANT
SOLELY ON EYEWITNESS TESTIMONY.
IT ALSO ASSIST LIEUTENANTS OF
THE DISCIPLINARY PROCESS FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
SPECIFICALLY LIEUTENANTS CAN
USE VIDEO RECORDING TWO DECADES
RULES VIOLATION REPORTS VIDEO
RECORDING CAN ALSO ASSIST IN
FINDING LOST OR MISPLACED ITEMS
WHICH HELPS AVOID THE SHUTOUT
OF INSTITUTIONS PROGRAM. TO
SEARCH FOR THAT MATTER VOIGTS
EXTENDED LOCKDOWNS WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION. THIS IS NOT A NEW
TECHNOLOGY FOR US IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN CD STORE
INSTALLED ON AVS ASPIRIN. BUT
IT OUR SYSTEM WITH TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVEN HIGH DEFINITION
CAMERAS IN DESIGNATED HIGH
TRAFFIC THE BORDERS
CONGREGATION AREAS OF HIGH
DESERT STATE PRISON. THIS
SERVED AS A TECHNICAL PILOT
ENABLING CDCR TO TEST THE
VIABILITY OF OPERATING THIS
TYPE OF EQUIPMENT ON CDC OUR
NETWORK. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN CITIES HERE
RECEIVE FUNDING TO COMPLETE THE
VSS AT HIGH DESERT STATE PRISON
AND INSTALL IT AT CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S FACILITY.
THESE LOCATIONS WERE DETERMINED
TO HAVE AN IMMEDIATE NEED FOR A
THE SS BASED ON CRITERIA. SUCH
AS THE NUMBER OF VIOLENT
INCIDENTS. ARE THESE RESOURCES
AND COMPLEMENTARY FUNDING
INCLUDED IN A PROPOSAL THAT
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT IN A
MINUTE THE ARMSTRONG COURT
COMPLAINTS PROPOSAL. WILL BE
ABLE CDCR TO INSTALL FIX
SECURITY CAMERAS AT NINE TO TEN
INSTITUTIONS PER YEAR OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THIS TECHNOLOGY
WILL TRANSFORM SURVEILLANCE
ACROSS THE PRISON SYSTEM AND
GREATLY INCREASE CDC OUR
CAPACITY TO OPERATE SAFE
EFFECTIVE PRISONS. THANK YOU.
CAITLIN O'NEILL WITH THE L. A.
O. WE GENERALLY AGREE THAT THE
VIDEO SURVEILLANCE- IT SEEMS
REASONABLE TO EXPAND GIVEN THAT
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO PROVIDE
OBJECTIVE INFORMATION WITH
WHICH TO EVALUATE- ACT
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF
MISCONDUCT- WOULD HAVE BEEN OF
GREAT CONCERN RECENTLY MESSAGE
COMMITTEE TO WHERE- BUT WE ARE
GETTING THIS PROPOSAL ALONG
WITH- TWO OTHER. THAT WILL
DISCUSS WEEK- TAKES CDC
STATEWIDE WITH VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE ACCESS TO ALL
PRINT ALL STATER IN PRISONS
THAT ARE NOT. THE TWO SCHEDULED
TO BE CLOSED FOR THAT DON'T
ALREADY HAVE A VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE AND WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT INSTALLING
VIDEO OUT OF PRISON THAT IS
SUBSEQUENTLY CLOSED. AND WE
ALSO FIND THERE'S NO NEED TO
FUND THE INSTALLATION OF THE
TWENTY- PRISONS THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD FIND IN. OUR
EARS AT THIS TIME THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN COME BACK IN
JANUARY OF NEXT YEAR TO REQUEST
FUNDING FOR THOSE ADDITION
PRESENT AT THAT TIME AN ACT
THAT AT WHICH POINT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT HAVE GREATER
CLARITY ABOUT WHICH ADDITIONAL
PRISONS. MAY BE CLOSED IN THE
FUTURE. SO I'D ALSO MENTION
THAT THE PRISON THAT WHICH
THERE IS AN EXISTING. COURT
ORDER RELATED TO THE VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE WILL RECEIVE VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE- IN A SEPARATE BE
A SEPARATE PROPOSAL- THIRTIES
PROPOSED SEPARATELY- AND THAT
THIS PROPOSAL IF JUST THE FIRST
YEAR IS FUNDED WITH- WOULD
COVER. WHICH IS WHAT WE
RECOMMEND IT WOULD COVER AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR PRESENCE SO-
THE STATE WOULD HAVE A LOT OF
PRISONS THAT ARE SORT OF THE
HIGHEST MOST SERIOUS CONCERN-
THE DRIVE THE MOST SERIOUS
CONCERNS IT SEEMS TO BE SEEMS
TO BE REGARDING AT STAFF
MISCONDUCT ISSUES. SO IN SOME
WE RECOMMEND ONLY APPROVING THE
FUNDING FOR IT THOUGH IT'S FOR
PRISONS THAT ARE IDENTIFIED FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR- AND THEN
LETTING ADMINISTRATION COME
BACK. FOR FUTURE PRESIDENTS
POTENTIALLY. I THINK WOULD
DEPART OF FINDING. TO THE
MINISTRY PLAN DOES PROPOSE AT
FIND- INSTALLATION OF- FIXED AT
SECURITY CAMERAS OVERTHREE
YEARS SPECIFICALLY TO PROVIDE
THE FLEXIBILITY. I'M TO
DETERMINE WHICH PROJECTS ME
MOVE FORWARD IN WHICH YEARS AG
GIVEN THAT INFORMATION AND
POPULATION PROJECTIONS ARE
CHANGING IN ALMOST REAL TIME.
SO THERE IS FLEXIBILITY BUILT
INTO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO ACCOUNT FOR CHANGES
LIKE THAT I THE INVESTMENT HERE
IS TO CREATE CERTAINTY THAT
WORK WERE ROLLING THIS
TECHNOLOGY OUT ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS SO THAT. I SEE HERE IS
ABLE TO REALIZE THE BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH- A STEEP WIDE
ROLLOUT TAKEN IN COMBINATION
WITH COMPLEMENTARY EFFORTS. I
AM WE ALSO NO CERTAINTY OF
FUNDING IS HELPFUL FOR CDC ARE
IN BOTH THE PLANNING AND THE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS SEES AND SO
IT GIVES THEM SOME CERTAINTY TO
BE ABLE TO BE. PLANNING FOR THE
NEXT PROJECT THAT WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED AND- BEYOND THOSE
IDENTIFIED IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND THE MINISTRATION NOTES THAT
AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE HAVE.
HADN'T MENTIONED DURING THE
COURSE OF THIS HEARING THAT
THERE IS UNCERTAINTY REGARDING
POPULATION PROJECTIONS. AND
GIVEN THIS UNCERTAINTY AND IT
IT MAKES SENSE TO KIND OF MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS PLAN AB
HOLDING UP THIS DEPLOYMENT THAT
WOULD KIND OF BE COUNTER
INTUITIVE ARE CONTRARY. TO YOU
TIME. GOING TO EASIER TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT THIS PROPOSAL
STATEWIDE AND SAID THAT THE
BENEFIT OF US- OF COULD
INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY WOULD NOT BE FULLY
REALIZED AND THERE IS
FLEXIBILITY BUILT INTO OUR PLAN
AND WE'RE ABLE TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. AND. TO ADDRESS
THESE CONCERNS. OKAY THEY HAVE
ANY FRIENDS OR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE LOUIS NINE TO ISSUE
FOURTEEN THE ARMSTRONG COURT
COMPLIANCE CONTINUATION. SINCE
OUR REQUEST A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO POSITIONS AND EIGHTY POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO IN ORDER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO COMPLY WITH THE
RECENT MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
ARMSTRONG COURT ORDER- THE
COURT ORDERED THE START OF
INSTALL FIX VIDEO CAMERAS BODY
WORN CAMERAS. STAFFING FOR THE
ALLEGATION ENQUIRY MANAGEMENT
SECTION ALSO IT AIMS AN
ADDITIONAL SUPERVISORY STAFF
IN. EXACTLY LIKE A. B.
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ARMSTRONG COURT ORDER AND
CORRESPONDING BCP THAT FOCUS.
ON THE RICHARD J. DONOVAN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY. SO THE
CURRENT ORDER FROM MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- FOCUSES ON FIVE
INSTITUTIONS CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON CORCORAN SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FACILITY CALIFORNIANS
TUITION FOR WOMEN. KERN VALLEY
STATE PRISON AND THE REMAINING
YARDS AT CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISON LOS ANGELES COUNTY- TWO
OF WHICH WERE INCORPORATED IN
THE PREVIOUS QUARTER. AND AGAIN
WITH THAT HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE ERIC SWANSON FROM
CDCR FOR ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
THANK YOU YES SO- I WILL GO
OVER AND GET THE LIST OF
PRISONS THAT- THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST MENTIONED BUT
JUST. THIS COURT ORDER IS
RESPONDING TO A MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE U. S. DISTRICT
COURT- ORDER FROM THE NORTHERN
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA. WHICH
ORDERED CDC ARE TO DEVELOP A
PLAN TO IMPLEMENT REMEDIAL
MEASURES OF THE FIVE
INSTITUTIONS THAT WERE JUST
MENTIONED. I ALSO WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT OUR OUR STANDING
VIDEO OR AUDIO VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM ON WHICH WE
WILL INSTALL IT THESE. FIVE
PRISONS- BUT LET ME TALK ABOUT
THE THREE OTHER COMPONENTS OF
THIS A PROPOSAL. BY THE COURT
ORDERED AS YOU DESIRE TO BEGIN
USING BODY WORN CAMERAS FOR ALL
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER TO THE
FIVE INSTITUTIONS. WHO MAY
INTERACT WITH DISABLED
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS OF THE ORDER. THIS
FOLLOWS THE INTRODUCTION OF
BODY WORN CAMERAS AT R. J. D.
IN LATE JANUARY OF THIS YEAR.
PROFIL THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
AUTHORIZE DEPLOYMENT OF. TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED TO BE WORN A
BODY. BY CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
AND SERGEANTS PERSONAL. BOTH
THE STANDARD CAMERAS BODY
CAMERAS WALKOUT EAT EAT CDCR.
IN OUR CONTRABAND INTERDICTION
EFFORTS INVESTIGATION
SURROUNDING IN BEING ITS
INCIDENCE. AND ENHANCE OUR
STAFF ACCOUNTABILITY. THE THIRD
COMPONENT OF THE COURT ORDER-
PAST TO SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
SUPERVISORY STAFF BY POSTING
ADDITIONAL STAFF ARE VERY
WATCHES AT ALL FACILITIES THESE
FIVE PRISONS. THE STAFF WILL
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH NEWLY
ESTABLISHED GUIELINES POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES SOME OF THE
DUTIES INCLUDE TRAINING
PERSONNEL REVIEWING VIDEO
FOOTAGE CONDUCTING DAILY TOURS
OF HOUSING UNITS LEADING
INVESTIGATIONS OF ALLEGATIONS
GRIEVANCES BUT THEN I FIND
CORRECTIVE MEASURES. REPORTING
FINDINGS MONITORING APPROPRIATE
HOUSING OF INMATES INSURING
EQUAL ACCESS TO PROGRAMS
SERVICES AND ACTIVITIES.
FINALLY SIMILAR TO THE ORDER AT
RGD THE COURT ORDERED AN
EXPANSION OF THE ALLEGATION IN
COURT MANAGEMENT SECTION OR
EIGHTEENS IN ORDER TO REFORM
THE STAFF COMPLETE PROCESS OF
THE SELECTED PRISONS. WHAT ARE
THE STRENGTHS OF AMES IS IT'S
DISTINCT SEPARATION FROM CDCR
INSTITUTIONS TO MAINTAIN
OBJECTIVELY. OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS STAFF IN CHARGE OF
STAFF COMPLETE INCREASE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE NOT LOCATED
WITHIN INSTITUTIONS WHERE THEY
WOULD BE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
LOCAL BUYERS CITY INFLUENCE
FROM WORKING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE STAFF THEY INVESTIGATE.
THIS WOULD INCLUDE ALL
ALLEGATIONS OF UNNECESSARY
EXCESSIVE OR UNREPORTED
INSTANCES OF USE OF FORCE STAFF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST A
PROTECTED CLASS RETALIATION DUE
TO USE. OF THE STAFF COMPLAINT
PROCESS. I THINK THE YOUR
GENDER STRUCTURED WE'RE GOING
TO ABOUT OUR NEXT WHICH AND
AIMS BEFORE WE GET TO THE L. A-
SWIPING TO TURN IT OVER TO. AMY
MILLER. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- ANY
MILLER DIRECTOR FOR THE
DIVISION OF CORRECTIONAL POLICY
RESEARCH AN INTERNAL OVERSIGHT
WITH CDC ARE. I'D LIKE TO
DISCUSS THE OTHER PROPOSAL
MENTIONED WHICH IS SEVEN POINT
NINE MILLION. AND FORTY
POSITIONS IN TWENTY. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AN ON GOING TO
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE
INVESTIGATION PROCESS FOR THE
USE. OF FORCE AND PRESENT
WRINKLE IN THE NATION AFTER
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST STAFF.
CURRENTLY INQUIRIES INTO
ALLEGATIONS OF UNNECESSARY OR
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE AND
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT AND STAFF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OF INMATES ARE
CONDUCTED BY INSTITUTIONS
SUPERVISORY STAFF. TRAINED TO
COMPLETE THE INQUIRY IS. UNLESS
THERE IS ALREADY EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT THE ALLEGATION OR IN
THE CASE OF USE OF FORCE THERE
IS SERIOUS BODILY INJURY
DOCUMENTED. WHEN ASSIGNED THE
INSTITUTION STAFF ARE EXPECTED
TO COMPLETE THE IN CORY'S IN
ADDITION TO THE REGULARLY
ASSIGNED JOB DUTIES. REFERENCE
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THERE
WERE APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
ALLEGATIONS OF UNNECESSARY OR
EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE AND
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE. ALLEGATIONS OF
STAFF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT OR
STAFF SEXUAL HARASSMENT OF
INMATES SUBMITTED TO CDCR
OFFICIALS. AS MENTIONED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- WE RECEIVED
FUNDING TO ESTABLISH THE
ALLEGATION INCREMENTA
TRANSECTION BUT THE OFFICE OF
INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND THAT
SECTION WAS CREATED TO SUPPORT
THE GRIEVANCE AND APPEALS
PROCESS. BY PROVIDING
INDEPENDENT OBJECTIVE INCREASE
AND ALLEGATIONS MADE BY
INMATES. HOWEVER DUE TO THE
ROBUST INQUIRY PROCESSES AND
ONGOING MONITORING AND
OVERSIGHT THAT ALREADY EXISTED
FOR CREATE AND USE OF FORCE ON
THE CATIONS. CDC ARE EXCLUDED
THESE TYPES OF ALLEGATIONS FROM
GOING TO THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
pTHERE WAS ALREADY EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT THE ALLEGATION OR THE
USE OF FORCE RESULTED IN
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY. THIS
DECISION WAS MADE BECAUSE THE
EXISTING PROCESSES ALREADY
PROVIDED FOR SEVERAL LAYERS OF
REVIEW AND OVERSIGHT BOTH
INTERNALLY AS WELL AS
EXTERNALLY BY WAY. OF THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
CDCR DOES HOLY RECOGNIZE THE
SERIOUSNESS AND THE SENSITIVITY
THAT SURROUND THESE TYPES OF
ALLEGATIONS AND HOW TROUBLING
IT WOULD BE IF EVEN ONE OF
THESE ALLEGATIONS IS NOT
THOROUGHLY EXAMINED IN A FAIR
AND ETHICAL MANNER. CITIES ARE
ALSO KNOWS THE DEPARTMENT'S
CREDIBILITY DEPENDS ON THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT DEMONSTRATE
IN EVERY CASEAPPROPRIATE STEPS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO IDENTIFY.
CORRECT AND HOLD STAFF
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN MISCONDUCT IS
SUSTAINED. AS MENTIONED THE
OFFICE OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS AS
DISTINCTLY SEPARATE FROM CDCR
INSTITUTIONS IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN OBJECTIVELY INTO THE
INVESTIGATORY PROCESS. THIS
INTENTIONAL SEPARATION MAKES
INVESTIGATORS LESS SUSCEPTIBLE
TO BIAS AND INFLUENCE. MOVING
THE PROCESS FOR INVESTIGATING
ALLEGATIONS INVOLVING USE OF
FORCE STAFF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
THE STAFF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AGAINST INMATES TO THE OFFICE
OF INTERNAL AFFAIRS WILL
ENHANCE THE INVESTIGATION
PROCESS BY ENSURING THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE INVESTIGATED BY
STAFF. WHO ARE EXPERTS IN THE
INVESTIGATORY PROCESS AND WHOSE
SOLE JOB IS DOMESTICATE
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT.
I AM AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. NO NO
WITH THE L. A. L. AND MY
COMMENTS PERTAIN TO ELEMENTS OF
THE PACKAGE OF PROPOSALS THAT
YOU JUST HEARD ABOUT RELATED TO
STAFF MISCONDUCT ISSUES. THE
FIRST ELEMENT IS THE PROCESS
FOR HANDLING ANY EMPLOYEE
ALLEGATIONS OF STAFF MISCONDUCT
AND THE SECOND RELATES TO BODY
WORN CAMERAS SO MOVING INTO THE
FIRST- WE FIND THAT THE LEVEL
OF RESOURCES NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THE CHANGES- THE ENTIRE AS-
STAFF MISCONDUCT INVESTIGATION
PROCESS- AT THE END ISSUE HERE
IS HIGHLY UNCERTAIN-
SPECIFICALLY THE NUMBER OF
CASES THAT THE DEPARTMENT WILL
RECEIVE HER YEAR AS WELL AS THE
STAFF TIME. REQUIRED HER
INVESTIGATION- PER CASE IS VERY
UNCLEAR THIS IS BECAUSE THE
DETAILS OF THE PROCESS ARE
STILL SUBJECT TO NEGOTIATION-
AND I IN ONGOING LITIGATION.
THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT WERE
USED TO FORM THE BASIS OF THAT
WORKLOAD ESTIMATES FOR THE
PROPOSALS. CAME FROM YEARS IN
WHICH THE INMATE POPULATION WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN. IT
IS NOW AND IS PROJECTED TO BE.
I CDCR. HAS HAD THINK OF IN.
THE TIME CURRENT. IN FACT IT
INDICATES THAT- DRAMATICALLY
UNDERESTIMATED THE TIME IT
NEEDED IN ITS ORIGINAL NINETEEN
TWENTY B. C. P. FOR THIS
PROCESS. AND MOVE MORE OVERSEAS
HERE HAS REPORTED THAT IT'S
LOOKING FOR EFFICIENCIES TO
REDUCE STAFF TIME PER
INVESTIGATION SUCH AS USING
VIDEO CONFERENCE TO CONDUCT
INTERVIEWS RATHER THAN HAVING
STAFF TRAVEL TO INSTITUTIONS.
BUT- SO AGAIN THAT DAY IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT THOSE HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED ARE FACTORED INTO
THE TIME- THAT'S BEING BUDGETED
FOR HERE. AND FINALLY WITH THE
EXPANSION OF VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
SYSTEMS TO MORE AND MORE
PRESENTS WE WOULD EXPECT TO SEE
A TIME FOR INVESTIGATION GO
DOWN AS WELL BECAUSE IT SHOULD-
PROVIDES. MORE CLEAR EVIDENCE
WITH WHICH TO HANDLE THESE
INVESTIGATIONS. SO WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING BOTH THE TOTAL THE
NINETEEN MILLION AUGMENTATION
BEING REQUESTED THROUGH THIS
PACKAGE FOR THIS NEW PROCESS AS
WELL AS THE BASE NINE POINT
EIGHT MILLION I'M- FUNDING THAT
WAS APPROVED IN NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET. ON A TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM BASIS BECAUSE THIS WOULD
REQUIRE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND SUBMIT A NEW REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES FOR THAT- FOR THE
PROCESS. FOR THE PROGRAM AFTER
IT HAS DATA FROM ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING- THE PROCESS THAT
THE CURRENT PROCESSOR THE
PLANNED PROCESS- WHICH WILL
STRAIGHTEN ABLE IT'S MORE
ACCURATELY ASSESSES. REESE
NEEDS AND JUSTIFY THE TO THE
LETTER. AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT AND
THAT LED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REGULARLY ASSESS THEIR
DIFFERENT- RESEARCH NEEDS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AND COULDN'T.
COME BACK WITH A PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS THE FUNDING BUT THAT
WOULD BE- AT THEIR DISCRETION
AND THERE IS NO THAT SO. THE
LARGEST ALLOWING FOR THEM TO
HAVE THE OVERSIGHT DOESN'T
REALLY PROVIDE DOESN'T PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE WITH A
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OVER
RESOURCES FOR THIS- PROPOSAL
WHICH AND WHICH ARE HIGHLY
UNCERTAIN AT THIS TIME. S SOON
SO THAT IS AND THAT IS WHAT I
RECOMMEND. RECOMMENDATION IS
GEARED TOWARD TOWARD. THANK
YOU- AND THEN START MOVING ON
TO BODY CAMERAS MAKES THE
SECOND ELEMENT THAT I WANTED TO
BRING UP HERE- WE RECKON WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE FUNDING
BECAUSE THEY ARE REQUIRED TO
PRESENT TO A COURT ORDER. BUT
AND GIVEN TEACHER LIMITED
EXPERIENCE IMPLEMENTING BODY
WORN CAMERAS AND THE LIMITED
RESEARCH ON THEIR EFFECTIVENESS
AND LIMITED USE OF THEM IN
CORRECTIONAL SETTINGS.
NATIONWIDE WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE AN
EVALUATION OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF BODY WORN.
CAMERAS BY AN INDEPENDENT
RESEARCHER. THANK YOU. THIS IS
THANK YOU IT TO PART OF FINANCE
JUST WANNA RESPOND OF MY
COMMENTS TO THE FIRST TO SEE IF
THERE IS MONITORING. THE LADY
THIS YEAR AND THEY ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF COLLECTING DATA AND
GIVEN THAT THAT I CAN WRITE
THAT BODY WORN CAMERAS WERE
ROLLED OUT ON A PILOT BASIS
PURSUANT TO THE WORK ORDER AND
WE'RE OPEN TO DISCUSSIONS IN
TERMS OF HOW TO BEST PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE ADDITIONALLY I
WOULD NOTE AND WITH REGARD TO
THE ALLEGATION ENQUIRY
MANAGEMENT SECTION STAFFING THE
MINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT NAY
THAT LIMITED TERM RESOURCES
COULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS CRITICAL
PROGRAM AND IT IS DOUBTLESS
THAT RECRUITING FOR A LIMITED
TERM POSITION. AND IS I CAN BE
CHALLENGING AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS SET UP TO BE AS
SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE GIVEN
THAT THE CRITICAL ROLE AND
FUNCTION THAT PERFORMS- WITHIN
THE ORGANIZATION I'M IN WHICH
IS UNDERSCORE THAT THAT
IMPLEMENTATION YES- WE WANT TO
SET THIS PROGRAM UP TO BE AS
EFFECTIVE AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
IT'S ESSENTIAL BOTH TO MEETING
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE COURT
ORDER I'M AND AS WELL AS KIND
OF ADDRESSING CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN AT A PREVIOUS LEGISLATURE
I'M A CONVERSATIONS OR- THIS
YEAR AND THEN UP. ON GOING RE
WHICH NOTE VERY SAID DID NOT
THE OPERA TO PROGRAM STAFFING
LOW ARE AND POINT IN I'M AND
CITIES HAS NAY KIND OF
COMMITMENTS TO KEEP THE WHAT
INFORMED OF PROGRESS AS IT
RELATES TO THE M. PROGRAM AND
WE CONTINUE TO DO SO RICK OF
THE TIMES. I WHICH ARE AT
APPROVED. HI THANK THANK YOU
FOR THE I AM. HAVE A QUESTION A
THREE I HAVE A CALL PER- SO I
DO A PRE THAT FROM OUR OR YOUR
FROM NOW SEE THE THING R. HAS
BEEN WORKING TO IMPROVE- THEY
DIFFER. OF A THE STAFF PLANT
OUT THERE BUT- WE STILL. SOME
WORK TO DO. BOTH OUR COLLEAGUES
HERE AT AND OUR HOUSE WANT TO
MAKE WE HAVE SOME THAT'S-
OBJECTIVE OUT THERE AND WE DO
AS MUCH AS THEY CAN REMOVE THIS.
OF THE PROCESS IS JUST WITH
BIGGEST CONCERN. WITH THE PRICE
THAT WE HAD OUT THERE BIRTH
COMPLAINTS. SO DECIDED TO PUT
THAT OUT THERE- AND YOU JUST
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT AIM HERE.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE CITIES IS TO
BE HAVING EVERYTHING LOOKS OF
GREEN. I PROCESS BY THE OF THE
OF. IS THAT ACCURATE. THIS IS
NOT HERE TRYING TO FINANCE I
WANTED TO MAKE. I'M FROM SEATS
THAT WILL BE TO ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION. MATT AND- AMY MILLER
SO. IN THE ARMS COMPRO. THE AT
THE. HE MET BHASKAR THAT WE'RE
WORKING TO IS THAT ALL GRAY
WERE GO. THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS TO ESCROW NIT IN TO BE
REVIEWED TO IF IT MEETS
CRITERIA AS AND NOW OF STAFF.
WE ALSO COMMITTED IN A HERE
THAT THE WE WILL BE MOVED
FORWARD WITH MAKING THAT A
STATE WIDE PROCESS ALTHOUGH
WE'RE STILL OUT THE FOR THAT.
THANK YOU THAT IS ONE OF MY-
WITH OR NOT THIS BE STATE
WITNESS HER RECEIVED ARE
STARTING TO LOOK AT THE- AND
STILL. SO IT THE RATIONAL OF
THE WILL SEND EVERYTHING OUT
THERE IS THAT- STAFF IS.
SCREENING OUT BALLOT COME.
THAT'S CORRECT. AND SO IN DOING
THAT THE STILL DO TO THE A- OF
COURSE THE- FOR THE PROCESS.
THE V. I. IN MINTS THAT IS
BEING AREA THAT COME THE
SCREENING UNIT ACTUALLY BE THEY
WHERE THOSE ALLOCATE COME IN
AND THAT ARE ALL THE GRIEVANCE
WOULD COME AND THEN THEY WOULD
THAT. IS THIS SOMETHING THAT'S
ROUTE DOES INCLUDE ALLOCATE OF
STAFF IN NEEDS TO BACK TO
INSTANT TO BE ANSWERED OR IS
THIS SOMETHING THAT THAT
INCLUDE ALEC OF STAFF MISTER.
AND THEREFORE NEEDS TO BE
FORWARDED TO THE OFFICE
INTERNAL. SO THAT AIMS
CONTINUES TO ACCESS IT WOULD
JUST BE THE SECOND STP. THAT
WOULD THAT'S CORRECT MADAM
CHAIR. QUESTION FOR MICHAEL
MISTER JONES SAWYER. ACTUALLY
JUST ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK WILL A BENEFIT BOTH THE-
CDC ARE AND IT'S A- AN INMATE-
AND I HEARD A OF STAFF. S.
CONDUCT BUT I'VE I THINK HAVING
NOT VIDEO. AND BY CAMERA WILL
ALSO IS A- INMATE MISSED THAT
WE IDENTIFY. AND IN BE ABLE TO
SEE WHAT APPS HAPPENED. IN FACT
I WOULD LOVE HAVE EVERYONE NCDC
ARE HAVE CAN. AND THAT WE HAVE
SIX CAMERAS IN THE MOST OF-
MANNER. MY QUESTION IS A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN WE DO THESE ANALYSIS
ESPECIALLY WITH WITH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. WE NEVER LOOK AT COSTA
BOY. I NOTICED HARD TO THE CAP
BUT SOMETIMES A NOT- ONE
MISCONDUCT. MIGHT IN- LOCKDOWN.
SERVER REPORTS HAVE TO BE RE.
ON ON A STAFF. IT HAS TO IN SO.
IN ADDITION WITNESS NEED TO BE.
OUR INTERNAL AFFAIRS COULD BE
INVOLVED THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
COULD BE INVOLVED IF YOU COULD
GO OUT TO DEPARTMENT TO THE AG
STATE AG DOJ'S OFFICE IT COULD
BE A FEDERAL INVESTIGATION DOJ.
AND OF COURSE A GOOD BE SEVERAL.
AS OPPOSED TO US JUST GOING TO
THE CAMERA AND LOOKING AT THE
VIDEO AND THEN WE'RE DONE. AND
SO. I WE EVER THOUGHT ABOUT
CALCULATING THE COST OF
BOYKIN'S OF PUTTING THESE
CAMERAS AND BODY CAMERAS ON ON
INDIVIDUALS AND HOW MUCH MONEY
WE WOULD SAVE JUST ON ONE.
ALLEGATION WHETHER TRUE OR NOT
THE AMOUNT OF TIME AND EFFORT
WE PUT IN TO DOING THAT AND THE
FACT THAT WE COULD SAVE. SAVE
MONEY UP IN ADDITION I HAVE A
IN MY OTHER QUESTION IS I JUST
HAVE A- I HAVE A OF A- PROBLEM
WITH THE INTERNAL FAIR AFFAIRS
PROCESS YOU YOU MENTION
EVERYTHING GOING TO INTERNAL
AFFAIRS. AND I BELIEVE IT AFTER
IT LEAVES THERE GOES TOWARDS-
IT DOES THIS THIS PROCESS WILL
NOT GO TOWARDS. OKAY I GOT MY
QUESTION ANSWERED. THE L. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF I COULD
ASK THAT SO- IF IT IS TO TRY TO
BE IN A- OF STAFF MISCONDUCT IT
WOULD. GO TO THE OFFICE VENTURE
AFFAIR WHERE AND- WOULD BE
COMPLETED. AND THEN ONCE THAT
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETE IT
WOULD THEN BE ROUTED BACK TO
THE HIRING AUTHORITY AND SO IN
THE- EVENT THAT SET AN INMATE
ALLEGATION WOULD GO BACK TO THE
WARD AND- WHERE THE DISCIPLINE.
WOULD CONTINUE BUT THAT
INVESTIGATIVE REPORT WOULD BE
COMPLETE AND WOULD HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT HE HIRING
AUTHORITY NEEDS TO MAKE A
JUDGMENT. ABOUT THE ALLEGATIONS
IN THE REPORT. SHOPE WARDEN.
DON'T WANT THIS IN. TO GET OUT.
A MAIN GET OUT OF THE HIRING
ORGANIZATION. HOW IT GET TO THE
SET HAD TO GET BACK TO US THAT
THERE'S X. AMOUNT OF COMPLAINTS
GOING ON TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL PROCESS. THE THIRD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION ARE JUST
EMPLOYEE DISCIPLINE PROCESS IS
MONITORED BY THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL THEY'VE ALSO
BEEN GIVEN AUTHORITY- AND HAVE
A THIRTY TWO MONITOR ARE-
EMPLOYEE DISCIPLINE PROCESS SO
FROM THE POINT THAT IT'S
IDENTIFIED AS AN ALLEGATION OF
STAFF MISCONDUCT THROUGH THE
POINT. THAT ANY DISCIPLINE IS
TAKEN THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
OFFICE DOES HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO MONITOR THAT ENTIRE PROCESS.
CAPE WILL. I'M GAY MIXED
INFORMATION WILL WILL DIE CHECK
ON THAT AND THEN. ON THE COST
AVOIDANCE- BUT LET'S LET'S- IS
THAT HAS THAT BEEN NEVER
THOUGHT ABOUT PUTTING IN TO
JUSTIFY WHY WE NEED TO EXPAND
THIS BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE WE
NEED TO WE ACTUALLY NEED TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON EVERYTHING YOU
JUST SAID I'M JUST BE QUITE
FRANK WITH YOU AS FAR AS CAMPUS
CONCERNED AND SO UP IT SOUNDS
LIKE WE NEED TO GET SOME
JUSTIFICATION. TO DENY ONLY
FINANCE MAYBE THE L. A. O. OF-
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS AND HOW
COST EFFICIENT THIS WOULD BE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT HAVE WE EVEN
THOUGHT ABOUT DOING SOME
ANALYSIS LIKE THAT OR I THINK
SOMEONE SAID THEY WANTED THEY
WANTED ANALYSIS DONE WHAT WE
WE'VE BEEN DOING SO FAR WAS
DONOVAN OR OTHER PLACES. HOW DO
YOU HOW DO YOU QUANTIFY THAT OR
HOW DO YOU. PLAN TO MOVE. WITH
THESE EVALUATE. YES MEMBER-
THOSE ARE GOOD. I THINK IT'S-
ERIC'S WHY A AGAIN THE DID
DIRECTOR OF THE OF FOR SERVICE.
I THINK OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
BODY CAMERAS IS TOO NEW TO
QUANTIFY WHAT THE SAVINGS WILL
BE ALTHOUGH I THINK RATIONALLY
WOULD ACCEPT YOU WOULD- BELIEVE
THAT SAID THERE WOULD BE
SAVINGS THAT WOULD OCCUR IN
TERMS OF- THE A LENGTH OF
INVESTIGATIONS AND THAT KIND OF
THING WE STANDING CAMERAS WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
EXPERIENCE BOB WE ARE WE TRIED
IT ON A PILOT BASIS I DO AVE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM D. A. R. R.
MISTER SPEARMAN WHO CAN TALK A
LITTLE BIT HE HAS FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE OF SORT OF- SOME OF
THE- BENEFITS. OF THAT CAMERA
HAS BROUGHT CAMERAS ARE BROUGHT
IN TERMS OF BOB WHEN THERE'S AN
EXIT ON THE ARCTIC BE SOLVED A
LOT SOONER- THEN- AND THEN HE
SOAK I WILL TURN IT OVER TO CUT
OF GO THROUGH ROUTE. ASSEMBLY
WILL GO QUITE. THAT WAS MEANT A
LOT IN A- WORKS IN A BEEN A- OF
THE ACTUAL OFFENDER. A LOT OF
TIMES BAR MY STAFF ABOUT HIGH.
STATE PRISON SEEK TO PEOPLE AN
ALTAR. EMPIRE TO BODY WORK. OF
STAFFS TO OF. FIGHTING THEM
THERE IS. OUR RULES. REPORTS
AND YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
FIGHTING IS STAFFED THAT. IF
YOU'RE READING A BOOK AND
ANOTHER PERSON COMES UP AND
ATTACKS THEM. AND THAT PERSON'S
RIGHT TO DEFEND THEMSELVES. IN
A YOU KNOW- WE CAN MAKE SOME
INFORMED DECISIONS ON IS THAT
PARTY WITH THE VICTIM ISSUED A
RULES VIOLATION REPORT. ALSO
THAT IT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER-
BY MY COLLEAGUES JUST ONCE AND
THAT THE MEDICATIONS WHAT WE
THOUGHT SOMEBODY BROUGHT
SOMETHING AN INSTITUTION LIKE A
FLASHLIGHT OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT WHICH YOU KNOW AND I
THOUGHT THEY LOST IT. WE CAN
RUN BACK BY OF. AUDIO VIDEO
SURVEILLANCE EQUIPMENT. AND SEE
IF THE PERSON DIDN'T BRING IT
IN AND OUT AT THAT POINT
EMPLOYEES CALL IN OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS ONLY YOUR FLASHLIGHTS
DIDN'T APPEAR ON THE NIGHT
STAND WHERE IT IS. SO IT AVOID
US HAVING TO. IMPACT THE
PRESIDENT TO A MODIFIED PROGRAM
AFFECT REHABILITATIVE. PROGRAMS
FOR PEOPLE IN ARGUE NO. SCHOOL
ON THE SCHOOL COLLEGE OTHER
ACTIVITY GROUPS. IT HELPS THAT
WAY ALSO AGAIN AS YOU KNOW IT
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER YOU KNOW
BODY WORN CAMERAS IS A NEW TO
THE CORRECTIONS. OUR DEPARTMENT
AND IS A FEW DEPARTMENTS TO
HAVE BODY WORN CAMERAS PLACED A
NEW TECHNOLOGY. YES THE WE
THINK AS A BENEFIT OF ALLOWING
US TO LOOK AT THE SIX PRISONERS
THE FIVE NEW PRISONS AND R. J.
D. N A WE CAN DETERMINE HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY ARE. AND COULD
THEY SAVE US MONEY AND THOSE
KIND OF THINGS. BUT PRETTY MUCH
SO WE KNOW WE HAVE ALLEGATIONS
WHAT SOMEONE SAYS SOMETHINGS
SOMEONE SAID SOMETHING TO ME
PROVOKED HIM TO. BUY LET'S TALK
ABOUT. IT VENDOR SAYING ON A
STAFF MEMBER DIDN'T THAT. BOTH
WITH THE AUDIO BILLS OFFENSE
WE'RE GONNA BE TO HEAR EXACTLY
WHAT WAS SAID PRIOR TO
SOMETHING OCCURRING. SO CAN IS
THAT. STAGES WHAT WE TAKE THIS
AS A CHALLENGE WITH THESE. PER
TO LOOK THE IF. AND SEE DOES
BODY WORN CAMERAS COMPLEMENT
OUR FIX. VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS. OR IS IT SOMETHING ARE
FIT CAMERA. COVER THINGS FOR US
AND WE NEED BY CAMERAS WALKED
DETERMINE AS WE ADVISE WITH THE
USE OF THEM AND COUPLE YEAR.
OKAY I CAN HELP YOU GET THE
DONE COULD. IN AND JUST AN FYI.
THE AYE THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
OFFICE THOSE. UNDERFUNDED
PROBABLY ONLY HAVE THREE PEOPLE
O LOOK AT ALL THESE INTERNAL
INVESTIGATION. AFFAIRS
INVESTIGATIONS SO- THEY MAY NOT
BE- EQUIPPED RIGHT NOW UNLESS
WE GIVE THEM MORE RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO. HANDLE THE BY YOUR
BED THAT COMES IN SO- WE'VE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT THE
WHOLE. SLATE AND PLATE OF. THE
WAY WE HANDLE- STAFF AN INMATE
MISCONDUCT. THANK YOU. IT WILL.
MISTER LUCKY YEAH I JUST HAVE A
REALLY QUICK QUESTION ON THE-
THE POLICIES. RELATED TO- THESE
BODY CAMERAS AND FOR EXAMPLE
THE RETENTION. CIRCUMSTANCES
HOW LONG ARE WE GOING TO RETAIN
THE RECORDS OF- THESE THESE
CAMERAS AND WHO'S GONNA BE
RESPONSIBLE TO- TO RETAIN THEM
AND WHO WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
REVIEW THEM AND WHAT THE
PARAMETERS ARE FOR REVIEW. ARE
THOSE- POLICIES AVAILABLE TO US.
I WOULD TO FOR TO AYE TAMMY OR
WHEN YOU THEIR TAMMY. OKAY WHAT
I CAN SPEAK ON A- AT TAKE
MYSELF OFF ME I'M AS FAR AS THE
POLICIES- GO AROUND TRIGGERING
EVENTS WHEN THEY'RE VIEWED I'LL
LET MR SPEARMAN REFER TO THAT
I'M I'M CAME HERE WHEN AND
SECTION CHIEF- AND ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
TECHNOLOGIES FOR CONTRABAND.
INTERDICTION AND SAFETY
SOLUTIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. I'M WE ARE
RETAINING VIDEO ACCORDING TO WE
HAVE POLICY WHERE THERE IS A
NINETY DAY RETENTION POLICY FOR
ALL VIDEO I'M WHEN THERE IS A
pTHEN STORED FOR A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME. AND AS IT PERTAINS TO
THE COURT ORDER PROCESS- AND
THOSE EVENTS THAT ARE- THAT
INCLUDES- THE CLASS MEMBERS
THAT THAT VIDEO IS STORED-
INDEFINITELY. WE DO HAVE- A
COMPLEMENT OF I. T. STAFF- THAT
SUPPORT- LOCALLY PROVIDED ONE
CAMERAS- AND- THEY ALSO ASSIST
ON THE FIXED CAMERAS ALONG WITH
OUR PLANT OPERATIONS STAFF AND-
WE HAVE IT STAFF AT
HEADQUARTERS. I'M AND THEN
THERE IS ALSO. A COMPLEMENT OF
THE OUR CORRECTIONAL STAFF AT
THE INSTITUTIONS IN THE
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES UNIT-
THAT SUPPORT AND- EIGHT THE
INSTITUTION AND ITS EVALUATION
AND- EXTRACTED VIDEO OR-
STATING VIDEO. AND WHEN IT'S
NECESSARY AND. ALL THAT MR
SPEARMAN SPEAK TO THAT. SO IT
TRIGGERING EVENTS IT OUT SHE
WITH YOU IS A BUSINESS PLOY
USED FORCE- IF THERE'S A RIOT-
IF THERE'S A PRISON RAPE
ELIMINATION ACT ALLEGATIONS- IN
ABOUT PLOY MISCONDUCT. OR
MISCONDUCT THAT SOMEONE GETS
INJURED WE EVEN LOOK AT SOMEONE
SAYS THEY SLIPPED AND FELL LET
SOMEBODY GET INJURED WE CAN
LOOK AT THE CAMERAS AND SEE YOU
KNOW FOR WORKMAN'SCOMP
PURPOSES THERE. SO THAT'S WHAT
IT TAKES BY THE FACT WHEN
THERE'S AN INCIDENT INVOLVED
WERE STAFF USE FORCE EXPRESSLY
THEIR. WILL WRITE THEIR WRITTEN
REPORTS. AND IF THERE IS
CLARIFICATION ON THE USE OF
FORCE. OR AFTER DEPLOYS SUBMIT
AND SIGN IT TURN IN THEIR
REPORT TO THEIR SERGEANT AND
THEY WANT TO LOOK AT BODY WORN
CAMERA FOOTAGE OR THEY WANT TO
LOOK AT- YOU KNOW FIX CAMERA
FOOTAGE THEY CAN DO SO. UP SO
THAT'S KIND OF HOW THAT GOES
THERE IF THE OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS IS DOING AN
INVESTIGATION OF SOMEONE AMY
STUDENTS DURING IN
INVESTIGATION. AGAINST THE
WHARTON GET SOME OUTSIDE PERSON
SAYS SOMETHING IS HAPPENED
ABOUT ONE THAT WOULD BE A
TRIGGERING EVENT AND THEN WE
WILL GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
TIME FRAME OF WHAT THE PERSON
THAT THE ACTUAL. EVENT TOOK
PLACE FOR HIS ACTION REPORTABLE
INCIDENT PEOPLE WILL LOOK AT
THAT IN IT IT COULD BE USED AS
FAR AS YOU KNOW IN THE
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS IF AN
EMPLOYEE HAS BEEN FOUND. DO
SOMETHING INAPPROPRIATE OR IT
COULD EXONERATE SOMEBODY THAT
WHAT WAS ALLEGED BACK WHEN I
WAS AT HIGH DESERT BEFORE YEARS
UP THERE AND PROBABLY THE LAST
TWO AND A HALF I WAS AWARDED.
WE HAD BALK AT WE HAD THAT PAGE
CAMERAS A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE
MADE ALLEGATIONS AGAINSTMY
STAFF AND IT. IS A TRIGGERING
EVENT WE LOOKED INTO IT AND A
PERSONAL EXONERATING IN THAT
THAT DIDN'T TAKE PLACE AT ALL
AND THEN ON THE FLIP SIDE- I IS
A HIGHER GET THE WOULD HAVE
TAKEN ACTION OPEN TO INCLUDING
DISMISSING SOMEONE. WHO YOU
KNOW USED EXCESSIVE UNNECESSARY
USE OF FORCE AGAINST AN
OFFENDER AND I TOOK THE
APPROPRIATE ACTION AND BESIDES
WRITTEN REPORTS THAT THEY
SUBMITTED AND OTHER EMPLOYEES
ADMITTED I ALSO USED THE ERA.
FIXED A SURVEILLANCE CAMERA
FOOTAGE TO PROVE AND TO SHOW
YOU KNOW THEM FLOWY THERE
ATTORNEY AND TO SHOW ALSO
ADMINISTRATIVE. LAW JUDGE WHY
TOOK THE ACTION. OKAY MY LAST
QUESTION WOULD BE WHAT ARE THE
PARAMETER. BY WHICH OF THE CRY
OFFICE HAVE TO HAVE THE- BODY
CAMERAS ON. ARE THEY EVER
PERMITTED TO TURN THEM OFF. YES
THEY ARE GOING TO PERSON CHECKS
OUT THEIR CAMERA- THEY TURNER
CAMRON BUT OF COURSE IF
SOMEONE. WAS USING THE RESTROOM
THEY CAN TURN THE CAMERA OFF IF
SOMEBODY'S HAVING EMPLOYMENT
NEED- SOME TYPE OF- DIALOGUE
WITH THE SUPERVISOR OR IF
THEY'RE IN AN INTERNAL AFFAIRS
INTERVIEW THEY'LL BE DIRECTED
BY THE SPECIAL AGENT TO TURN
THE CAMERA OFF- IF SOMEONE'S
INVOLVED IN SOME TYPE OF LABOR
ORGANIZATION. DISCUSSION THOSE
TIMES WHEN A PERSON COULD TURN
A BODY WORN CAMERA OFF BUT
OTHER THAN THAT. PEOPLE SHOULD
KEEP THEIR CAMERAS ARE. OKAY
YOU ANSWER MY QUESTION SOMEONE
IN MOST CASES THEY ARE NOT ABLE
TO TURN THEM OFF UNLESS THAT
MAKES ONE OF THOSE.
CIRCUMSTANCES YOU JUST OUTLINED
LIKE. YOU KNOW OF COURSE
PERSONAL NEED NOT KIND OF THING.
THAT IS CORRECT AND WE HAVE
ACTUAL PROCEDURE ON IT AND
EVERYBODY'S BEEN TRAINED ON
THAT AT LEAST AT THE RICHARD J.
DONOVAN CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
IN SAN DIEGO WITH ACTIVATED
BODY WORN CAMERAS I THINK
JANUARY NINETEENTH. THEY'VE ALL
BEEN TRAINED IT'S ALSO A
PROCEDURE THAT'S OUT THERE FOR
ALL STAFF TO KNOW WHEN THEY CAN
AND CANNOT TURN THE CAMERAS ON.
SOMETHING I WORK IN ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT MRS- WHEN THEIR
KIDS WERE WORKING WITH THE
VENDOR TO LOOK AT SOME
SOFTWARE. JUST TO SEE BECAUSE
WE CAN'T. WHAT WE BARGAIN WITH
LABOR THAT WE CAN'T. LOOK AT
CAMERAS TO SUPERVISE THEM
THAT'S AGAINST YOU KNOW A LOT
ABOUT A MEMORANDUM
UNDERSTANDING. WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT TRYING TO PUT PIC
TRYING TO FIND SOME TYPE OF
REPORT TO SHOW. IF I CAMERA
SPOTS BEYOND ENACT WAS SAFE AND
GET EXAMPLE IF THE AVERAGE IS A
CAMERA SHOULD BE ON FOR WILL
SAY SIX HOURS AND TEN MINUTES A
DAY. BARRING SOMEONE USING THE
BATHROOM AND THOSE KIND OF
THINGS AND WE'RE LOOKING TO GET
SOME TYPE REPORTS WE CAN JUST
KIND OF WAS LOOKING TO SEE OKAY
THE AVERAGE FOR CAMERAS IS
THAT. SO IT'S A PRESS THE
CAMERA WAS ON PER HOUR AND TEN
MINUTES BUT YOU KNOW THE
EMPLOYEE WAS THERE FOR EIGHT
HOURS. THAT WE CANNOT ALLOW US
TO KIND OF LOOK TO SEE KIND OF
WHAT HAPPENED IT COULD BE THAT
THAT PERSON WENT HOME SICK. SO
AGAIN WE HAVE DIFFERENT WAYS OF
LOOKING. AT YOU KNOW WHEN THE
CAMERA SHOULD BE ON AND OFF.
AND MY LAST YOUR CALL. IF
UNDERSTOOD CORRECTLY THE
NATURAL TATIAN A RETENTION OF
THE RECORDED ACTIVITY IS NINETY
DAYS UNLESS THERE'S A
TRIGGERING EVENT. THAT IS
CORRECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THOSE QUESTIONS MR LACKEY-
I WOULD BE INTERESTED IN DOWN
THE ROAD ON THE DATA- THAT
FIRST TO LOOK AT. PEOPLE ARE
BEING TRAINED WHEN THEY SHOULD
AND SHOULDN'T TURN OFF THE
CAMERA THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY
CAN'T JUST TURN IT OFF IF THEY
WANT TO- AND FILL. I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN THE DIFFERENT
MECHANISMS THAT YOU HAVE
INCLUDING WHICH IS ASCRIBED TO
ENSURE THAT THAT THE ONLY TURN
THEM OFF WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THEY
REALLY NEED TO FOR PERSONAL
PURPOSES AND SO FORTH AND SO I
DO APPRECIATE THAT UPDATE. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS ON
THESE ITEMS. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO FACT NEGOTIATING
THAT INFORMATION ON THESE TWO
ITEMS AS YOU COULD TELL US A
LOT OF INTEREST FROM COMMITTEE
THERE WAS SO MUCH INTEREST I
SEE THAT WE SKIPPED I DON'T
FIFTEEN. FROM THIS PANEL AND SO
I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BUT IF WE
CAN ACTUALLY. HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AN ALLEY-
TALK ABOUT ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN.
FOUR SEVENTY FRIENDS OIL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OUR
SERVER ITEM FIFTEEN REPLACEMENT
OF A DAY OF ROOM AND COMMON
AREA FURNITURE TV STAR REQUEST
ONE TIME RESOURCES OF THIRTY
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND. IN
ORDER TO PURCHASE AND REPLACE
MODULAR FURNITURE- AGAIN FOR
DAY ARMS ARE COMMON AREAS- ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS. TICKETS ARE
RECOGNIZED IS THAT MUCH OF THE
FURNITURE INSIDE ITS
INSTITUTIONS THAT IS NOT
EXACTLY CONDUCIVE TO FOSTERING
A REHABILITATIVE ENVIRONMENT.
AND CHANGING THE FURNITURE IN
PLACES WHERE INCARCERATED
PEOPLE SPEND A MAJORITY OF
THEIR TIME INTO THEIR
PROGRAMMING IS A SENSIBLE FIRST
STEP TO A CHANGING THE
TRADITIONAL INSTITUTIONAL
SETTING. THE STAR WILL TARGETS
DAY ROOMS AND COMMON AREAS AND
AT NON DESIGNATED PROGRAMMING
FACILITIES PROGRESSIVE OR
POSITIVE PROGRAMMING FACILITIES
AND FEMALE FACILITIES. AND WITH
THAT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. DEGREE FROM OUR-
WITH THE L. A. M. ARE DATED
THIS PROPOSAL IS INTENDED TO
CREATE A PHYSICAL ENVIRONMENT
THAT'S MORE CONDUCIVE TO
REHABILITATION.HOWEVER
CONCLUDED IT IS TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE METHOD FOR FUTURE.
ATION FOR EXAMPLE I COULD FOCUS
ON INCLUDING ACCESS TO EVIDENCE
BASED REHABILITATION PROGRAM
FOR ALL INMATES I THANK PEOPLE
APPROVING THIS PROPOSAL WE
RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRE CDC ARE
REPORT ON WHETHER CLASS
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO PROVIDE
ALL INMATES WITH ACCESS TO
EVIDENCE BASED REHABILITATION
PROGRAM. IF THE DOCTOR CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT THIS IS THE
CASE THAT. WOULD BE. HARD IT
OTHERWISE IT MAY BE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE APPROACHES TO IMPROVE
THE DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO
MEET THE REHABILITATION NEEDS
OF INMATES. ROBIN BY FURNITURE.
THANK EBONY FRETBOARD TO PARK
OF FINANCE- I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO OFFER A QUICK RESPONSE. TO
THE L. A. O.'S CONCERNS.
OVERALL THE ADMINISTRATION
INTENDS FOR THE FURNITURE
CHANGES TO BE A COMPLIMENT TO
THE REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY OFFERED AT THE%
INSTITUTIONS. SO IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S I THIS IS A
REQUEST TO MAKE THAT
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING MORE
EFFECTIVE- AND THEN KEEP IN
MIND THAT SOME INDIVIDUALS MAY
NOT OPT INTO THESE
REHABILITATIVE OPPORTUNITIES-
CESAR DOES OFFER QUITE A ROBUST
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM. TO
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAS INCREASED SUBSTANTIALLY
OVER. THE PAST TWO FISCAL YEARS.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THAT I GUESS
AS- K. TWO PREVIOUS DISCUSSIONS
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT CHANGING
THE CULTURE AND- DOING BETTER
AND REHABILITATION AND LOOKING
AT AT THE NORWAY MODEL OF FOR
EXAMPLE I GUESS IT'S UST A
QUESTION THIS IS AN AND WHILE
THESE THINGS ARE COMPLIMENTARY
IT'S TO WE INVEST IN THIS NOW
OR IS THIS SOMETHING. THAT WE
SHOULD BE INVESTING IN FIRST OR
AT THE SAME TIME BEFORE WE DO
THIS FURNITURE PURCHASE. MISTER
LACKING I JUST HAVE A QUESTION
THIRTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
SEEMS LIKE A HECK OF A LOT OF
MONEY. FOR FURNITURE. I THINK
IT IS. YES THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS SEEMS LIKE A VERY BIG
PURCHASE FOR FURNITURE AND I'M
I'M JUST. TRYING TO GET A
LITTLE BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
THE JUSTIFICATION. OF FOR THAT
HIGH PRICE TAG AND I HEARD WHAT
YOU JUST SAID BUT DON'T WE GET
DESERVE A BIT MORE DETAIL. A
JUSTIFICATION FOR THAT- THAT
AMOUNT OF MONEY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION. BEAR OUR NUMBER OF
ROOMS THAT AND TABLES IN THESE
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE SO
THAT I KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE A BIG
NUMBER BUT IT DOES ADD UP
PRETTY QUICKLY EVEN THOUGH THE-
INDIVIDUAL UNITS MAY NOT BE.
THAT EXPENSIVE- BUT I'M ALSO
HAPPY TO DEFERRED TO ERIC'S
ONCE AND ACTIVISTS ARE HE MAYBE
MAYBE I COULD CLEAR BY MY
QUESTION. LAKE WHERE HOW DID
YOU ARRIVE AT THIS NUMBER. I
MEAN HOW MANY IS THIS JUST LIKE
A. A POCKET GAS. OR I'M I'M
JUST NOT TRYING TO GET SOME
MORE JUSTIFICATION AS TO HOW
YOU ARRIVED AT THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AND WHAT'S THAT
GONNA BY. YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THIS IS A ERIC SWANSON DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
FISCAL SERVICES. WE CAN PROVIDE
YOU AND YOUR STAFF A- SORT OF A
BREAKDOWN OF HOW WE GOT TO THAT
AMOUNT SAYS- MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MENTIONED IT IS THE NUMBER OF.
ROOMS WERE TRYING TO COVER AND
IT'S ACROSS- THIRTY TWO
INSTITUTIONS- SO IT DOES ADD UP
QUICKLY BUT FOR SURE WE CAN
BREAK DOWN FOR YOU HOW WE GOT
TO. GET TO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EVERY INSTITUTION SO. I MEAN
THAT'S A LOT OF FURNITURE
THAT'S A PRETTY HIGH QUALITY
FURNITURE LIVE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE SO. ALL I'M TRYING
TO GET IS A LITTLE- BETTER
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT THAT
PURCHASE MAY BE SO I CAN FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE. I THINK THE
REST OF THE PEOPLE WOULD FEEL A
LITTLE MORE COMFORTABLE FOR
THAT AS WELL. I DO APPRECIATE
THE QUICK MATH OF A MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A- PURPOSE AND FOR
SOME OF THESE ROOMS AND SO I DO
THINK THAT THAT RAISE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION- AS WELL
IN ADDITION TO YEAH YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE PARA TASTING AND IN
THIS PROCESS OF TRYING TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE BUT- THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUICK MATHA. I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND SO WILL
LEAD TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO US THAT DOWN THE
ROAD AS SOON AS POSSIBLE- WITH
THAT WE HAVENO MORE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS
PANEL. AND SO WE WILL MOVE ON
TO PANEL NUMBER EIGHT. LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY. IT EVENING JUST
NAME AND ARE GONNA FINANCE THAT
FIRST REQUEST AND LOCAL PUBLIC
SAFETY IS. AT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. EIGHT CALIFORNIA
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAM
THIS PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED IN
CHAPTER SEVEN THIRTY FIVE
STATUTES OF TWENTY NINETEEN. IN
THE PURPOSE WAS TO BRING PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY BY SUPPORTING
EFFECTIVE PILOTS PRODUCTION
EACH YEAR IN COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY VIOLENCE A PARTICULAR GROUP
NUMBER INVOLVED HOMICIDE
SHOOTING AN AGGRAVATED ASSAULT.
AT THIS PROPOSAL AGAIN WITH AT
SIXTY SEVEN BILLION IN BUDGET
YEAR SIXTY SIX MILLION IN THE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS- AND EXPAND
ENCUMBRANCE AND EXPENDITURE- IN
THIS. BUDGET BILL I DON'T GO
OUT YES YOU SEE THE FOLDER
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS TO
RUN ANOTHER. GRANT PARK CYCLE.
AUTHOR THERE'S OFF THE TRAILER
BILLING THAT SPECIFIES THAT
PRIORITY SHOULD BE GIVEN TO-
AFFECTED YOU PROGRAMS. IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN CITIES THAT
APPLY FOR THESE GRANTS AND IT
WOULD INCREASE THE AMOUNT
AVAILABLE ACROSS THE GRAPHICS
CYCLE FROM ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO SIX MILLION. NOELIA
CONCERNS ON THIS PROPOSAL.
NUMBER TWO IS AN INCREASE- THAT
INCLUDES A THREE POINT SIX
BILLION FOR A GENERAL FUND FOR
A NUMBER OF INCREASES TO THE
POST RELEASE COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION POPULATION THIS IS
ASSOCIATED SPECIFICALLY WITH
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN AND THE
INCREASE IS ABOUT FOUR POINT
ONE BILLION GENERAL FUND OVER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROJECTION THIS IS LARGELY DUE
TO INCREASE CREDIT
OPPORTUNITIES- SEE SERVICE
RECENTLY PROBABLY. EARLIER DID
NOT RAISE CONCERNS ON THIS BUT-
ALL. FRIEDMAN WROTE IN HER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WILL BE
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER THREE
THIS PROPOSAL IS FOR STATUTORY
CHANGES TO DECREASE THE LEASE
REVENUE AUTHORITY FOR COUNTY
JAIL CONSTRUCTION PROGRAMS BY
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
FIFTY NINE THOUSAND AS A RESULT
OF THE WARD RELINQUISHMENT FROM
FIVE COUNTIES FOR FOUR SEPARATE
FUNDING PROGRAMS AND ANIMAL.
AND AWARDED FUNDS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF ADULT LOCAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE FACILITIES
THIS PROPOSED ACTION WILL
ELIMINATE THE REMAINING AND
RELINQUISH MONTESSORI THE
COUNTY JAIL CONSTRUCTION
FINANCING PROGRAMS THE
STATUTORY REDUCTIONS AFFECT
FOUR SEPARATE COUNTY JAIL
FINANCING PROGRAMS THREE WITH
THE SEC OF THE PARTICIPATING
DARK DEPARTMENT AND ONE WITH
CDC AS- A STATE DEPARTMENT.
THERE IS ALSO A STEP BUT
RELATED ACTION. TO ALLOCATE
RESOURCES INSTEAD TO WORK
COMPETITIVE GRANTS QUALIFIED
COUNTY AND TRIBAL ENTITIES TO
ACQUIRE AND REYES AND
REHABILITATE REAL ESTATE
ASSETS. THAT EXPAND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TREATMENT RESOURCES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS. OR DEEMED INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL ON A FELONY
CHARGE. THIS SEPARATE ISSUE WAS
PROPOSED FOR RUBIO AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FINANCE LETTER. AND
NOT RAISE CONCERNS ON THIS
REDUCTION OF THE OF THE THIRTY.
I THANK YOU I DO APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THE MULTI YEAR
FUNDING FOR THE VIOLENCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM. WE'VE
SEEN- CONTINUOUSLY IN THE NEWS-
THE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS AND OTHER
ISSUES OUT THERE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE DEALING WITH AN-
I WILL SAY I RUN A ANNUAL HIGH
SCHOOL PROGRAM AND THE NUMBER
ONE ISSUE THAT COMES UP WITH
THE STUDENT COMES UP FROM MY
STUDENTS IS THE STRESS OF
LIVING UNDER THE THREAT. OF
ANOTHER SCHOOL SHOOTING OUT
THERE ON AND SO WE DO NEED TO
DO THE SEPARATE INVESTMENTS
AMONGST OTHER THINGS TO ENSURE
WE HAVE. NOT JUST A SAFER
COMMUNITY BUT SPACES WHERE
WHERE WE ARE ABLE TO FUNCTION
AND BE HEALTHY- MENTALLY AND
PHYSICALLY. I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON THE SIDE OF. OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU VANNETT WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
TO PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
WE'RE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENTS
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE. THE PHONE NUMBERS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE ON THE AGENDA
AND ALSO ON THE SCREEN OF YOUR
STREAMING THE HEARING. THE
NUMBER JUST IN CASE IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN IN THE ACCESS
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099 AND
A STAFF MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU.
WELL THINKER IS A POLICE TO
PROVIDE WRITTEN A PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AS WELL. WHICH CAN BE
SUBMITTED AT BUDGET SUB FIVE AT
A. S. M. DOT CA THAT BECAUSE
AND THAT IS ALSO LISTED ON THE
AGENDA. DO WE HAVE ANY- MEMBERS
FROM THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM.
RIGHT SCENE AND THEN WE WILL
OVE ON TO OUR PHONE OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE FOLLOWING FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. EACH PERSON HAS
UP TO ONE MINUTE FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENT. IF YOU FEEL LIKE TO
ASK PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND WE WILL GO TO A
LINE OF THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES SIR MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE CHERYL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY- WE ARE CALLING ABOUT
TWO ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TONIGHT
ONE IS THE FUNDING TO TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING. FOR
LEGAL AID AND THAT THE VICTIM.
COUNSELING LEGAL AID AND
COUNSELLING SERVICES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THAT AND WE'RE
HOPING THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE LEGISLATURE COULD EVEN
INCREASE THE FUNDING FOR. THE
SECOND ITEM THAT I WISH TO
COMMENT ON IS THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS PUT
FORTH AS AN AMNESTY PROGRAM FOR
PERSONS WHO HAVE ON EIGHT-
TRAFFIC- THAT- FROM UNDER EIGHT
TRAFFIC FINES AND FEES- WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- PUTTING FORTH
A PROPOSAL THE THIRD ACT. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT LAST WEEKEND-
THE SENATE BILL LMAO TESTIFIED
TO THE FACT THAT- THIRTY EIGHT
POINT SIX. BILLION DOLLARS IN
UNPAID TRAFFIC FINES AND FEES
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA SO MUCH
OF THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION AS
A GOOD GESTURE IT'S NOT GOING
TO GO VERY FAR IT REALLY
DOESN'T ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEMS THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE OUTLINED. EARLIER IN THE
HEARING WE WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS FUND AS A WAY TO TRY TO
REDUCE FIGHTING THE CIVIL
ASSESSMENT THIRTEEN AT THAT
EVERY DAY LET'S JUST WAVE THE
UNPAID FINE THE FEES THAT AND
THAT THAT NO ONE SEEMS TO BE
ABLE TO PAY. I JUST GOT OFF
PEOPLE. FAST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. DO YOU NEXT
SO BOTTOM LINE OF FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
PHANTASM BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA WE WERE HEARTENED TO
SEE REITERATION AND THEY
REVISED THE COMMITMENT TO MAKE
THE COURT HOLD FROM THE TRIGGER
CUTS IN CURRENT BLOCK HERE AS
WE'VE IN LAOS AND FURLOUGH DAYS
AS A RESULT OF BOTH OF THESE
BUDGET CUTS. AND THE FINE
COLLECTION REDUCTIONS EMANATING
FROM CO THAT WE WERE CONCERNED
HOWEVER ABOUT THEM AND CARRIED
OF BUDGET ON MEDICATIONS WHICH
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE MAIN
REVISED PARTICULARLY AS THEY
RELATE TO THE ABILITY OF THE
COURT THE FUNCTION POST
PANDEMIC. WE HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO INCREASE THE TRANSCRIPT
RATE KERR COURT REPORTERS AND
FUND THE HIRING OF COURT
REPORTERS FOR PURPOSES OF
COMPLYING WITH JAMESON BE DEATH
THAT WE ALSO WERE DISAPPOINTED
NOT TO SEE FUNDING FOR LAW
LIBRARY DEDICATED FUNDING FOR
SPECIALTY COURT. AND FUNDING
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS AND PUBLIC
DEFENDER OFFICES AND HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL CONTINUE
CONSIDERING THESE IMPORTANT
ITEMS WHILE WE CONCUR WITH THE
STATEMENTS MADE PREVIOUSLY BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM WESTERN
CENTER ON REGARDING THE AMOUNT
BEING TOO SMALL WE ARE FULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE AMNESTY
PROPOSAL FOR OLD FIND THAT
PARTICULARLY AS THE FUNDS COURT
WILL LOSE WILL BE BACK FELT.
THIS IS IMPERATIVE FOR COURT
OPERATIONS THAT SOME COURTS
RELY HEAVILY ON THE FUNDS FOR
STAFFING COSTS. FINALLY WERE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROPOSED
PRE TRIAL RELEASE PROGRAM
EXPANSION AND FUNDING
AUGMENTATION AND ALL THAT ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FUNDING FOR
LEGAL AID ALTHOUGH WE ONCE
AGAIN CONCUR WITH WESTERN
CENTER THAT WE HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL ENHANCE IT TO
THE TUNE OF AN ADDITIONAL.
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK AND
NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF ONE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
KAREN MEMBERS SCRIPTED THE BOOK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WANT TO
SPEAK TO THE PROPOSED ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
VICTIM SERVICES FUNDING DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE
INCLUDED IN MAYBE FIVE. MONDAY
IS CRITICALLY NEEDED TO ADDRESS
THE KLEINS IN THE FEDERAL- FOR
THE CONSERVATIVE PROGRAM
HOWEVER WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT SIGNIFICANTLY A THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD OF TIME. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE LARGER DOLLAR
AMOUNT WILL PROVIDE FOR GREATER
STABILITY AS THE FEDERAL
PROCESS FOR FIXING THE CAUSE OF
THE DECLINE IN FEDERAL FUNDING
IS LIKELY TAKE AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME OVER MULTIPLE
FISCAL YEAR. AND WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING SITUATION MAY FURTHER
DETERIORATE REQUIRING A GREATER
BACK WELL- I WILL ALSO ADD ON
THE THAT WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE THAT
SHOULD BE FEDERAL OUTLOOK
IMPROVED AT A GREATER SPEED
THAN ME IN COURT THAT HE- ANY
ADDITIONAL REVENUE THE STATE
HAS ALLOCATED YOU SPECTRUM
SERVICE AND- THEY HAVE OF THE
STATE THE PROGRAM. TO BE ABLE
TO AUGMENT THE IMPORTANT WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING THEIR
SURVIVORS OF VIOLENT CRIME
ANAHEIM GLAD THAT DEMAND. FOR
SERVICE IF. FIVE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE MAY REVISE AND
COURAGE BUDGET Q. FORWARD WITH
A HIRED AMOUNT- ALSO THAT WE
ARE DIFFICULT NOT TO BE AN
INVESTMENT IN PREVENTION OF
DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
AND ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONTINUE CONSIDERING
INVESTMENT IN THIS AREA OF LAW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
GO O LINE OF FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MICHELLE WELL
JUSTICE LA HI. ASK THAT THIS
BODY REJECT THE GOVERNOR ONE
HUNDRED FORTY BILLION PROPOSED
SPENDING ON PROBATION BY PRE
TRIAL PROGRAM. THE GOVERNOR AND
THE STATE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING ON AND SPENDING ON
BOTH THAT COMMUNITY BASED PRE
TRIAL SERVICES WHICH DO YOU
HAVE A PRUDENT RECORD OF
SUPPORTING AN INDIVIDUAL'S
RETURN TO COURT HERE AND
ADDRESSING THE ROOT CAUSES AND
CONSERVATION IT'S FISCALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE TO EXPAND PILOTS
BUT LACKS A PROVEN TRACK RECORD
OF EFFECTIVENESS QUALITY
REVIEW. AND LONGER TERM BENEFIT
ADDITIONALLY THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE IS A BASIC WEBSITE
PROVIDED BY OUR CONSTITUTION
AND THE BUDGET BY THREE O'CLOCK
THAT MANDATE THE GOVERNOR TO
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
PROPOSED SPENDING ON PROBATION
LEAD PRE TRIAL PROGRAM. IS
ANTITHETICAL TO THE FUNDAMENTAL
TENETS IN A SENSE AND THE WILL
OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS WHO
REJECTED PROP TWENTY FIVE THE
PILOT PROGRAMS ARE ESSENTIALLY
THE SAME AS THE SYSTEM PROPOSED
BY PROP TWENTY FIVE WHICH USED
A BIAS RISK RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOLS AND UNCHECKED POWER TO
PROBATION DEPARTMENT. LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUPERVISION OF
LEGALLY INNOCENT PEOPLE
COMPROMISES THEIR RIGHTS TO A
FAIR TRIAL AND PERPETUATED OVER
INCARCERATION AFTER THE BODY
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S ONE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION PROPOSED
SPENDING ON PROBATION BLOOD PRE
TRIAL. PROGRAMS ADDITIONALLY
BASED ON EVERYTHING THAT I'VE
HEARD TODAY I SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER AND I FULLY SUPPORT THE
CLOSING OF ALL PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA PRISON. SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND PEOPLE CURRENTLY CAJUN
CALIFORNIA ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
EARLY RELEASE EVERY SINGLE
DOLLAR DISCUSS TODAY SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED THROUGH. THAT LENS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ENEC SO I
OF THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK MY NAME HE
BACKED AWAY I'M WITH DIGNITY
AND POWER NOW AN ORGANIZATION
BASED HERE IN LOS ANGELES PART
OF THE CAREFIRST CALIFORNIA
COALITION. AND I WILL ALSO WANT
TO VOICE CONCERN OVER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR UP
SPENDING ON THE PROBATION THAT
PRE TRIAL TRIAL LET'S PUT UP BY
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HERE IN
LOS ANGELES WE WERE ONE OF THE
COUNTIES THAT RECEIVED THE
INITIAL FUNDING FOR THE PRE
TRIAL THAILAND. AND WHAT HAVE
BEEN INCREDIBLY CONCERNING IS
THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY AROUND
THE EFFICACY OF THE PRE TRIAL
PILOT WE ACTUALLY RECEIVED
INFORMATION FROM A PROBATION
DEPARTMENT THROUGH A PR A
REQUEST. AND WE THE RESULTS
WERE INCREDIBLY DISTURBING
UPWARDS OF 97% OF THOSE THAT
WERE RELEASED ON MISDEMEANORS
NOT FELONIES MISDEMEANOR
CHARGES WERE PLACED ON
ELECTRONIC MONITORING AND OUR
CONCERN IS THAT CONTINUING TO
FIND PROBATION DEPARTMENT
SUPERVISION OF BOOKS THAT ARE
LEGALLY INNOCENT LIKE THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER MENTIONED.
WILL ACTUALLY INCREASE THE USE
OF ELECTRONIC MONITORING WHICH
IS COSTLY FOR COUNTIES AND
COSTLY FOR THE INDIVIDUAL THAT
ARE PLACED ON ELECTRONIC
MONITORING WHAT WE REALLY NEED
FOR AN ALLEY COUNTY AND I WOULD
SAY ACROSS THE STATE IT'S
FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY BASED PRE
TRIAL SERVICES. ALREADY MODELS
IN THE STATE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY THAT ARE
USING A COMMUNITY BASED PRE
TRIAL SERVICES MODEL WITH MUCH
HIGHER EFFICACY RESULTS ARE
WHAT COMMUNITY MEMBERS NEED
ARCHITECT MESSAGE REMINDERS
TRANSPORTATION TO COURT CHILD
CARE THE VAST MAJORITY OF FOLKS
NEED THESE LIGHT TOUCH
SERVICES. BUT THE LONGER THE
THREE TOP FINALISTS ARE PUTTING
SUPERVISION IN THE HANDS OF
PROBATION OF LEGALLY INNOCENT
PEOPLE WERE ACTUALLY CREATING A
REVOLVING DOOR BACK INTO
INCARCERATIONS L. A. COUNTY IS
THE LARGEST JAIL SYSTEM IN THE
ENTIRE NATION AND WHAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING HERE IN L. A. COUNTY
IS A DIFFERENT MODEL BASED ON
ALTERNATIVES. TO INCARCERATION
BASED ON THE- COMMITTEE BASED
ON PER PROP FOR WITH THEIR BAY.
NEW AND CHARGE TO. THAT STATE
HAS YET INVEST IN TWELVE TO.
THE WAY OUR IS MOVING A I
REALLY ASK WITH TO CONSIDER A
LINE. WITH THE MORE.
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
VISION THAT RESPECT THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE OF.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL MANDATE AND
ALLOW FOR TRANSPARENCY. RIGHT
NOW THERE HAS BEEN NO
ASSESSMENT YET BY THE STATE
AROUND- THE EFFICACY OF THE
NEEDS PETROPOULOS NETWORK
INVESTING ANOTHER. A HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION AN EXTENSION ON
THE THIRTEENTH LIKE A STEP TOO
FAR TOO EARLY WE NEED THE
RESULTS OF THE PRE TRIAL PILOT
BEFORE ALLOCATING ANYMORE
DOLLARS TO EXPAND. A MEASURE
WHICH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ALREADY REJECTED- WE REJECTED
CROP TWENTY FIVE YOU REJECTED
IT BASED ON BY ITS RISK
ASSESSMENT INSTRUMENT WE
REJECTED ON THE BASIS OF THE
BASEST OF EXPANDING THEIR
POWER. AND FUNDING TO PROBATION
DEPARTMENT. BUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY SPOKEN
AND IT WILL BE ENVISIONED
SOMETHING. MORE PROTRACTED
SOMETHING THAT REALLY ALIGNED
WITH. THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT THE LINE OF WITH
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD EVENING NINE ACCORDING
AND BEEN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CART SACRAMENTO IS PART OF
THE CARE FOR COALITION I AFTER
THAT BODY REJECTS. THE GOVERNOR
OF A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED TO BE SPENT ON
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH PROBATION
MY PRE TRIAL PROGRAMS I
DISAGREED. THAT THE PILOTS HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL AND HAVING
MONITORED THE ONE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I DO NOT BELIEVE
PROBATION SHOULD BE TRUSTED
WITH LIBERTY BASED PRE TRIAL
REFORM. WE NEED A MODEL THAT
THE PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
AND WE HAD BETTER MDELS OF
OTHER CALLERS STATED LIKE
AFFECT PRE TRIAL. EVEN OUR
PUBLIC DEFENDERS PROGRAM.
SACRAMENTO I TELL ONE ONE CENTS
WOULD. THAT'S BEEN MADE. WE
WANT TO REINVEST DOLLARS FROM
THE BLOATED BUDGETS OF BOTH CDC
ARE IN PROBATION. IS A
COMMUNITY BASED AND NEED BASED
SYSTEM BUT ACTUALLY BREAK
CYCLES OF CRIMINALIZATION.
PROBATION AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
BEEN UNDER ITS TENTACLES OF A
VERY HARMFUL AND FIFTY THAT
TRAP PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO
SEND. IN QUIETER. WAYS FOR
LONGER PERIODS OF TIME. IT'S
GONNA BE HARD. AND ELECT
MONITORING PARTICULAR EXTREMELY
CONCERNING ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT
OF THE HUMPHREY DECISION THAT
BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL GET
CALIFORNIANS A FALSE CHOICE OF
EITHER. CASH BAIL OR PROBATION
CONTROL. THE PROBATION OUR
PROPOSAL OF ALSO IS AVAILABLE
TO THE WILL OF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS. PILOT FOR RESPONSE THAT
YOU CAN RECOGNIZE THAT STATES
HAVE FOUND THAT VOTERS NOT DOWN
APART TWENTY FIVE WE KNOCKED
DOWN AND THE USE OF BIAS BUT
GETS A- HOLD THAT BUT ALSO THE
UNCHECKED POWER. GIVEN TO
PROBATION DEPARTMENT SB TEN OR
PROP TWENTY FIVE FOR THE PILOT
MOTOR THAN THIRTEEN AFFECTING
COUNTIES 81% WHO HAD THESE
PROBATION LIKE PROGRAMS.
PROTECTED PROPERTY BY THE WAY
DEFINITELY WATCHABLE PRE TRIAL
FOR THE CENTER COMMUNITY BASED.
ON WHAT WE ARE SUPPOSED BY AS
ABI RICH. BUT WE ARE INTEGRAL
PARTS OF EUROPE ON ABILITY AND
LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
LAST TEN YEARS I'VE BEEN-
MONETARY YOU FOLLOWING PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE HEARING.
HARPSICHORDS RAPIDLY REDUCING
BEAR PROJECT CONTINUING DOWN
THE PATH RELATED TO PRESENT
CLOSER PARTICULARLY FOLLOWING
CURRENT PEOPLE PLAN FOR
PRESIDENT CLOSER I AGREE
THERE'S A LOT TO CONSIDER IN
CHOOSING WHICH CURRENTLY
PROPOSED FIRST. URBAN DEVELOP
YOUR BASS CRITERIA FOR THAT
SURVEYING THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT RIGHT
RECOMMENDED THE CLOSURE OF AT
LEAST TEN OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. SO INCLINED PLEASE DO
NOT EXPAND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
PROBATION PILOTS FORGET
ANYTHING ARCH ANYMORE FUNDING
WE DON'T NEED TO BUILD
COMMUNITY LIKE ATMOSPHERE
INSIDE PRESENCE. WE ARE LOVED
ONES BACK. IN THE COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ABOUT THE
LINE OF NINE YEAR LINE OPEN. I
DON'T REMEMBER THEIR NAY LONGER.
THE DIFFERENCE TO PREVENT GUN
BY THE THREAT FIVE TWO SEVEN
ONE L. A. ZERO ZERO ONE LIKE
HOW VIOLENT INNER- INTERVIEW
PREVENTION. WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S-
JIM OUT OF TWO HUNDRED BILLION
AFTER THREE YEARS AFTER THE
PROGRAM BUT WHAT AFTER
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERATION TO
ALLOCATE A HUNDRED FOURTEEN
MILLION. IN BUDGET YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO- TESTS ON THE
BACKLOG OF APPLICANTS- OF
PROGRAM APPLICANTS- AND
ESPECIALLY THERE'S BEEN A 46%
INCREASE IN GUN VIOLENCE- IN
MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES
STATEWIDE- FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEN- WE ARE
ALSO. REQUESTING REDUCTION. IN
THE MATCH OBLIGATION AND AN
INCREASE IN THE CURRENT GRANTEE
GRANT ALLOCATION THANK YOU. Q.
AN EXTROVERT SO LINE FORTY TWO
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CLAN BACK FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN THE DEBT FREE JUSTICE
COALITION. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSED
TO BE GIVEN TO THE COURT FOR
FEED THAT. IS THAT THAT IS
CURRENTLY ON COLLECTIBLE. IT
WOULD BE A BILL RECORDS BUT IT
WOULD NOT BE MEANINGFUL TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. WE'RE BURDENED
BY THE STREET IT'S A FRACTION
OF THE OVER EIGHT POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN OUTSTANDING
DEBT HANGING OVER FAMILIES. IT
WOULD DO NOTHING TO STOP THE
ACCRUAL OF NEW GET MOVING
FORWARD. EVERYONE AGREED IT WAS
NEVER RIGHT TO BALANCE COURT
AND LOCAL BUDGETS. ON THE BACK
OF LOW INCOME FAMILIES OF COLOR.
WITH THE INFLUX OF FEDERAL
FUNDING IN THE HIGHER REVENUE
THAN EXPECTED NOW IS THE TIME
TO FIX THIS RACIST AND
REGRESSIVE POLICY. WE BELIEVE
THAT ALL OUTSTANDING TAX LEVIED
ON THOSE WHO ARE RATCHETING
CARTER YOU'RE PUT ON PROBATION
SHOULD BE FORGIVEN AND ALL THE
FEES REPEALED INCLUDING CIVIL
FAST. THE GREATER MILLION
SHOULD BE REDIRECTED TO THE
REPEAL OF CIVIL ASSESSMENT AND
GUESTS AT YOUR FEET AND
INCREDIBLY CLOSE TO. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
AVAILABLE LINE UP FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHEAP PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA- COMING
IN SUPPORT OF BEAT ME RATE
REVISION PROPOSAL- TO EXPAND
THE EXISTING JUDICIAL COUNCIL
PRE TRIAL PROGRAM TO MAKE IT A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM. AND SHE
STRONGLY SUPPORTED PRE TRIAL
SYSTEM THAT FOCUSES ON FIFTY.
NET EQUITY IN EFFECTIVENESS
PERSISTENT INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS
IN OUR COMMUNITY. IN LIGHT OF
THE HUMPHREY DECISION-
PROVIDING FUNDING THE COURTS TO
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE PRETRIAL
FRAMEWORK IS A VERY IMPORTANT
TIMELY AND REALLY HELPS.
MITIGATE THE DISPARITIES THAT
COULD OCCUR ABSENT A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM AS EIGHTY QUID STATED
EARLIER IN THE HEARING- IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THERE IS-
THERE'S NOT DESPERATE
APPLICATION OF THE PRE TRIAL
FRAMEWORKS. REALLY IN AN EFFORT
TO MAKE SURE AGAIN THAT THERE'S
EQUITY AND FAIRNESS- ACROSS THE
APPLICATION. OF THE PROGRAM SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I WE SUPPORT-
THE KNEE REVISION PROPOSAL- TO
EXPAND THIS PROGRAM STATEWIDE
IN CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
MORE. CONVERSATION IF I'M NEXT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WANT TO THANK THE
MODERATOR- FOR HER TIME AND ALL
OF. OUR PANELISTS AND- FOR THE
COMMON FOLKS AND- MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN HERE TO THIS MINISTER
TURNED.